I will now call the March 2020 meeting of the State Board of Education to order.
We will commence by saluting the flag.
Vice President Strouss, will you lead us in the Pledge of Allegiance.
Thank you.
There is one change in the agenda.
We intend to reopen SBE priorities item again tomorrow morning, just after the closed session.
There are two public hearings on our January agenda, items 14 and 15, which will be heard
tomorrow.
There is a handout on the table in the lobby identifying the proposed items on the consent
calendars.
The proposed regular consent items are items 10 through 13, and the proposed consent waiver
items are waiver 01 through 12.
I'd like to remind board members that any members wishing to remove any items from the
proposed consent calendars should advise Executive Director Karen Staff Walters by 11 o'clock
today.
We'll take up the waiver consent items this afternoon and the regular consent items tomorrow
morning.
In terms of public input, speakers should sign in at the table just outside the room.
Speakers are on the table with separate pages for each item number.
Signing in on the page that identifies the item number and what you would like to speak
will help ensure that we keep track of all the speakers for each particular item.
Item 16 is the general public comment item, during which members of the public may provide
comment on items that are not specifically listed in the board's agenda.
Public comment will be limited to one minute per speaker.
In order to ensure that everyone gets their one minute, there is a timer at the podium
that will flash a red signal to each speaker when the one minute time limit has been reached.
And now I'd like to invite State Superintendent Thurmond to provide the superintendent's
report.
Thank you, Madam President.
Welcome to our board meeting.
I'm happy to share with you that we recently recognized over 2,000 educators at the Distinguished
Schools Award.
This is from all across our districts who have made performance in many categories.
While we have many challenges in education, we have to start by acknowledging our successes
and where we are making progress, and it was an honor to celebrate 2,000 awardees.
Immediately on the heels of the Distinguished Schools Award celebration, we moved into a
first ever equity conference where 1,000 educators came together to talk about our main priority
at the California Department of Education, closing equity gaps and ensuring quality education
for all students, regardless of their background, regardless of their neighborhood, regardless
of their zip code.
And I want to commend our teams who brought together all of our federal programs, all
of our title programs, together under the banner of equity with great speakers and workshops
and professional development for all of our teams.
We are actively in a legislative cycle right now and budget season, continuing to work
off of the proposed budget that the governor has put forward for us in January.
Our teams have been active in working to process out and vet out some of the details of the
things that are in the budget.
Everything from the work really of our president on things like teacher recruitment and retention,
how we improve special education and how we augment students who are homeless, have been
impacted by trauma, who live in foster care.
By that I'm speaking about the community schools program.
And so our budget right now is being played out in the assembly and senate education budget
committees and the staff at the Department of Education have been active in providing
testimony on these bills, on these budget measures and on bills and have been working
closely with the Department of Finance to start to fine tune some of these proposals
and how they might look should they be enacted by the legislature and approved by the governor
in May and in June when the budget process is complete.
I'd like to talk with you about the thing that I suspect is on everyone's mind in America
and in our world, the coronavirus.
And I want you to know that California is leading as it relates to a strategy to address
the impacts of the coronavirus and how we as the experts say, bend the curve to address
the diagnoses, to address our response.
And California has an incredible response team of experts from the fields of public
health, from the office of emergency services and I want you to know that your team at
the California Department of Education has been helping to lead this conversation as
it relates to our 6 million students, our 10,000 schools and the family members and
the community members who are impacted by everything that you can imagine.
Every day we hear questions about closure and what should we do and when should closure
happen and we've worked with our schools and our counties to say our framework for
making those decisions is safety first, keeping our kids safe but we have to also balance
that for many.
School is the place where our students get a meal or as I'm reminded by some of our
superintendents, three meals a day and so the Department of Education has been working
with school districts that have closed to get the waivers that they need to provide
meals to students in alternative locations throughout the communities where these schools
have been closed.
I'm grateful to our team at the California Department of Education who this week helped
to co-convene a meeting with Governor Newsom and all 58 of our county superintendents to
build a structure for how to support our schools, our superintendents, our districts on everything
related to coronavirus.
Our framework has been the same, to make sure that we talk about these issues in the context
of local decision making, synchronized and coordinated with county public health departments
who are working with county superintendents but with the support of the California Department
of Education in helping to guide those decisions and yes, answering all the questions, the
number one question that everyone asks about is when can we close and how will we handle
the issues about attendance and can we do distance learning and I couldn't be more
proud of our team at the California Department of Education for leading this conversation,
working closely with our governor who is way out front on this, our governor has become
an expert himself in talking about the things that we need to be doing, about how we can
be smart and safe, how we can be calm and not reacting to rumor but facts but also taking
steps and measures that are proven to mitigate and to prevent when possible exposure for
our students and their families.
I'd like to ask a few of our staff who have been working directly, we have one of our
deputy superintendents is on a daily call with the governor's cabinet members, this
has been a 24-7 thing, I want to ask deputy superintendent Lisa Constancio if she would
please stand, she has been our point person and has been doing incredible work here, I
want to acknowledge her.
Working closely with her around coordination, around communication, she is single-handedly
taking calls from all thousands of our school districts, deputy superintendent Kendra Britt
who also has helped to lead this, I'd like to ask her to stand and be acknowledged.
Our new chief deputy who you will hear about just a little bit more later has also been
part of that coordination and I want to ask Dr. Stephanie Gregson to also stand and be
acknowledged.
In spite of the challenges that we must face as it relates to the coronavirus, we still
have our mission of educating all of our kids from rural communities and frontier communities
to urban communities to communities that are more impacted than others, we've got to make
sure that we continue to have conversations about equity and your California Department
of Education team has been at the forefront of these conversations.
I'd like to also acknowledge the staff of the State Board of Education for their work
and their guidance and for our State Board President Linda Darling-Hammond who also was
part of this convening of 58 county superintendents whose leadership and the leadership of the
State Board of Education has helped to provide guidance that we can provide to every district
in this state.
Now we can't answer every question that they're going to come up with, we cannot answer every
that they might fear or anticipate, but what we've done is we've built the structure for
how to work through it together, how to game plan through those systems together and so
again I'd like to acknowledge everyone at the State Board of Education and our chair
for our president for that work.
Now I know that there's probably no one in the room from the State Board of Education
but if you are, stand up, we'd like to applaud you as well.
State Board of Education staff, come on, you're in the room.
I was being, I was joking, I was a little sarcasm.
I want to talk to you about some of the staff that will be introduced to you today from
the California Department of Education.
You'll hear about Dr. Stephanie Gregson who is taking over as our new chief deputy superintendent
and if you don't know, she represents the first traditional educator in the role in
more than 20 years, someone who's been in a classroom, someone who's been an administrator
in a school, someone who's been an expert on literacy and has done a number of things
here at the Department of Education.
And so just a little bit later we'll say a little bit more about Dr. Gregson, but I want
you to meet some other folks here at the department who are in new roles and who are continuing
to provide excellence for the work that we are doing.
I'd like to reintroduce for you, those of you who have not yet had the opportunity to
meet Dr. Malvang.
Is Dr. Malvang here?
We want to congratulate Dr. Malvang.
She is our new director of assessment, development and administration division.
She brings a deep background in assessment.
She also comes from the classroom and from working in local districts.
She's been working here at CDE and is bringing a new passion to our leadership team as we
have incredible conversations about assessment in our schools.
Again, welcome to your new role, Dr. Malvang.
A lot of what we do with districts is have conversations about their fiscal challenges.
Let's be honest, their fiscal challenges are many.
Many of our school districts are seeing deficits that are 30, 40 and 50 million dollars.
Some of these are districts that have had strong fiscal controls for years.
They simply cannot keep up with the rising costs of education.
They simply cannot keep up with the costs of special education without more support
from the federal government and from the state.
They're dealing with rising costs related to pensions.
They're dealing with rising costs related to healthcare.
They're dealing with just about any scenario that you can imagine.
Like every single district in our state, they're dealing with declining enrollment.
Our districts face those challenges.
We work with them to understand how local control funding works.
We work with them when they experience power safety shutoffs or other crises that impact
their traditional funding of education.
We've got a new director who will oversee our School Fiscal Services Division to make
that happen.
She's no stranger to CDE as she's been working at CDE for 14 years in the School Fiscal Services
Division.
She will be continuing to lead us in that division.
I'd like you to please help me welcome Elizabeth Bierstein.
Is Elizabeth in the room?
Stand by.
She'll be prepared to answer all your questions about LCFF and the formulas.
She's been coaching me up on all kinds of formulas.
We are grateful to have her leadership.
We have so many incredible leaders that I want you to meet.
In this quarter, I commissioned a new ad hoc group.
I call it the Superintendent State Advisory Council.
We have some 15 superintendents from county offices, from districts, who are really thinking
through with us some of the big challenges of the day.
Many of them are leaders who come from districts who are recognized as bright spots, who found
ways to improve graduation rates, to increase performance for students of color and students
from low-income backgrounds and students who had other challenging experiences.
Some of them are from large districts.
Many of them are from small and rural districts.
Together we're going to continue to shoulder the load of making sure that we provide a
great quality education for our California students.
So for now, I'll submit this as my report and then come back to you when we have an
opportunity to speak in detail about our new Chief Deputy and swear her in.
Thank you, Madam President and members of the board.
Looking forward to that.
Thank you.
I want to just add my deepest appreciation to Tony and his team for all of the leadership
that they've exerted around the coronavirus events and the leadership that they will provide
as we go through this period of time together.
I also want to thank the principals and teachers and school nurses and counselors and librarians
and nutrition services workers and custodians and office managers, all of whom are going
to be working around the clock in a variety of new and different ways to help keep our
students safe, to ensure that their education proceeds during this period with a combination
of in-classroom learning and well-scrubbed classrooms, distance learning, independent
study, meal delivery, as the superintendent noted.
I know there are a lot of anxious students and parents out there.
I know our school staffs are doing the very best to maintain supportive learning environments.
And I thank all of those administrators and teachers who are dealing with many, many questions
and decisions around the virus and for keeping the lines of communication open and keeping
everyone informed.
I know our schools are in good hands, hands that are frequently washed for 20 seconds
at a time, and that accurate and timely information is our best antidote to anxiety.
Please check in with your colleagues, make sure that they're okay.
It's an anxious time for educators as well.
No hugs or handshakes, please.
We'll be demonstrating the new California greeting in just a few moments so that we
can all use it safely together.
I'd also like to announce, sadly, the departure of David Sapp, who you may recall was announced
as on leave.
He has now become, he was the Deputy Policy Director and Assistant Legal Counsel at the
State Board from January 2016 to February 2020, and he has accepted a position in the
Governor's Office of Legal Affairs.
Dave is responsible for a lot of the work that we enjoy and continue around the accountability
system.
He shepherded our ESSA state plan through to get the Department of Education's approval.
He helped establish the framework for our statewide system of support, as well as providing
legal support to the board.
And we want to recognize his contributions and thank him for those contributions at this
time.
I have a little certificate for you.
Thank you very much.
So I'm going to start by, just as one of the board members, trying to make a couple
of comments.
So Dave, you were with us for four years.
That's a really long time for us, and really, during some really important times.
I just want to say I can remember sitting in your office drawing pictures of the dashboard
on the wall as we started to think about how we were going to report our new accountability
system.
And you've been so involved intimately with all the details of the processes that we are
now fully implementing.
And I just want to personally thank you for your thoroughness, your thoughtfulness, always
responding, glad to follow up on emails, always willing to take a call.
And I just think you guided us through a lot in the four years you were with us.
And I'm excited for you for your next chapter, but hopefully you'll stay connected.
And we heard that you're definitely willing to be a tour guide in Napa if we're interested
in coming up to visit.
But I just want to personally thank you for the work that you gave in support of the staff
and the board during the last four years.
We're going to really miss you.
Thanks.
Any other comments?
All right.
I also.
Yes, go ahead.
Well, I was just going to add to the comment that another major project that Dave spearheaded
for the board was the ESSA plan.
And just going through that, having been the liaison to the plan, David, just balancing
the legal, the policies of California and the requirements at the federal level was
just amazing and really appreciated all you have done for us in that area.
So this is a time of arrivals and departures.
And we have two additional state board members whose terms have been completed to whom we
are enormously grateful.
We want to take this opportunity to thank state board members Ortiz-Lacon and Sandoval
for their years of service on this board.
In particular, I want to thank member Ortiz-Lacon for serving on the state board screening committee,
our liaison on English learner issues, liaison on two of the curriculum areas, including
the health framework and ethnic studies.
So yeah, right.
And finally, liaisons of the California Workforce Pathways Joint Advisory Committee and being
a passionate advocate for our students, particularly our students who are furthest from opportunity
in this state.
So thank you very much.
Let's take a moment and appreciate.
And then I'm also going to announce and then we'll go around and take recognitions.
Member Sandoval, Nikki Sandoval, for being our liaison on special education.
She covered the advisory committee on special education, two curriculum areas of history,
social science, visual and performing arts.
She's been our liaison to the summer school for the arts and also a passionate advocate
for students.
And her time has been immensely appreciated.
We will miss you both.
I want to welcome, before I give you your very fancy certificates, I would like to welcome
our colleagues to add their words of appreciation.
Well, so I just have to say, so let me start with Nikki says, I think it's seven years,
right, that you're completing your service.
And that's a long convoluted drive and flight from Lumpook.
I don't know if anyone realizes how, what it takes for Nikki to get here.
But I think it's a drive, a train, a couple of planes, and she makes it every time.
And I just have to say, Nikki has been, you've been consistent, you're thoughtful.
When you make comments, they really have, they're really important voice.
And the work in special ed and the work that you've done, it just has really been an important
voice here on the board.
And I just have to say, like, I just so appreciate getting a chance to work with you and getting
to know you.
Both of us lecture at the University of California, and I just have appreciated her collaboration
and as a colleague and just for being part of the team.
And for Felisa, like, your energy is amazing.
And I just have to say, I love her energy, her thoughtfulness.
She's busy traveling around the country doing her important work for her day job, and yet
always has time to take time, spend time getting into the agenda, really looking at the issues,
really thoughtful.
I've had the fortunate of Felisa's poke into my graduate class and has been such a model
for leadership and for improvement for students.
And I just, that hopefully, that we will be long term friends and colleagues.
But it's just been a really important voice, and I just so appreciate that you found time.
I know your family has wished you weren't always coming to Sacramento, but we just so
appreciate that you've been able to find time to do that, and I look forward to celebrating
with you guys soon, thanks.
Hello, I just wanted to thank both of you for serving as such a great example for young
students across California and specifically young women who are trying to get into leadership.
Both of your unique perspectives and the passion you bring definitely, I think, inspires a
lot of people to talk about the issues that really matter.
So thank you so much for the example that you've set for children across the state.
And I will open the floor if there's anybody from the public who wants to make any commentary.
All right, it's time.
Thank you very much.
I've had an opportunity to express my personal gratitude to individuals who I've been in
service with, and kakinalin, that means I am grateful to you, and I mean to my colleagues
here on the board, and also to our stakeholders.
You are such an important part of the work that we do, and I'm just so grateful to you.
I'm also grateful to the department staff, the state board staff.
I also want to shout out to the young people who come to every meeting.
I always worry, why aren't you in school?
But once that kind of wears off, I listen carefully, and I'm really touched by the testimony
that you offer about the impacts of our decisions on your lives.
So thank you for that.
And I also want to acknowledge the people whose warmth and support keeps things going.
They're the people that you see, you don't see.
They're behind the scenes, keeping the machine moving.
Lisa Hopkins, Malia Goncalves, Amy Bubbaco in the state board office.
You're fantastic, and thank you for all that you do.
I just wanted to publicly name and thank you.
And also our audio visual technicians, the people in the booth.
You don't know this, they're not only phenomenal technicians, but they're accomplished musicians.
Derrick, George, Clayton, Sasha, I just want to give you a big thanks.
And we're all here united for the good.
Your hearts are good.
Kakinush, and that in my language, the Somali language, means thank you.
Ditto to all of that.
And I just want to add, of course, you know, I've always used this as a platform to give
a message to those that support me and I support and to lift other voices.
But today I'm going to lift my own voice.
I started this journey five years ago.
And when I came in, I came in with six family members for two minutes wherein.
And I know that many of you remember that.
I followed that up with having 18 family and close friends for my Senate confirmation.
And I know that that sounded a little excessive, but not in the Latino community.
In the Latino community, we call that colectivismo, which is being part of the collective.
And this journey has always been of many for many.
So and I'm sorry, it is emotional because it is personal.
I want to acknowledge those that today my entourage is a lot smaller, but still powerful.
I want to acknowledge my cousin, Justice Miguel Marquez, who's here today with me, my best
friend, Jessica Guzman Green, who knows me since high school, ninth grade, to be exact,
and who serves the community as a clinical social worker.
My former colleague, Choco Leandro, who is a lifetime educator in Texas and nationally
with Unidos U.S. and her husband, Judge Bob Foster.
Thank you for being here today.
Thank you for being part of this journey.
I know that they bring the spirit of many who are not here physically today, including
my husband and my two kids.
I have to bring them to this space because as Eileen mentioned, sorry, Board Member Strauss,
I travel quite a bit for work.
I work for a civil rights Latino serving organization called Unidos U.S.
So we travel quite a bit and this appointment added about 15 trips or so a year to my schedule.
And there was times where my kids had a really hard time with that because I couldn't do
homework with them.
I couldn't tuck them into bed.
I couldn't read with them.
But one of the things that my husband and I have always told our kids is that this work
for us is part of our legacy.
My parents immigrated to this country to provide better opportunities for the kids and top
of list was a quality education.
So for me, this work has always been my lifetime mission and it will continue because it's
not bounded by an appointment.
It is the work that needs to continue because our students have not been fully served yet.
I look forward to working with all of you in this journey to make sure that equity
is tangible and actionable for our students.
I look forward to working with all of you and holding the friendships that I was able
to develop.
I came to Sacramento knowing no one except the entourage that came with me that day.
And I'm leaving with a lot of friendships.
So I want to thank the department, the state board staff, everyone that, all the AV guys,
they never brought that filter that I asked, but thank you.
I always tell them to put a little extra filter and they didn't.
But I want to thank them.
I want to thank the organizations, the advocates, the students that come before us because it
matters to them and it should matter to us as well as I know it will.
State Superintendent Tony Thurman, I want to lead your Latinx advisory council, which
I know you don't have.
I'm proposing it.
And I'm not proposing it that I lead it.
I believe California needs to be unapologetic about properly serving their Latino majority
students.
And I look forward.
Let's just make it so.
We'll do it.
Well, we're going to elbow on it.
We're going to elbow on it.
I'm going to leave you with a quote from a friend that I met through this work here in
Sacramento and she texted me and I've received a lot of outpour of support from folks as
they're learning that my appointment has come to an end.
And she said, Felisa, you are there to protect the trees.
You are the Lorax and our kids need you.
They are the trees.
So I'm going to leave you with a quote from Dr. Seuss and that book.
Unless someone like you cares a whole awful lot, nothing is going to get better.
It's not.
The work ahead is tough.
It has been my privilege and honor to serve the 6.2 million students of California and
their families.
And I look forward to collaborating with you in the work ahead.
Thank you.
I would just like to add that for both members Sandoval and Ortiz-Lacon, all of the liaison
work and committee work that you've done has been enormous, both in quantity and impact.
And both of these wonderful board members have offered to continue to help us.
We have specific ideas for that.
So I really, really appreciate the fact that you will be continuing to serve the 6.2 million
students of California.
So let's get some photos.
Thank you so much.
What a good start to the day.
Moving on to agenda item one.
Item one is the appointment of Stephanie Gregson to the Chief Deputy Superintendent of Public
Instruction.
The Department of Education recommends that we appoint a new Chief Deputy Superintendent
of Public Instruction in accordance with Article 9, Section 2.1 of the Constitution of the
State of California.
This item is presented by State Superintendent Thurmond.
You may begin.
Thank you Madam President and board members.
Today I represent to you Dr. Stephanie Gregson, who will serve as our new Chief Deputy Superintendent.
It is a very unique role.
It is, in my estimation, part educator, part administrator, and you have to have a kind
of political acumen to understand all the things that are happening around you.
Stephanie possesses all those skills.
As I mentioned, she is the first traditional educator to serve in the role as Chief Deputy
in more than two decades.
After spending 10 years as an elementary school teacher, after serving as a district coordinator
for reading and intervention, after serving as a director of curriculum and assessment,
she brings many, many relevant skills as an educator and as an administrator.
She has served at the California Department of Education for just about four years in
a number of roles, not the least of which is overseeing our work in the curriculum frameworks,
health frameworks, computer science standards.
Coming to the Department of Education, the thing that I probably underestimated as being
the biggest challenge are the conversations about what goes in our curricula.
We have seen the kind of difficulty and challenges that can come with that great opportunity,
and Stephanie has really been, I would say, tested in her ability to manage that and to
manage how we include the voice of all in our conversations about what goes in our curricula.
She will tell you someday about her superpower.
When she is not leading in education, she runs marathons.
She finds time to be a mom and a wife and to work with her family and a coach to two
great kids, two scholar-athletes who we get to hear often about and who you'll get to
meet today.
What I appreciate about Stephanie is that upon my arrival when she was serving as a
division director, she heard the call for us to do all we can to be a big agency that
delivers special touch to all of our students.
It's a special way that we do it, though.
We're not a local district, and so the work that we do has to be facilitative.
That means we have to be responsive to the needs of districts.
That means we have to look through the lens of what's best for students in everything
that we do, and Stephanie has that vision.
She has a vision for how we'll support all six million of our students as we support
our districts, as they become those that we serve, how we offer support and assistance
to them in addition to compliance and monitoring, in addition to all the things that have to
happen administratively behind the scenes for the California Department of Education.
At the end of the day, it is about ensuring great quality education for our educators.
She has a master's degree in educational leadership, a doctorate degree in curriculum instruction
and assessment, but more important, she has the heart, the passion, and the vision for
serving California kids, and I'm honored to have her serve as our partner, my partner
in the work in delivering for California's education.
I'm going to swear her in now, but I'd like to ask for her family members who are present
to come forward.
Today, she is joined by her parents, Stan and Diana Britt, her husband, Jeff Gregson,
and her two children, Nicholas and Madison Gregson.
Please welcome the Gregson and Britt family as they come forward for swearing in.
I think we have to vote on it first.
Just one moment.
Just kidding.
I move approval.
Yes, I move approval.
I second.
Thank you very much.
Any further discussion?
All in favor say aye.
Any opposed say nay.
Any abstentions?
Congratulations.
Come on up.
Thank you for the vote.
It's all over but the shouting.
Okay.
Please raise your right hand.
Aye.
State your name.
Do solemnly swear or affirm that I will support and defend the Constitution of the United
States and the Constitution of the State of California against all enemies, foreign and
domestic, that I will bear true faith and allegiance to the Constitution of the United
States and the Constitution of the State of California without any mental reservation
or purpose of evasion, and that I will well and faithfully discharge the duties upon which
I'm about to enter.
Congratulations.
Thank you.
I wouldn't be a teacher if I didn't have a few words to say.
When I started teaching in the 97-98 school year, I didn't even remotely understand the
magnitude of the work done at the state level.
I was solely focused on the 33 students in front of me and making sure I wore matching
shoes every day.
Yes, there's a story there.
I'm a strong believer of trusting the journey, but I never dreamed my journey would lead
me to this humbling opportunity.
I knew when I was in first grade that I wanted to be a teacher, and every step I made was
towards the goal of becoming a teacher that provided all my students an environment where
they could thrive under an umbrella of love, trust, and no barriers.
My journey has been shaped by several influencers.
First and foremost, my parents.
My parents taught me grit, perseverance, love, and kindness, each in their own way.
As the first college graduate in my family, their lessons were invaluable.
My husband, Jeff, and my children, Nicholas and Mattis, have filled my journey with true
and unconditional love, pride, and so much joy.
My best friend, Lisa, and my tribe brought authentic friendship and depth to my journey.
The students I have had the honor and privilege of serving over the years, whether it was
my classes of 33, schools of over 800, or a district of almost 10,000, they all gave
my journey the purpose of serving and supporting.
Thank you to all for shaping my journey in such a profound way.
This new role provides me with excitement and trepidation all at the same time.
I am excited to be working alongside a state superintendent who is willing to challenge
the status quo, ask the hard questions, have the courageous conversations, and disrupt
the systemic inequities to ensure all our students have the opportunity for success.
A superintendent who always puts students' interests first and ensures that it is the
lens and framework we use in making our decisions.
I have some apprehension only because I understand the magnitude of the work and the urgency
of which we need to act in supporting the adults and students in our educational system.
This is a time for healing and for breaking down the barriers, even if we built them ourselves,
that are impeding student-adult success.
As a teacher, principal, district, and state leader, I have always started my work by asking
what our students need from the adults so they can succeed.
I am so honored to take on this new role and the responsibility that comes with it.
You can all expect to see more collaboration among adults, organizations, and communities
that put our students at the center.
To provide every child in California with what we need, we will have to heal from past
wounds, create new agreements, and behave in new ways.
As chief deputy, I see my role as a lead learner, convener, and facilitator, ensuring all students
in California are well-known, well-cared for, and well-prepared for the future.
That will require all of us to work in new ways.
The California Department of Education is an amazing team that has an opportunity in
this moment of time to lead this work and to model how to support our counties, districts,
and schools in their work to helping all our students achieve and find their success.
I'm honored, humbled, and excited to be the first educator chief deputy in over 20 years
and lead the CDE with our state superintendent, Tony Thurman, in this work.
We will need all of us, as our education system will only thrive with collaboration and partnership
within our schools and agencies, between our schools and agencies, and with all of our partners.
It is with esteemed gratitude that I take on this new role and take the next step in
this journey I started 22 years ago.
I know that I'm not alone, as I'm on this journey with all of you and all of the children
and families of California, and I hold myself accountable to share in their successes and
challenges along the way.
Thank you so much.
Applause
Do you have a phone or do you want me to take it and send it to you?
Yeah, I'll send it to you.
Thank you.
Your family and your friends.
Hey, congratulations.
It's all downhill from here.
All these wonderful recognitions.
Now we've got to get down to the work, but I don't want the staff who are presenting
the Workforce Innovation and Opportunity Act item to feel underappreciated, so we do want
to bring them up for agenda item number two.
This is the Workforce Innovation and Opportunity Act item.
The CDE recommends that we approve the skills attainment for upward mobility, align services
for shared prosperity, workforce development plan for 2020 through 2023.
Under the Workforce Investment and Opportunity Act of 2014, this item will be presented by
Tim Rainey, Executive Director of the California Workforce Development Board, followed by Carolyn
Zachary, Administrator of the Adult Education Office at CDE.
So Tim, when you're ready, please begin.
I think it's okay.
You might want to pull it up close to your mouth.
Yeah, no.
Thank you.
Yeah, I thought I'd get it started off with a bang.
I embody it's downhill from here, so I'm happy to present.
It was an incredibly moving morning.
I'm so glad I got here on time.
Well, almost on time.
It was incredible to hear all of the personal stories and how connected everybody is to the
work that we're doing.
I was on my way downtown.
My daughter, she's taking me places these days because we're sharing a car.
And I'm late and I'm full of anxiety.
I'm always late.
And I'm practicing.
And she says, what are you doing, Dad?
And I said, I'm presenting to the State Board of Education.
And she said, that's impressive.
Thanks.
Glad we could do that for you.
And she said, because you dropped out of high school.
And I said, thanks for the pep talk, honey.
I appreciate that.
But I think it is impressive.
And thank you very much for this opportunity.
Fremont Adult School saved my life.
It gave me a chance to get back on my educational path.
And the community college system in California is the best in the world, as far as I know.
And it was a big part of my journey.
So I want to say to the kids in the room, because I think there are some, don't drop
out of high school.
It's not the easy path.
There are definitely easier ways to go.
I want to quickly acknowledge the fact that I spoke to the Workforce Pathways Joint Committee
just a few weeks ago.
And I want to apologize to Ting Sun, because she has to sit through my presentation a second
time.
And I know that's very difficult to do.
I also want to acknowledge that the Honorable Tony Thurman sits on the State Workforce
Development Board.
And he has to sit through it if he comes back a second time next week, because we present
to the State Workforce Development Board.
But if he doesn't come back, then he doesn't have to suffer through it a second time.
We're good to go.
I have a lot of content to move through, so I'm going to go pretty fast, because I want
to respect everybody's time.
I was last here in January 2015, I believe, presenting on the first State Strategic Workforce
Development Plan for the Workforce Innovation Opportunity Act.
And that plan was from 2017 to 2020.
So we're back with a brand new State Strategic Plan.
Only the second under the Workforce Innovation Opportunity Act.
Before I launch in, I wonder if it's  should I say something about the State Workforce
Board?
It might be helpful for folks in the room.
Then very briefly, the State Workforce Development Board is required of every state that receives
the Federal Workforce Innovation Opportunity Act money, which is every state.
We have a  by statutory requirement, federal statute, we have 51 percent business on our
board, a majority on the board.
We have a 43-person board, so it's wonderful to see you guys.
This is such a manageable size.
I don't know why anybody would have a 43-member board.
Fifty-one percent business majority, appointed by the governor, Governor Newsom.
Two members from the assembly and two members from the Senate that are appointed by legislative
leadership.
Community-based organizations, also appointed by the governor.
And at least 15 percent labor representation, labor organizations on the board.
That's actually by state statute, not by federal statute.
And then state partners.
All of the components of the workforce system, all of the departments and agencies that
represent the big investment in California are also on the State Workforce Development
Board by federal statute, but also by choice because we have a much broader representation
than required in the federal law.
And as I said, the superintendent is on the state board.
So now Patricia Rucker has to sit through my presentation two times, so I apologize
about that.
The State Workforce Board is primarily charged with the alignment of the workforce development
system in the state.
That's our main charge.
Under a single vision, among all the system components driven by the governor, but also
in collaboration with the state legislature, and common strategies.
And I'll talk about the vision and common strategies in a bit.
The intent is to make it more navigable.
It's a patchwork system.
It's difficult for workers and students to find their way through it.
And it's also difficult for businesses to navigate.
Businesses that need to find talent in a skilled workforce.
We need to get it aligned for that reason, but also to get scale and impact.
It's a big investment, but when it's patchwork like this, we don't get the kind of scale
and impact to really move employment in the state of California.
So that's our main charge, this alignment piece.
The vision and the strategies are expressed in the state strategic plan, which I'm sure
you read last night, because it's a real page-turner, and it's the one thing that
will keep you awake at night.
So ask any detailed questions you want to.
The draft plan was approved.
It's before you now.
I'll talk about it.
It was approved by our executive committee last week, and it's here for your review and
comment, and we'll take it to our full board next week, on Tuesday actually, for review
and approval, and then it goes to the governor for final approval, and then off to the U.S.
Department of Labor for their review.
And they usually kick it back to us, and we do a little back and forth with the federal
government until we get a finalized plan.
I want to quickly thank, because she's sitting behind me, and she's here to save me if you
ask really detailed questions, Marissa Clark on my team, who did the work of coordinating
with all of our partners, working with you, and working with our board to get this plan
to its current state, and I do think it's quite a good read, if I do say so.
I think it's, how many pages is it?
204.
204?
Oh, that's far too long.
Read the executive summary.
The plan is not an operations manual.
It is more of a guide.
It's about where we want to be as a state in creating a California for all, as the
governor says.
Again, it's about visions and strategies, and less about how you get there.
So it's about where we want to be, and not really about how we get there.
California is very diverse.
The regions are very diverse.
And we need to maximize flexibility and creativity around the state, because there are
many ways to get to the promised land, which is a shared prosperity in the state, again,
in California for all.
A little bit on the why, that you'll read somewhat in the state strategic plan, but
also wanted to go through a very quick history of the workforce development, the federal
workforce development program, Congress's commitment to job training, and then onto
the state plan.
And I promise this won't take long.
I hope it won't take long.
I hope it seems like it was really quick.
So the why.
As you know, California produces enormous wealth.
We have a $3 trillion economy.
We're at full employment for all intents and purposes, 4% across the state.
In some places, it's lower.
But we still have double-digit unemployment in the inland part of the state.
We have high unemployment, as you know, for communities of color.
Even in the coastal regions where unemployment is dipping below 3%, we have double-digit
unemployment for communities that have been locked out of prosperity for generations.
We have the highest levels of poverty in the United States.
In California, obviously, a challenge, a crisis around homelessness and addressing
homelessness, and we have a disconnected youth problem.
That means students, people, youth who are neither in work nor in school, and we are
losing track of them in many ways, and we need to be sure to bring them back into the
mainstream of our educational system and or into work.
Most poor people in California work, oftentimes full-time.
Some people work more than one job.
They're over-employed.
35% of Californians make $15 or less an hour, and 21% of those have an associate's degree
or a bachelor's degree.
We need to, for all of these reasons and others, we need to maximize our investments.
California invests $6 billion a year across all of its education, training, and employment
services components, federal and state dollars, $6 billion a year, but as I said, it's a
patchwork rather than an integrated system.
It's difficult, again, to navigate for people who might not be able to do that, but it's
difficult, again, to navigate for people who most need good jobs.
I don't think it's too much money.
$6 billion sounds like a lot, but for California, the size of the state, a $3 trillion economy,
if we just took 1% of the state's product, annual product, we wouldn't be investing $6
billion a year.
We'd be investing $30 billion a year.
That would probably be a scale that would meet the need of the challenges, but also
the needs of businesses who are saying that workforce development is their number one
challenge in doing business in the state of California.
Not the cost of doing business, not the cost of housing, not taxes.
Workforce is the number one challenge.
Really quickly on the history, because I think it's interesting, and I hope you do, too.
We have a workforce development program that has its roots in the New Deal.
Its focus has largely been throughout that history on skills training for people who
are locked out of prosperity, who are poor, who most need skills to be competitive and succeed.
There was a significant departure in that in 1998 with the Workforce Investment Act.
That was a time of welfare reform and work first, where we de-emphasize training services
and instead emphasize quick attachment to labor markets.
I know it had a huge effect on the effectiveness of the workforce system in terms of outcomes
for people who most need good jobs.
I'll start with Lyndon Johnson, because in 1935 he was appointed by FDR to run the precursor
to youth programs in the Workforce Innovation Opportunity Act.
Two years before he was elected to the House, he ran in Texas a youth job training program,
which is part of the WPA program.
It really has its roots in the New Deal.
In 1962, we have the Manpower Demonstration Training Act, signed by John F. Kennedy.
It was created initially to retrain workers displaced by technology.
In case you thought this conversation about future work is new, it's not.
It's actually a consistent theme throughout the workforce development programs, starting in 1962.
It was formula-based funding, based on population poverty.
Focus, again, was on training, and the dollars went not through states, but directly to communities
to provide services to people who most needed services.
That unique relationship between the federal government and Congress and local communities
has actually stayed consistent throughout all of the iterations of the law.
In 1973, the Comprehensive Employment and Training Act, CEDA, was signed by President Nixon,
set up even more local control.
It established what we call prime sponsors, which were cities, counties, and consortium of government,
so that it's not just community organizations that are getting dollars directly,
but it's going through cities and counties and consortium of government.
It created a thing called private industry councils that were made up of business, labor,
and government to make local policy about how those dollars are invested,
to be sure that we were aligned with what businesses need,
but also aligned with other components of the workforce system.
Sounds familiar?
It added this thing called public service employment.
60% of all of the dollars were invested in giving people who had challenges around employment
public sector jobs.
Really fascinating component of the system that lasted quite a while,
but in the next iteration of the law in 1982, it was knocked out,
probably because that was President Reagan.
It was President who signed the Job Training Partnership Act.
It further solidified the local service areas through counties, cities, and consortia.
It still formula allocated money to the locals, but now it's going through states,
so it brings the state in as a partner.
The states are then formula allocating dollars to these local, what we call, service delivery areas.
No more PSE, but public sector employment, but the training, investment, or commitment
is at 70%, so 70% of all of the local dollars had to be spent on training services.
1998 Workforce Investment Act, signed by Clinton, as I said,
time of welfare reform, work first.
Fast placement is a priority.
It's a full employment economy.
It established the one-stop career center system that we've pioneered here in California
under the previous iteration of the law.
It created mandatory partners, so all of the different components of the workforce system
are required to partner together and plan together and produce a plan that we sent
up to the U.S. Department of Labor.
Universal access is part of the system.
It's new.
It's actually central to the system, and you've got a sequence of services
that makes training the last level of service.
Training investments plummet.
In California, we went from 50% investment in training services and skills
to 10% in some areas of the state, zero, in training services.
The Workforce Innovation and Opportunity Act re-emphasizes training.
It re-emphasizes skills.
It focuses on industry sectors so that skills are aligned with what companies and businesses
need by sector.
It emphasizes regionalism for the first time, so not just political jurisdictions,
but how industry sectors organize in a state, and also local and regional planning
for the first time.
WIOA is pretty awesome, but it's not perfect.
It doesn't require the training mandate.
There's no specified percentage of the dollars that should be invested in training,
even though the new law is re-emphasizing training services and skills.
We still have the Workforce Investment Act in everybody's mind.
Actually, some people, it's probably still CETA or even the New Deal.
We're making a transition that's a long-term transition to a focus on skills in sectors
and regions.
The new state strategic plan really doubles down on those elements.
The plan.
I'm so glad I did that right.
I'll skip ahead.
The core programs of the Workforce Innovation and Opportunity Act, still walking through
a little bit of the structure of the system.
Forgive me if you already know this.
There are four titles in the Workforce Innovation and Opportunity Act that represent
about six programs.
WIOA Title 1 is what the State Workforce Board has direct policy authority over.
Those are the dollars that are formula allocated down to 45 local workforce development
boards around the state.
Each board is similar to the state's board, 51% business, organized labor by state statute
that do policies on behalf of the system.
They oversee roughly 200 one-stop career centers around the state.
We call them AJCs, American Job Centers of California, AJCCs in the state.
The money is administered by the Employment Development Department.
We do the policy.
WIOA Title 2, Adult Education and Literacy Activities.
WIOA Title 1, by the way, is about $400 million a year.
WIOA Title 2 is around $100 million a year.
That's administered through the Department of Education.
As you know, the policy set by y'all, the education services are aligned to assist adults
with basic skills, completion of post-secondary education, secondary education rather, and then
transitioning to post-secondary education.
Title 3 is called Employment Services.
It's about $76 million a year.
It's administered through the Employment Development Department, through AJCCs,
which assist people with identifying opportunities for jobs, looking at job lists,
and doing labor exchange, for the most part.
Title 4, Vocational Rehabilitation Activities, about $313 million a year, administered by the
Department of Rehabilitation, and it's employment-related vocational rehabilitation for
individuals with disabilities.
Those are the four components of the system.
As I said, six programs, because in the WIOA Title 1, it's three separate funding streams,
adult, dislocated worker, and youth services.
As I said, the draft plan, I think I said this, is going to be submitted to the U.S.
Department of Labor at the end of this month.
It outlines a four-year strategy for the state of California.
The plans are four-year plans.
We've been working with all of the core programs that I talked about in the previous slide,
among other partners, including Corrections, Social Services, a vast array of programs
that are invested through the state of California and locally are represented in our planning
process.
The state workforce development plan is not just about the workforce development boards,
it's really about the broad system and a vision for the broad system.
Just one point about Perkins, and we'll talk about WIOA Title 2 a little bit later.
My colleague, Carolyn Zachary, will come up and talk about that in a bit.
With regards to Perkins, because we're not going to do a whole presentation on it,
we have held working forums with all of the partners to discuss ways of aligning and jointly
implementing the state strategic plan and all of our funding streams.
But as the joint administrators of Perkins, the chancellor's office, the Department of Education,
and the State Board of Education met with us a number of times on better alignment of the
Perkins program with the rest of the workforce development system.
The draft 2020-23 state plan that we're talking about includes a couple of goals related to
Perkins.
One is we continue working together through formal committees to continue to improve
coordination of CTE programs and the Workforce Innovation Opportunity Act Title 1.
We will work together to utilize the comprehensive local needs assessment criteria
under the Perkins 5 as a tool for encouraging greater alignment of the local eligible agency
or institution with their local and regional workforce systems.
I read that because if you ask me questions, you'll know I don't know the answer to them
probably, but Marissa Clark is going to jump up here and save me if you ask Perkins questions.
Yeah, she's good.
Very quickly, state plan vision, and then I want to walk through strategies, and
well, strategies, and I'll wrap that up quickly.
But I want to spend a couple of extra minutes on the vision because it's important
and it's new to this year's or this four-year unified strategic plan.
And it's about high road and taking the high road, and this is language that the governor
is using quite a bit and the secretary of labor is using a lot.
In fact, she's talked about doubling down on the high road, and it's four basic things.
It's number one, quality jobs.
So we start with the best jobs, and this is really turning the workforce system sort
of upside down in a way because the workforce system tends to start with programs,
give people what we think is the wherewithal to be successful in competitive labor markets.
We send people out in those markets and we hope that they connect to a job.
Obama called that train and pray.
Instead of that, starting with programs and pushing people into labor markets,
our intent is to work in industry sectors that are driving regional employment
with companies in those sectors who do right by workers, who treat workers
not as a cost to be reduced, but as an investment, as an asset to invest in.
So in this partnership with companies in those sectors that are driving employment,
we can create pathways into good quality jobs.
And instead of pushing people into labor markets, we pull people into jobs.
That's the quality job piece.
Worker voice is the second one in the design and the implementation of workforce programs.
We understand that if you're doing deep sector dives with companies and you're looking at
challenges and opportunities around workforce for a company or a group of companies,
you need workers at the table because they understand best.
About what happens on the shop floor, so to speak.
They understand how to create efficiencies.
They understand job flow, workflow.
And if they're not at the table, you're not going to get the best product.
You're not going to get the best program.
You're not going to get the best implementation because when workers are at the table,
you get buy-in.
It's also important for the future of work.
It's an anxiety reducing exercise to have workers give them more agency
in what their future looks like.
The third piece is equity.
The workforce development system generally does very well on the equity side.
If that means removing barriers to employment for populations that have significant barriers
to employment, we do that well.
But you don't have equity if you don't have job quality.
It makes no sense.
I think it does no good to help somebody who's underemployed,
unemployed, or has a crappy job, which is a technical term.
To put that person in another dead-end, low-wage, low-quality job.
So the job quality and the equity go hand in hand.
And then finally, climate.
As you know, California is leading the nation, possibly the world,
in mitigating climate change, pulling carbon out of the atmosphere.
That affects industry.
It affects industry sectors.
It also affects workers.
So our investments in workforce development includes a focus on those sectors
and those communities and those workers who are most impacted by climate change
and climate change policy.
Sorry, I didn't keep up with my PowerPoint slides.
I just got a couple of more.
We have three state plan policy objectives that you'll read about in the plan.
We think these are important.
So we've got the vision, but we've got a lot about the how also,
and the how are the state plan policy objectives, those three,
and then state plan strategies.
The first of the three state plan policy objectives
is fostering demand-driven skills attainment.
As I said, reinvesting in skills training using the Title I dollars,
but also partnering with our schools that are doing effective
career technical education investments, and that partnering is crucial.
Aligning workforce programs, though, with industry needs is the key part there.
So again, we're not pushing people in the labor markets.
We're pulling people into good jobs.
Enabling upward mobility for all Californians,
making sure that programs are accessible, navigable,
so we're aligned so workers can find their way through what is now a patchwork system.
And then aligning, coordinating, and integrating programs and services
to achieve that scale and impact I talked about.
State plan strategies, we have seven.
You can see them here.
Some of them, I think, are self-explanatory.
I've talked about them.
Sector strategies, again, deep sector work.
That doesn't mean inviting employers to your office or to an event
to give you a couple of hours of input on what they think their needs are.
It's sitting down with employers in sectors that are driving employment
and building partnerships that are long-term and understanding their needs with them
both internally so you can move workers up through incumbent worker training
and you create opportunities for getting into new jobs at the front end
so you get an upskill, backfill thing going.
Career pathways, aligning the system so that, not pathways the way you maybe think about them,
but pathways in the sense that we have a navigable workforce system
that job seekers aren't starting over every time they go to a new program,
but instead the alignment is such that a worker is finding his or her way through it
on her way to a really good job, not really knowing
that there are different funding streams and silos.
That's the intent.
Regional partnerships, a new push in the federal law,
but it's been a push of ours previous to the Workforce Innovation and Opportunity Act.
The point is that industry sectors don't align within political jurisdictions.
We have to be organized regionally because industry sectors are organized regionally.
The way companies recruit workers is regional and commute patterns are regional.
We can't be focused on trying to figure out
how to get sector work within narrow political jurisdictions.
Earn and learn, utilizing work-based learning,
paid internships and formalized apprenticeship, and then supportive services.
The workforce or the workers that we're most focused on making an impact on or with
have significant barriers to employment
and don't have the wherewithal to sit in a long-term training program
that is probably going to be necessary for their success.
Wrap-around services are crucial for transportation, child care,
stipends so people can earn while they learn.
Apprenticeship is one of those models that work very well, as you probably know.
Cross-system data capacity.
It's really hard to align a system that is so siloed but also working with its own data.
So if we can work on the front end on data alignment,
we can create that navigability in a real way.
It's also important on the back end so we can better understand
which interventions are having the best impact on workers.
And then finally, integrated service delivery.
That's it.
Just a few dates.
I've already talked about these, so I don't need to go over them again.
Then I want to hand it off to my colleague Carolyn Zachary to talk about WIOA Title II,
but I also want to offer any questions that Marissa can answer.
Terrific. Thank you.
Perfect. Thank you for putting those together.
All right. Good morning, President Darling-Hammond, board members.
I am Dr. Carolyn Zachary, the administrator for the Adult Education Office
in the Career and College Transition Division.
The roots of adult education are strong and deep here in California.
Beginning in 1856 in San Francisco with the Board of Education establishing evening classes
for adults in academic subjects and vocational subjects, specifically drafting and bookkeeping.
And those subjects were taught to individuals who were mostly immigrants from Italy, Ireland,
and China. And then in 1870, they had almost a thousand students enrolled,
and adult education became a permanent fixture in the San Francisco Unified School District.
In 1910, adult education became part of a free public education in California.
And federal support began for adult education, as Tim talked about, in 1964 with the Economic
Opportunity Act, and continues now with the Workforce Innovation and Opportunity Act.
And today, we have over 400 agencies providing adult education services.
Our history is so rich and treasured that Stanford University has established an archive
for adult education, and it continues to maintain that with our annual reports every year.
The archive includes a book published in 2005 called Meeting the Challenge,
a History of Adult Education, and Chad has copies to pass out to all of you later.
Or you have them, oh good, you have them, perfect. So let's first look at how the opportunities of
the California Department of Education has to connect with our state agency partners
in WIOA titles one, three, and four. We'll talk more specifically about two a little later.
As Tim Rainey shared, the WIOA state plan covers the four title areas identified in the act.
Many program offices within the California Department of Education have connections with
services and support that assist WIOA target populations, including individuals with barriers
to employment, as well as veterans, unemployed workers, incarcerated individuals, immigrants,
the homeless, and youth. Our education options office in the current college transition division
connects local education agencies with title one youth programs, and our special education
division works specifically with title four in the area of transition students through the
workability title one program. The CDE is the designated state agency for WIOA title two
adult education and family literacy act. As a recipient of the funding, the CDE adult education
office is responsible for awarding the funds and grant compliance monitoring through the federal
program monitoring system. This includes all sub-grantees, K-12 adult schools, community and
faith-based organizations, community college non-credit programs, correctional institutions,
and library literacy programs. The WIOA funding is one of two funding streams which supports the
adult education system in California. The state funding stream, the California adult education
program, is the main source of funding for adult programs, and that is jointly administered
between the California adult education, between the California department of education and the
community college chancellor's office. The adult education agencies across the state offer programs
in all of these areas that you see listed here. I want to specifically draw your attention to
something that was new in WIOA, and that is the integrated English language civics education
known as IELCE, just because we need more acronyms in education, and IET which is integrated
education and training, and many of those adult schools that are doing integrated education and
training programs are partnering with career technical education programs and eligible training
providers to deliver training components for that IET, and these training programs do include those
high road areas that Tim referred to earlier. In the adult education system, you can find programs
and classes in a variety of locations as stated on the slide, and as I talked about earlier,
the adult education system is supported by those two funding streams, the state funds and the
federal funds. CAPE, which is the California adult education program, the state dollars
are in the amount of approximately $550 million, and these are allocated to K-12 adult schools
and community colleges within 71 consortia in the state following the community college
district boundaries. The CAPE, as I said earlier, is jointly administered between the chancellor's
office and the CDE, and 88% of those funds go to K-12 adult schools. The other funding source
is the federal WIOA Title II Adult Education and Family Literacy Act, which is part of the
WIOA plan for which we are seeking approval today. These funds of $103 million are considered
supplemental to the state funds, and the CDE funds these through a competitive grant process
on a three-year basis. In California, we serve over 800,000 students in our adult education program.
That's in addition to the 6.2 million that we often hear quoted, so we're really serving
almost 700 or 7 million students in California, and the only requirement is that you be 18 years
of age to be in these programs. So as you heard earlier from Tim Rainey, WIOA Title II AFLA
is part of the larger WIOA state plan. The plan guides the services to assist individuals in
our state to move forward. Our adult education system in existence for nearly 165 years is still
focused on assisting students to improve their skills to have better jobs and improved lives
and better opportunities. The CDE requests your approval on the WIOA state plan. Thank you, and
now I know that we'll be happy to answer any questions. Okay, we could take if there are any
clarifying questions, but then we'll have public comment and come back for additional deep dive.
And Ting Sun, would you like to add some comments as our liaison? Yes, so just a couple things.
First of all, thank you, Tim, and thank you for coming and presenting, and Tim is just as
fascinating the second time around. So this is an application process that, as Tim said,
requires the partnership of the Department of Education and the State Board of Education.
It is not one that we necessarily lead, and so it doesn't come up to us very often, but, you know,
it is a very important part of our work. And so I think mainly just kind of understanding that
this is a much, much broader application process. We're one piece of it, and that we also, through
the Perkins application that you'll be hearing about a little bit later, and through the work
of the California Joint Workforce Pathways Advisory Committee, we are also liaisoning
as well with this larger WIOA application. Thank you. Are there any just quick clarifying
questions that we need to ask to understand the data that's been presented? All right,
let's see if there's any public comment. We have three people signed up for public comment,
Branka Marcetta, Jennifer Barrett, and Karen Malkiewicz.
Okay, we encourage you to state your name and affiliation for the record.
Hello, esteemed State Board members and State Board staff. Thank you for allowing
you to take this public comment today. My name is Branka Marcetta, and I currently
facilitate and direct the work of the Adult Education Consortium here in the Greater
Sacramento region, one of the 71 that Dr. Zachary mentioned earlier. And previously,
for over a decade, I served the field of adult education for the whole state and nationally
within the space of the Workforce Innovation Opportunity Act. I also speak on behalf of a
professional association whose 3,000 plus members are educators, support staff, learners, and friends
of adult education. More of my fellow educators would be here today if they were not a few blocks
away participating in activities with our workforce development partners. I'm here to express
my support for the WIO estate plan. I would like to thank the California Workforce Development Board
and California Department of Education for their work in the planning and development of this plan
with particular recognition of Mrs. Carolyn Zachary or Dr. Zachary. Ms. Zachary and her team
at the Adult Education Office are well structured in their position to support the implementation
of the plan. I invite you to visit with our local programs that are co-located
with adult education programs and job centers. Please visit with us in Sacramento area to see
this in action. Thank you very much. Good morning, Madam President and the esteemed members of the
California State Board of Education. I'm here this morning to provide my support of the new
WIO estate plan and to recognize the CDE Office of Adult Education staff for their tireless work
in its development. My name is Karen Malkowitz and I'm a K-12 adult education principal in Sacramento
County. I oversee programs funded by WIOA Title II, including programs in correctional settings.
We owe a Title I serving adults, out-of-school youth and refugees, and CTE programs funded
through Carl Perkins. The strategies in the plan designed to serve and support California's
disenfranchised adults and older youth were established as a result of extensive research,
collaboration, and stakeholder input. As educators, we know that a parent's ability to obtain
and retain a family-sustaining career can have a direct impact on a child's success in life.
For the sake of our state's future, please approve this plan and I thank you for your time.
Good morning, Madam President, members of the California State Board of Education,
and Executive Director Karen Staff Walters. My name is Jennifer Barrett and I would like to
express my support for the WIOA state plan. I have worked in the field of adult education
for the past 30 years as a teacher and now as an administrator, serving the communities of South
Sacramento and Elk Grove. I manage a job center and the correctional education programs housed
in the Sacramento County jails. The job center is co-located within a K-12 adult education facility
and WIOA services help our communities navigate school and work issues with the goal of developing
family-sustaining pathways. Having both DOR and DHA as on-site partners is immeasurably
helpful to those with disabilities and serves as a touch point for families who receive state
financial assistance. I've been around long enough to remember the divide between education
and employment services. The state plan sets a great path toward WIOA 1 through 4 collaboration
needing to support our at-risk populations by providing necessary structure and cross agency
times. Thank you. All right, open the conversation to the board for any discussion.
Member Navo, Member Burr, oh you're pointing, oh Member Rucker, okay. You know I was just had a
question for, oh Patricia first? No, no. Okay, sorry. Go ahead. For Tim, first of all I really
appreciate this and I think deeply about the migrant communities in the Central Valley
that greatly struggle and need as much support as possible and I'm interested in the wraparound
services that you highlighted where there's geographic spread and transportation barriers
and where, can you highlight maybe a couple places where this is working or these wraparound
services are really improving the opportunities for those in situations like I'm describing?
That's a great question. The workforce development boards who oversee the career centers, the AJCs,
they're all, like I said, there are 200 of them across the state. Through those AJCs,
supportive services are provided to workers, job seekers who need those supportive services
and they're not as generous as we'd like them to be. There just isn't enough money in the system
I think to support the level of need. We had a program last year that we're still administering
AB 1111 which provided 15 million dollars for additional supportive services but the unique
thing in 1111 was it created a partnership and alignment between workforce development boards
and community-based organizations across the state because CBOs are on the front lines.
The mission-driven CBOs are on the front lines. They know best how to serve populations with
barriers. They know best what kinds of wraparound services are necessary and we need to bring them
more into the mainstream of the workforce development system. They often have their own
resources but they're also under-resourced so that collaboration between the CBOs and the
workforce development boards is really crucial not only to get a scale for impact of the resources
but also to reach the communities in the most effective way. So we're going to continue to work
on trying to ensure that we have adequate funding for the supportive services part because the job
training doesn't work if people can't be in the job training because they've got issues around
child care, transportation, or if they need a paycheck.
Member Rucker? Well, Tim, I want to first of all thank you for bringing this plan before the board
and I was looking forward to your presentation today and I did read the plan and I thought
it was really compelling reading actually because I was fascinated by several things.
First of all, given California's place in the world and in the economy, I think it's really
important for a state like ours to make a definitive policy and an definitive assertion
about establishing a high-road workforce system. I think that was very important and I thought it
was very thoughtfully developed and crafted and explained in the plan. Secondly, I was absolutely
appreciative that you did not in the plan treat California's workforce like a monolith.
I appreciated the level of granularity that you looked at regional needs but also regional
differences about what defines the workforce, where the gaps are, and where the growth opportunities
actually exist. When I travel out of state and I visit friends and family, as I did recently,
people still look at California and think about the Silicon Valley or agriculture, but not all
of the other types of work that defines our workforce. But finally, and I really want to
thank you for the statement you made about the dignity of work and its importance to the people
who are in our workforce. Because accepting and understanding that, many people not only define
themselves by that work, but they are defined by others, by the dignity of the work that they do.
So I truly appreciate the vision the plan articulated, but also the very artful and forceful
way you createdand notice how I used the royal weyou created a plan that will create a different
line in the sand and a different direction for the state. So thank you very much for that.
Any other board comments or discussion? Okay. All right. Do I have a motion?
I will move the department's recommendation to approve the plan.
And I will second it.
All right. All those in favor say aye.
Any opposed nay. Any abstentions? Motion carries. Thank you very much. We appreciate it.
Right along to item three, which is the Career Technical Education Incentive Grant.
There is an addendum for attachment one. There are, I believe, two recusals for this item.
Members Ortiz-Lacon and Ting Sun. So we'll let you leave the room.
Okay. And the CDE recommends that the State Board review and approve the following
information. There is a proposed allocation formula for the Career Technical Education
Incentive Grant and specific proposed funding amounts and the number of grant awards, which
is an attachment two. So you have two attachments there. The purposes for which grant funds may be
used, which includes the minimum eligibility standards, allowable and non-allowable expenditures.
And this item will be presented by Pradeep Khurram Raju from the CDE. Pradeep, please begin.
Oh, hi. Good morning.
I will be presented by Kai Jackson and Pradeep. Thank you, ma'am. I appreciate it. Good morning,
President Darling-Hammond, State Board members and staff. And as the President noted, I will be
assisted in this presentation by Dr. Kodam Raju, Director of the Career and College Transition
Division. Russ Weichel is in the audience, who is a retired annuitant, provide technical assistant,
and the unit manager for the CTE unit will provide technical assistance. And indeed,
this is a good day to talk about workability and Career Technical Education and its various modalities
and grant variations. And so we'll talk a little bit about CTE IG. But before I do that,
this issue was really reinforced to me yesterday when I met with between 40 to 50 students
from various school districts within Orange County. And of the many things they talked to me about,
school funding, mental health, CTE was one of them. And they reinforced not only the desire to have
more career pathways at their schools and within their districts, but the desire to be ready and
prepared for the jobs of today, tomorrow, and beyond. And so as we've seen in our state over
the last number of years, CTE has had a number of increased investments, and our state has increased
and bolstered its efforts to prepare our students for the jobs of tomorrow.
So we saw in 2018-2019 budget year that there was an appropriation for $300 million
ongoing towards CTE. And in that package, roughly half went to the California Community Colleges,
K-12 Strong Workforce Program, and the other half, approximately $150 million, went to the
CTE for the CTE Incentive Grant. And as you may recall, this item was postponed from the January
meeting. There were questions from our customers, from the field, from the LEAs. And today we will
speak to many of those questions. But since January, we, the state board staff, the CTE staff,
some members that are here today, have engaged with the field, with our customers, stakeholders,
and we've heard them loud and clear. We've been engaged with various conversations in various
conversations and in various modalities, whether via webinars, whether in person,
whether legislative hearings, with advocates, with LEAs, the legislature, Department of Finance,
and LAO, and many more. And so today, we will affirm that they've been heard,
and that we've looked at issues that they've brought to us, to include ensuring that these
resources can be as predictable and stable to the maximum extent possible, that we provide
transparency in messaging, either potential or actual changes. And we've heard their desire
to work towards more alignment between these funding streams. And importantly, we've heard
their desire for us to maintain and bolster an equity lens as we implement these dollars.
And so our team, to include the state board, have worked very, very diligently, incredibly hard
to address these issues, to ensure that these funds get out where they're intended to be
accurately and on time. And so I'd like to turn this over to my colleague, Dr. Kotam Raju,
and he'll talk about the CTE Incentive Grant.
Thank you, Kai. Good morning. I'm Pradeep Kotam Raju. I'm the Director of the Korean College
Transition Division at the California Department of Education. President Darling-Hammond,
members of the board, State Superintendent Tony Thurmond, and other colleagues. Just to add one
thing to what Kai was talking about is the K-12 Strong Workforce Program and the CTIC program
are worked together for student outcomes. We've had several conversations with the
Chancellor's Office to talk about how we can align the metrics for the two, and we'll talk about that
in a moment. So the funding allocation is stipulated in code, and the authority is set out
to develop the allocation formula and is jointly determined by the State Board of Education and the
California Department of Education. What you have in the blue copy is an attachment that
describes how the formula has been laid out and how the allocations are set. And in the board
memo, we provided an attachment for what we call the matrix of metrics. And also in that memo,
we talked about how the renewal grants are awarded, and I'll address that
in the presentation. Attachment three is provided as it lays out the statute in detail for the CTIC
grant. So just to give you an idea of what the matrix of metrics is, I won't read all of that,
but as you read that for yourselves, you can see a lot of that is familiar with a lot of the
indicators that we are dealing in other programs as well and within the California Accountability
Model. And the thing to keep in mind here is what we're trying to do is we have metrics that we
have to report for CTIC, we have metrics that we have to report for K-12 strong workforce,
and we have metrics that we have to report for the Carl Perkins grant. We are working together
within the department and with the Chancellor's Office to try to make sure that we align that
so that when LEAs provide data to either the California Department of Education or to the
Chancellor's Office, they're actually, so we have a single system which we're sort of moving
towards using CALPADS, so when they submit this data, they don't have to do this three times,
and it will be within staff within that will then extract that and use the metrics appropriately
for all of these different programs.
The other thing I would like to say is that some of these metrics that were laid out in the
legislation are yet to be collected within the system, like apprenticeships or industry-based
certifications, and we are having conversations within the California Department of Education
how to include this through, excuse me, within our data system, but particularly how we
can bring them forward into the CCI or the College and Career Indicator.
As Kai mentioned, the item was postponed from the January 2020 meeting, and since that time,
we have been diligently working to ensure the accuracy of the allocation formula and the
specific allocations that will now be proposed to the State Board of Education. We held a webinar
to explain to the field the allocation process. The webinar provided an opportunity to receive
additional feedback from stakeholders and LEAs and to answer questions from the field.
It also provided the CDE an opportunity to give additional clarity and transparency
into the changes. The CDE also participated in a California Assembly legislative hearing
and were able to answer questions and provide feedback to the Assembly Committee on Education.
The CDE continues to affirm our commitment to work with stakeholders, the legislature,
and the Department of Finance, as well as with you, the State Board of Education,
to ensure the accurate implementation of the CTIC grant.
For the 2019 and 20 funding for the fiscal year, the CDE proposes using three categories based on
the legislation. The CTIC funding, a total of $150 million, is allocated per legislation
in the categories that you see in front of you, and it's based on average daily attendance or ADA.
Roughly, the small category has $6 million, the medium category has $12 million, and the large
category has $132 million, and the percentages are prescribed in legislation.
The other factor that drives the allocations is one is the eligibility of how much an LEA is eligible
is based on a calculation, which I will explain and which is described in the blue sheet that
was provided to you. The other criteria is the legislation stipulates that there has to be a
two-to-one match. For every dollar from this grant, there has to be two local dollars to that,
and that has implications of how eventually each LEA gets allocated funds.
The application process, just as a clarifying aspect, there are two parts to this,
or two broad areas. One is we have an application process that LEAs apply either singly or as a
consortium, and that application, that two-part application as you see on the slide, is that
we have that inputted into our Grants Management System. The points are signed there. There's a
self-evaluation, there's a narrative, there's a budget narrative, and a three-year budget,
and how is this application connected to the LCAP, and the maximum is a total of 54 points.
When the applications are scored, there is a total of, if you score 27 and above, you get put
into a pool of eligible LEAs for funding. So you're scored, and then the ones that meet the
application or that criteria, those 27 points, then we set out the allocation process for that,
and how each LEA will be awarded funds that you would be approving today.
So the next four slides that we will go through talks about the allocation formula that we've used
for the 2019-20 allocations. There are three sort of broad areas that we look at in terms of
calculation. One is we use the ADA, and this is, let me say this, this is done for each of the
categories. We do that separately for each of the categories, and so there is a 70 percent base grant
that is based on ADA. So it's the total ADA in that, for example, the small category,
and the share, the ADA share in that for that particular LEA determines how much of the base
category, the base funding that they would get. Then there are what are called positive considerations.
There are eight positive considerations. Seven of them are also using the same technique as we use
for the base grant we use in terms of the positive considerations. The point to remember about the
positive considerations is this. You're either in the, you have the positive consideration or
you do not have the positive consideration, and then basically the allocation is based on those
that are in that, in that, who make that or meet that positive consideration.
So when we look at the second, so for seven of them we use the formula that was,
let me just go back, that we use the formula that 30 percent that's there, the total category,
and as I said we do that for each of the ADA categories. But we also have an eighth category
which is called the unduplicated pupil count. In that, we essentially look at, for unduplicated
pupil count, that positive consideration is we look at the share of that LEA in the unduplicated,
total unduplicated pupil count, and then essentially multiply that by the per pupil
unduplicated pupil count dollar amount, and then multiply it by the LEA's unduplicated
pupil count to get a dollar amount for this positive consideration. So keep in mind,
we have a base calculation, we have these eight positive considerations for which we have a dollar
allocation, and then we add them together to get the, what we're referring to as the eligible
allocation amount for a single LEA, and we do that for every of each of the categories,
the small, medium, and large categories. So now once we decide, once we determine the eligible
amount that an LEA gets, the next thing we look at is the match. What kind of match can they provide
in the grant? And remember the match is one is to two, that is for every grant dollars there has to
be two local dollars that are provided. So the LEA receives the lesser of the two, either the
eligible amount or the match, and in your blue sheet, in the document, we've explained in that
how, and giving you examples of how that is there in terms of describing how that works. So the
thing to keep in mind, it's the lesser of the two, either the eligible amount or the match that they get.
When you add up the eligible amount for a category, let's say the small category, we notice that
the LEAs in the small category did not expend the six million dollars that was allocated to that
small category. So there was essentially funds in that we needed to find some way of allocating
that because keep in mind all of these dollars have to be allocated otherwise they go back to
the state in terms of that. So we had to find a way of allocating those funds to making sure that at
least LEAs get awarded all of that amount. So it allows for awarding LEAs in the small categories
up to their match. So in the small categories, so going to the next slide,
when we looked at this, basically what happens is that we found that there were some LEAs,
I'm using the small as an example here, there were some LEAs that could match a lot more than
what they were eligible for. So the extra funds that were available in that small category then
was then reallocated first to those in the small category so they ended up getting at least up to
their match. And so we gave them additional dollars over and about what they were eligible for.
And as a result of that, even after that there were still some funds left over. So then we
took those funds and moved them to the medium category. And we did the same allocation process,
we did exactly the same process and moved that. And there was still, once we allocated to all of
the medium, there were still funds left over that we moved to the large category. So the thing to,
first thing to keep in mind that both the small and the medium category received their match,
what they could match for, so not only what they were eligible for but some additional dollars
up to their match. We never exceeded over the match amount that they had. Some, of course,
got exactly their match because that's what the allocation turned out to be,
but there were instances where they got some additional dollars in the small and medium category.
On the other hand, when we moved the remaining funds to the large ADA category,
because of their size, the large ADA categories probably had a lot more match
than what they were eligible for. So in the large ADA categories, there was match left on the table,
so to speak, and all they received was what they were eligible for. And in that way, we
ensured that the $150 million was all expended through this process that we applied.
So as I talked about, the cut score was 27 out of 54 in terms of applications. There were
50 new grant applications, applicants for this year of funding compared to 44 for the prior year.
There were 288 renewal grants again awarded from the 2018-19,
and the LEAs represented 54 of the 58 counties.
So once we did the calculations that I just described to you, this was the total allocation
for each of the three categories, and it totals up to $150 million. So we had 20 LEAs in the small
category, 52 LEAs in the medium category, and 264 LEAs in the large category.
One of the things the State Board of Education has to do is to also recommend in the recommendation
these allowable and non-allowable expenditures, and these are described to you in pages five and
six of the board item. So we tried to encourage and maintain the delivery of high-quality CTE
and the delivery of high-quality CTE, and the delivery of high-quality CTE, and the delivery of
maintain the delivery of high-quality CTE, and these allowable and non-allowable expenditures
are laid out, and the grantees are made aware of them through basically we have technical assistance
staff within that are assigned within our, and they make sure that they work with the
with the the grantees to to make sure that they are following these
this recommendation. So the number of grants recommended to be awarded are 336,
and basically, and that number hasn't changed very much from last year. Last year there was 337,
even the number of applicants last year was 379, this year was 378. So it's about the same
in terms of, and as you saw before, lots of the people that apply tend to be renewal or they
apply for as renewal grants. So let me come back and talk about the, before we go into the
recommendation, let me talk about the 2018-19 use of five categories. One of the things that,
as you recall through my, as I presented, the allocation formula that we used, and they were
these extra, I'll call them extra funds in each of the categories, and we had to find a methodology
to expend those funds so that LEAs receive all of the 150 million dollars.
So what we did was instead of using the three categories, which was in the statute, we ended
up using five categories where we divided the large category into three categories.
We called large A, large B, and large C. And what you have in front of you there is essentially
to look at, given that it's a fixed amount of dollars, there will be some adjustments
in the dollars that are allocated, and the smaller LEAs gained, when I say the smaller,
particularly the large A and the large B gained as a result of that, and it worked against the
smaller LEAs who joined consortia. One of the things to keep in mind that when we compare the
2019-20 allocations back to the 2017-18 allocations, which was essentially at that time
that we used the three categories, the dollar amounts allocated to LEAs were more or less the
same. So in essence, in 2018-19, there was a deviation from the trend, if you want to look
at that, there was a bump for certain LEAs, or there was a redistribution of the funds based on
using those five categories. So when you look at, we compared the two just to let you know what
those extra funds that were left there, and we used the same. So the big difference is
that the way we calculated the 19-20 was slightly different from the way we calculated the 18-19,
but eventually we were able to allocate all of the funds to the LEAs.
So the recommendation that you have in front of you is that the CD recommends that the SBA review
and approve the following information. Proposed TTIG allocation, which is an allocation formula,
the specified proposed funding amounts and number of grants awarded,
the purpose for which grants may be used and minimum eligibility standards,
and the allowable and non-allowable expenditures.
Does that end the presentation? Do you want to say something now?
Thank you, ma'am. I appreciate it. Thank you, Dr. Kodem Raju. I appreciate the data that was
presented, and just in closing, I just wanted to note something importantly that as California
continues to bolster preparing kids for the jobs of today and tomorrow, one of the things I'm not
quite sure that we mentioned was that as compared to last year when the requests for these dollars
were right about $300 million, this year the request was up to $900 million, which really
speaks to the demand for increased CTE funding and pathways in schools. And as we look over the
horizon at the demand signal, I see it increasing even more. And so today we talked about increasing
our transparency, ensuring the accuracy of the implementation of these dollars, equity,
and then ensuring that 100% of the funds were going to where they're intended to, to get down
to the school site level. And so in closing, once again, I want to thank all of the members who
supported this program and this effort and the staff and the state board. And with that, I
turn it back over to them. So I appreciate the closing comments and also the detail of the
presentation. And so I know there's a lot of detail in here, and I hope that we'll get a
chance to, but I'm going to first turn to Member Rucker. She's our liaison to this process and
ask her for some opening comments. Well, first of all, I need to give my commendations to the staff,
Dr. Kodemaraju and your unit, as well as the other divisions in the state, including the
Department of Finance, who worked very closely with us on putting this item together and on
doing an analysis about the distribution of the funding. And I also want to thank Patricia
DeCoste. She spent a lot of time with me going through this process and answering my questions,
so did Kaleem Jackson. He talked to me regularly as late as yesterday to look at this information
and to understand it. I want to draw attention for my colleagues on the board to page
two of attachment one. It says the State Board of Education is required to give the greatest
weight to applicants meeting criteria A, B, and C pursuant to Ed Code section 53075B.
So as I went through the list and I paid attention with great interest to each of the categories of
LEAs that are being funded, many people would assume with a grant and a pot this size that
large LEAs would particularly be favored in receiving the lion's share of the grant.
And in the work that was done with the funding formulas, particularly looking at
starting with the smaller districts and moving to the medium and large, there is great diversity
of who was funded. There's great diversity in the geography of the LEAs that were funded.
But there's also a great distribution between charter schools and non-charter schools
who were equally considered and equally weighted given the criteria that Dr. Kodem Raju explained.
And I'm satisfied that the weight of the recommendations that are being funded for
the LEAs that are being funded definitely do give weight to those applicants for those first three
criteria. So I can share with you that that is very clear. So when we finish with the discussion,
I am ready to recommend the recommendations. With one reminder, there was a revised addendum.
So as it relates to the proposed CTIG allocation formula,
it's the revised attachment one that I want to make sure you're paying attention to.
So member, I want to thank you for that and also for the clarification that you shared about
the diversity and variance in the regions. And I really appreciate that. So at this point,
we're going to open to board members just for one clarifying comment before we go to public
comments. I'll just kind of look around and see if there's any clarifying. So Brenna,
no? Any clarifying? Okay, so we'll go to public comment first and then we'll come back for board
discussion. There's no public comment. All right. Well, thank you. So now I'll go back to a member
record. Do you want any further clarifying comments? Because you obviously have a depth
of knowledge about this and the comprehensive. Is there anything else you want to share
for the board? Or do you want to start with your motion? I believe I gave the comment. Okay. Great.
Again, I do want to remind you that there was a revised addendum. Yes. So for your records,
work away, everything else. And make sure any future questions you receive, pay attention
to the revised addendum. So with that, will you make a motion? Oh, yes, go ahead. To follow up
on what member Rucker talked about. The other thing we should keep in mind is that the use of
the unduplicated people count because in that we use free and reduced lunch English language learners
and foster children. So that also leads to looking at equity in a much larger scale within this
allocation formula. Thank you. So member Rucker, will you make your. So I'm going to move the
staff recommendation as has printed out in the revised addendum on page one of the revised
addendum. Okay. And do I have a second? I'll second. Okay. We have a second member Navo.
Any other further board comment? So all those in favor say aye. Aye. Any opposed? Any abstentions?
So the motion carries unanimously. Thank you very much. With that, we're going to take a short break.
So I thank you to the department and everyone who works so hard on this process.
We're going to take a maybe a short, just short break. Okay. Thank you.
See you back in five minutes.
I hate to call people out, but everyone's why you have to do it.
All right. We're going to continue on so that we can complete this next item before lunchtime.
This is the item you've all been waiting for.
Item number four. Agenda item number four.
Thank you for taking your seats. We're going to continue.
If you have a conversation that's important, you can take it to the hall.
Okay. Item four is the federal Perkins state plan item. It does have an addendum.
The CDE recommends that we approve the draft federal Perkins five state plan and forward
the plan to the governor's office for a 30-day review. In addition, CDE recommends that the
state board allow the department in collaboration with SBE staff to make any necessary non-substantive
clarifying edits. This item will be presented by Pradeep Kotamraju from the CDE. Pradeep, please begin.
I'm Pradeep Kotamraju from the CDE, and I'd like to present the draft federal Perkins five state
plan for Korean technical education and recommend that it, subject to your approval, move it forward
to the governor's office. Before I start into my remarks here, I would like to thank
I want to thank the State Board staff, Patricia DeCoste and Pam Castleman, who have worked
with us as partners through this process, as well as staff from the California Community
Chancellor's Office, Community College Chancellor's Office, and staff at CDE.
I particularly want to thank those within the data division, the three data divisions
to help with the accountability section, but consultations with many of the divisions
within the CDE helped bring it to this draft that is in front of you.
So the overview that I'll go through, I'll talk about just in terms of the milestones
in the development of the plan, the approach that we took, the broad overview of the sections,
and then ask for your recommendation.
If you recall, when I came and presented to you at the January meeting, we went through
a rather detailed presentation of each of the different strands in that.
I will not be doing that, but giving you a high-level approach to what this plan entails.
And I think it's fitting in terms of having this plan be presented to you in the light
of the previous two items that we presented today, particularly looking at the WIOA plan,
because a lot of that, we've been having a lot of conversations with Tim Rainey and
his staff about how we can collaborate a lot more, not only in terms of the federal grants
that we have within the state, but also aligning the different state programs that we have
both on the workforce development side as well as the education side as well.
So as I mentioned here, we followed the leadership of the California Workforce Pathways Joint
Advisory Committee. Three of the members are from the state board. We have three other
members from the Board of Governors as well.
When I came here in July, and this was going on before that, we have what we call a joint
management team from these three agencies that met regularly almost weekly to work through
various iterations of the draft plan with input from not only the Joint Advisory Committee,
but also from other stakeholders as well.
We had a stakeholder and public comment process that we engaged in. We had the stakeholder
engagement that we looked at, and across, we had the cross-key subgroups. We had a two
full day meeting and one virtual session in the fall of 2019. We also added additional
stakeholder meetings to receive the teacher voice in this.
And all of this was done before, except for the accountability meeting, all of this was
done prior to actually writing the first draft of the plan so we could get input from the
field.
Once we wrote the first draft of the plan and then we put that out for public comment,
we had a public comment session. There were four in-person sessions and a virtual public
feedback session, and we had an online feedback session for 32 days. We had 361 comments
in 92 number of commenters. The public comment document is actually now available online
that there is a link in the board item as well as within the plan that we provided a
link for the public comment item.
We went through an iterative review with the California Workforce Pathways Joint Advisory
Committee. In November 2019, we presented the plan and that was reviewed and moved forward
for public comment. In January of 2020, we had a plan that was revised to include the
public comment and we detailed out the accountability section in the plan.
We were asked to come back again in March to present to the Joint Advisory Committee
and this time we updated the teacher and faculty preparation section and then the plan was
approved to move forward to you, the State Board of Education.
With regard to the review of the State Board of Education, there was a December 2019 information
memo that was provided as background. As I mentioned earlier, January 2020, we presented
as an information item to the State Board and today we're making this presentation to
you for approval.
Just to indicate what the next steps might be, there is an information item for the Board
of Governors next week. Then we forward this to the Governor's Office and the legislation
says that the Governor has at least 30 days to review the document and we have to submit
to the U.S. Department of Education no later than April 15th.
The approach we took in developing the plan was from guidance from the Joint Advisory
Committee, we started with the guiding principles that were laid out by the Joint Advisory Committee
and we used that as you read the plan through, we mentioned the guiding principles throughout
the document in terms of how and applied that in various ways in terms of not only the guiding
principles but we also used in terms of the college and career pathways, the 12 essential
elements of a high quality college and career pathway.
We talked a lot about a student-centered high quality college and career pathway and in
the Perkins legislation there is what is called, which is central to the Perkins legislation
is what is called a program of study. The program of study is a grade 9 to 14 curricular
framework with associated supports and that is one of the reasons among many that it is
a collaboration between LEAs and community colleges at the local level and at the state
level between the Chancellor's Office and CDE. There is a focused approach on special
population, just a little bit of history, I won't go into the kind of detail that Tim
Rainey went through but just a little bit of history. Until Perkins 5, special populations
were always treated as separately from other special populations, in fact Perkins had its
unique list of special populations. What has been done under Perkins 5 is to align the
special population categories to those that are available in ESSA and also within the
WIOA plan itself. So when LEAs or the state have to address special populations we address
the same groups that we do under ESSA or any of the local or state funding or any of the
workforce development programs. So that is I think a unique aspect of Perkins 5 as compared
to the previous iterations of Perkins. A new federal focus for teacher and faculty
preparation is teacher and faculty preparation. What the plan has done is to align that new
federal focus to ongoing state efforts and looking at that particularly in terms of teacher
credentialing and minimum qualifications for community college faculty.
And lastly but not least we aligned the Perkins Accountability Framework to the California
Accountability Framework or the California Accountability Model and in the plan we detailed
quite extensively about how we have used some of the special population categories.
The variables or the indicators that are available in the state accountability framework. A good
example would be in Perkins we are asked to look at what I call secondary quality indicator
and we are actually looking at what college credit courses which is an element within
the CCI. So just to briefly go through the plan development
and consultation. As I said before it is a joint effort by several entities through the
whole the development and consultation phase. Public comment and response development was
something that is prominent within the plan as you look at the plan. There are several
sections and prompts in the plan that talk about how did you do public comment and we
also had to have public comment for the accountability piece as well and so we did that as well.
So public comment was quite critical to essentially letting both the LEAs and community colleges
know about what this plan is about. Then we talked about the state vision for
education and workforce development and in the plan we are as you heard from Tim Raney
about the interaction between CDE and community colleges and workforce development and we
have included language that Tim was referring to within the plan.
One of the things we did throughout the plan and all of the different strands and prompts
is to make reference to all of the state programming that is going on within the state and we spent
a lot of time in terms of many of the programs that the CDE is involved with, the community
colleges, chancellor's office is involved with what may be happening at the local level
and we spent a lot of time describing those programs and making that connection to the
federal effort. We made sure that the state effort was prominent and upfront and essentially
as this is just the application to the federal, to the U.S. Department of Education for those
funds. So keep in mind that when we are talking about
programs of study implementation, one of the things that we should be aware of, the Carl
Perkins Funds is a funding source, much like it is CTIG, much like it is in the WIOA, it
is a funding source. But the programs that those funding source, that particular funding
source helps are our statewide programs. So that is what we have to keep in mind is that
whether it is a state program as Carolyn was talking about both in terms of Title II
and the CAPE funds, that is essentially adult programs at the local level but using those
two sources of funds. Similarly, we do that on the CTE side and that is the one thing
we have to keep in mind when we are talking about programs and programs of study within
a CTE. As I talked before, we talked about the embeddedness
of special population in implementing these different programs in the plan. We described
a lot of these special program activities. There is a section of special programs where
we took each of the ten special program categories and described not only in terms of students
of disability but we also looked, we just spent a little time, we looked at other programs
like foster youth. We looked at homeless, what the state is doing for homelessness
and other programs that we described through that process.
The final section we looked at, a section we looked at that was new to, definitely at
the state level, it is new to the LEAs and community colleges. In Perkins, there was
always funds available for professional development. There were funds always available for professional
development. What is new under Perkins 5 is that preparing teachers and faculty has
been elevated. In most states, we meaning CTE or the community colleges are not the
ones responsible for providing that credential. So we engaged with CTC with the help of state
board staff, talked to CTC, had conversation with them about how CTE credential occurs
in California and that has been detailed in the plan itself.
The other, in this section, we talked about both recruitment and retention and we talked
about how professional development is currently taking place and what we might do as we move
forward. At the end of that section, we listed a series of questions that may be a starting
point to discuss in this area as we develop the larger comprehensive state plan.
There is a section here in that we talk about fiscal responsibility and budget. We presented
that to you last time. Nothing much has changed in that. We are still using the same way that
we allocate funds, both between community colleges and LEAs, but we also are looking
at how we divide state funding, which is about 15%, and then 85% of those funds have
to go back to the LEAs or community colleges. The new thing in fiscal responsibility is
they have raised what is called reserve funds. So off that 85%, there used to be 10% that
was for reserve funds. Those reserve funds have been increased to 15% and that gives
us an opportunity to look at areas that are critical to making CTE work. Dual enrollment
comes to mind. Industry-based certification comes to mind. Teacher preparation and faculty
comes to mind. All of those areas are something that we can use the reserve funds to move
that forward. The one section that I would admit to you is close to my heart is the accountability
section. I spent a lot of time with my colleagues within this department to try and understand
the California accountability model, the five-by-five grid, and how that relates to the Perkins
accountability framework and how they are similar but not similar also because in Perkins
they have, and that's what the state-determined performance levels are, the numerators and
denominators that there was in ESSA, the denominator is different in Perkins as the state-determined
performance levels. Then for ESSA and the state-determined performance levels asked
us to project forward to 2023, some of those we ended up using what was the state projections
but in some of them we actually, with the help of my colleagues in the assessment division
as well as within Cindy Kazanis' division, we tried to do some estimates to get the state
determined performance levels. So based on that, I want to put forward the recommendation
that is in front of you and then talk about if you have any comments and questions on
that.
Hey. We have several liaisons to this work and so I want to ask Ting's son and then
Felice Ortiz-Lacon and Patricia Rucker each to comment. Ting, you want to start us off?
All right. So this has been, as Dr. Kodemarchu said, this has been an iterative process,
I would say an extensive iterative process, and I really appreciate my colleagues on the
board, member Felice Ortiz-Lacon and member Patricia Rucker for going through this long
year and a half with me, as well as our community college partners, Jelena Grande, Bill Rawlings
and Alma Salazar who have also worked on this application with us. So I want you all to
know that we've been working on the policy end for how K-14 will work together to further
the work of WIOA and the larger state policies regarding CTE programs. This is what you have
before you, an application for federal funds. So it is not our full plan. We will continue
our work. We just want you to know that. So we did take more of a minimalist approach,
if you will, to this. We wanted to be able to set direction in this plan on where we
want to go, but it is certainly not completely fleshed out. So we want you to be aware of
that, and we hope that over the next year we'll come back to you again with a fuller
plan beyond what is here in this application. And I want to also just extend my thanks
and to Dr. Kodemurachu who came into this process, what, six months ago? Eight months
ago? Okay, and dropped in the midst of our work and has been leading this in a very complicated
state policy and state education structure. So I really appreciate his time and his work
on that.
I would like to think it's not just me. There are a lot of people, particularly in the last
month, I would like to thank Sandy for helping us with the teacher preparation piece. Without
her, I don't think we'd have what you have in front of you. And that's been very helpful
for someone like me that I would admit to you that there's one area of CTE that is not
my forte. So I relied on people like her and others as well to really produce this document.
Very true. It's been very collaborative.
It's a collaborative piece of work that we're very grateful for.
Yes.
Member?
It feels great to be at this point where we're getting ready to submit this. There has been
conversations for the past couple of years. One of the things that I find to be a strength
of this process was that we started with principles and a vision. So this is an application, but
our principles are threaded throughout. And I think that it's been a bumpy road at times,
but I think we're in a good place now to submit the application and then resume the conversation
about our larger vision for this work. One of the things that was also kind of unique
about this plan is that we have to integrate it and align it with ESSA. So there was a
lot of conversations between what ESSA meant for our work, what Perkins 5, and then the
community college. So in a way, we had a little family reunion and we're trying to figure
out what our higher ed folks do. So we've learned a lot about the work that even though
we're in the same system of educating students, we're not always using the same language or
approach. So it's been a great experience, but I'm happy that we're finally at this
point where we could submit the application.
So let me begin by saying, by channeling my dad, he used to sit at the dinner table when
he was ready to talk about his work day and he would say, you know, I love work. I'm fascinated
by it. I could sit and watch other people do it for hours. And so that's kind of what,
that's a good way of describing what happened with this process and this plan. A lot of
work, a lot of time, a lot of learning together went into the development of this packet.
And even though it is only an application and even though it only is operating at the
top line, it's 205 pages of a very important public statement about what this state says
it wants to try to do. So in that sense, it's very aspirational. And in that sense, it's
also means we are holding ourselves accountable in a very different way. And I think there's
an important point to make here. One of the things that we board members tried to do in
educating our colleagues was about our state's accountability system. And we worked very
hard to create an alignment and come to some way in this plan to make sure that it would
be aligned with very high expectations for outcomes for these programs. But there is
a very important detail and key point to make. Our state's accountability system is based
on an enumerated list of accountability principles and criteria, but also an enumerated list
of students who are the critical subgroups that we will hold ourselves accountable for.
The Perkins plan is only interested in one particular student subgroup and those are
CTE concentrators. And while those CTE concentrators will fall across all of the subgroups that
we are accountable for in our statewide accountability system, students who are CTE concentrators
are not a student subgroup in our accountability system. And so we had to work very hard to
figure out a way to find consonance between those two very distinct sets of accountability
and outcomes to make sure that the plan was both aspirational but had very tough standards
for the outcomes of these programs for these students. So what I would like to say is with
this application, it's a good start.
Are there any specific clarifying questions at this point before we go to public comment?
If not, we'll come back for deeper discussion. Any clarifying questions? Seeing none, we'll
go to public comment.
Angela DeRamos.
Good morning. Angela DeRamos on behalf of California Teachers Association. We'd like
to thank and commend the CBE and SBE for their hard work on the Perkins 5. We would like
to call your attention to the overarching need to address the key barriers to ensuring
that students have access to well-qualified educators that are credentialed in the subjects
held. The plan states that the current efforts and approaches tend to be piecemeal and suggests
that a much more integrated systemic approach is needed in building the faculty for the
faculty pipeline. CTE strongly agrees and believes that the key questions brought up
in the plan regarding the teacher pipeline are crucial to success not only of the Perkins
plan but also CareerTech Ed in general. We would also like to reiterate that there must
be alignment between the accountability for results section of the plan and the state's
current accountability goals as defined by the LCAP and the dashboard systems. Otherwise,
we run the risk of creating a lower performance expectation for CTE students, which is an
unintended consequence. Thank you. That's it. All right. Discussion.
Remember, Navo, did you turn your microphone on for?
I decided not to. Now I decided I will.
You looked like you were getting ready to speak.
It's more of a question for the board liaisons, I think. So one of the things that comes up
is obviously producing the highly qualified professional workforce to educate our students.
And what I noticed in the plan and what I recall from superintendent, which was a long
time ago, is the designated subjects for those are not required to go through any kind of
licensure or an induction program, although it's offered. They're not required to have
a certification for those designated subjects for CTE. And I know it's just a draft unless
I'm misinterpreting it. Is there a plan going forward or is that something that we need
to think about going forward as we develop these applications? It's on page 129 as I read it.
There is a certification. There's several. There is a certification process.
So when I read it, what it's telling me is that the DS CTE credential candidates are
not currently required to complete teacher induction to earn their clearance. Yeah, that's
what I'm talking about. Right. And then below that it says CTE teachers are not required
for licensure. So what I'm trying to figure out, where does the support come from?
We've got three people here who have a little connection to the commission and we're all
kind of scratching our heads. Yeah. So either I'm misinterpreting it or and I could be.
Just basically what it's saying to me is none of it's required. There is a credentialing
requirement for the initial license for sure for CTE teachers. And I did not know that
induction would have been waived. In fact, one of the things that CTE and that CTC has
been working on for quite a while is creating multiple pathways to that credential because
we now have people who come straight from industry in the traditional sense and they
add on education courses to their knowledge base about whatever their skill set is. But
we also have people coming because so many of the fields are new STEM fields and their
physics and astrophysics and things like that. We have people coming from the traditional
college majors and then needing to pick up some work experience. So there is a credentialing
structure and it looks like we're about to get some additional insight. Thank you.
We've just started to have conversations with Mary Sandy and CTC to look at different
options that we have. I know we have the designated subject and single subject, but we are trying
to explore if there are other options there. But keeping in mind that CTE is critical to
that option and just as we move forward. So we're going to start having this conversation
once we put this application to bed so to speak. I think we should just double as we're
doing our editing on this which we have included as a part of the recommendation we should
double check the wording on this so that it is not misleading. I think the one that you
are looking at is the CTE Teach program which under Perkins 4 we funded it out of Perkins
4 fund. That really is for teachers that are there so it's not really a licensure program
much more so like a professional development program. So we'll make that clear in the
language. And I think that the question is about the statement that DSCT credential
candidates are not currently required to complete teacher induction to earn their
credential. I think maybe this program is not required, that particular program, but
I think an induction program of some kind is required. So we should be sure that that's
just clarified in the language. Member Rucker? I think maybe the best way to explain this
for people in the public who don't have this document in front of them, the document
specifically says that these designated subjects credential teachers are not required to complete
teacher induction to earn their credential. There is a credential program and teacher
induction as a practice and as a policy premise posits a responsibility both for the state
in supporting teacher professional development and certification but also on the employer.
So where there isn't a state induction program, the employer has a responsibility to provide
induction. Let's remember the purpose of induction is to support the transition of teachers
beginning their profession as an educator into the work that they are doing. And so
when California created their induction program, there was a responsibility for employers
to provide professional development and support to these new credential candidates as well
as a condition of the candidates earning their professional clear credential. Remember it
is the employer, not the state, that recommends these candidates for their professional clear
credential. So probably what needed to be said here is that there's a responsibility,
even though they don't participate in a state-sponsored induction program, the employers
have a responsibility to provide that professional support for induction. That might be helpful.
Does that make sense, Dr. Hamm? Yeah, and I think we can have this all evaluated with
the help of the CTC so that we get exactly right. Right. And what I was going to say
is what we can take from this particular section, as Dr. Cardamati said, this was a section
that was not necessarily sunshineed before. So in doing that, what we're seeing is that
there are different pathways for individuals to become qualified credentialed to be CTE
teachers, but each of them have their challenges and their issues. And they're disjointed,
and it's not clear depending on the type of industry. And so it varies quite a bit. And
what we want to try to do is have some more alignment, and that integrated approach is
a public comment about a more integrated approach to the credentialing of CTE teachers. And
one that will help to invite those who are out in industry, who have those qualifications
to bring that into our education system. So there's a lot of work to be done here, we
know that. And this is one of the key areas that we want to focus on moving forward.
Are there other questions? Comments? Yes? I just kind of wanted to echo what Member
Rucker mentioned before. I know that it can be seen as just an application, but I do think
it's promising that there has been this much effort and care put into it. Like we've just
been talking about, there still is a lot of work to be done, but if we use this as a
vision and keep building upon that, I think that we'll be moving in the right direction.
All right. Do I have a motion? I will make motion, but right before I do that, I also
want to thank one other person, Patricia DeCoss, who has been a champion in this process as
well and helping to keep us all on track and moving forward in this effort. So thank you,
Patricia. All right. So with that, I will make a motion to approve the California
Department's recommendation that we approve these draft Federal Perkins V State Plan and
forward the plan to the governor's office for a 30-day review. And in addition, that we
allow the CDE in collaboration with SBE staff to make any necessary non-substantive clarifying
edits. Okay. Do I have a second? Member Ortiz-Lacone, is there any further discussion?
All right. All in favor say aye. Any opposed say nay. Any abstentions? All right. Motion
carries. Yay! Okay. Because you've been so expeditious, we're going to keep going. I
think we can finish one more before lunch. And so item five is the accountability item.
And the CDE recommends that we provide guidance on the revisions under consideration for the
2020 dashboard and take additional action as deemed necessary and appropriate. This item
will be presented by Cindy Kazanis from the CDE. You didn't think you'd be up before lunch,
did you? I was so pleased that Pradeep did so well. And it will be equally efficient.
Great. Wonderful. A nice lunch. Yes. So again, Cindy Kazanis, the Director of the Analysis
Measurement Account of the Reporting Division. It's a pleasure to be with you this morning
and walk you through what we're thinking about for this year and get your feedback on our
work plan. So this is something that we've done the last couple of March items is to
bring forward the work plan for the year to make sure we're on track for what you're
expecting for us for changes for the dashboard. So I'm going to walk you through the three
different attachments and then we can open it up for questions or whatever. President
Dirlingham would like us to do. So the recommendation is to for you to forget to give us guidance
on any revisions under consideration for the 2020 dashboard and take action as deemed
necessary and appropriate. So first we're going to start with what we're thinking about
for 2020. We have a slide that talks about beyond 2020. And then we're going to have
a whole separate attachment around the English Learner Progress Indicator. So the first one
that I'm going to talk about is student growth model, which of course has been years in the
making. Additional measures for the college career indicator, additional career measures
rather. We're going to talk through how we can stabilize or change over time the state
indicators and then as I mentioned talk a little bit about the English Learner Progress
Indicator. So after many years in development and in 2019 taking a break and talking with
stakeholders, we're ready to move forward with incorporating a student growth model
into the dashboard. I will talk a little bit towards the end about how we would plan on
doing that, but just to walk you through where we've been and where we're headed. So we
had, as you directed us in 2018 to work with stakeholders to get further input on the dashboard
or rather on the growth model including it in the dashboard, we spent 2019 working with
a stakeholder group that had been developed and facilitated through WestEd. So WestEd
provided you a memo of those four meetings that took place, a summary of that in November
last year. And in those discussions we were able to clarify goals that stakeholders wanted
the growth model to meet and help set expectations for interpretations of the reports. So of
course we've been focused on the residual gain model that you have heard from us over
the last couple of years. We're looking at in 2020 how additional modifications to this
model could enhance validity and cross time stability and as part of this we will be of
course working with our testing contractor ETS to do some of this work for us or on our
behalf. And when we think about this model as well we are also keeping in mind your prior
guidance in not including student demographics of the control variable in the growth model.
So with that in mind some of the work that will need to be done this year is to look
through or rather work with again our assessments division and with Mal and her staff on
making adjustments potentially to the highest obtainable scale score which is something
that California has adopted Smarter Balances highest obtainable scale score but there are
other states within the Smarter Balanced Consortium that have actually done some work and
adopted different scale scores. We'll think about making some technical adjustments and modifying
business rules for inclusion of student scores in the model. All that to say we will be spending time with our technical
experts and we'll make sure that when we complete this work that we take it out for
public consumption once the technical and the ability of the model has been achieved.
So in doing that I talked a little bit already about working with the test contractor now that we have
an additional year of data they can rerun the modeling that they've already done and making the technical
adjustments that we think that we're going to have recommendations for. We will bring back that same
growth model stakeholder work group that met four times last year to obtain additional
feedback and then obviously take it out to the rest of our stakeholders. So we think that
we will be talking to you about this much more in 2020. Our recommendation would be to
implement it in the dashboard for informational purposes for this year and then spend next spring
or late winter and spring talking through what does it mean? How can schools and districts use it?
But also partnering with our assessments division to highlight existing resources for parents who have
student score reports who have seen the growth on those student score reports since the inception of the
new test, the CASP test for the last five years to make sure that we also
focus on how parents can look at students score reports and then what does a
growth model actually mean in terms of using it on the dashboard? So all that to say we have
communications, a great deal of communications work ahead especially once this information
is included on the dashboard. So for the college career indicator, we of course spent
a long afternoon back in May talking through what the college career indicator was, whether it was
college and career, college or career. I think we're still at college career indicator, college slash career.
Let's just revisit that. We didn't really have a final decision. It was a study session.
But we have already spent actually four different full day meetings in
February talking to our policy work groups as well as the technical design group about
things. And specifically around the college career indicator, we not only have the alternative schools task force group, but we also
have our college career work group, our college career indicator work group, but there's an accountability
subgroup to that. So we've been getting quite a bit of feedback on the data that we've collected this last year.
So as far as additional measures, we've been really focused on the career measures and trying to do a better job in collecting
data that we didn't have prior to the college career indicator being
measured in the dashboard. So what you can see from this slide is that we are
we've been working with the groups to collect additional data through CALPADS through our student level data system. And then we've also been focused on
making sure that we have ones that represent our alternative schools, which of course is over 10 percent of our population.
So in doing that, we did collect what you see on the screen in CALPADS in 2018-19.
So the quality of this data and the quantity of this data from districts is
something that we are doing our due diligence on right now and reviewing.
There are certain aspects of these measures that had better collection than others.
And in doing that, we will bring forward to you, most likely in the summer,
what measures we think would be appropriate for inclusion in the dashboard.
What I wanted to make a comment on is some of these are limited to our dashboard alternative school status,
which of course we determined are more appropriate for them because there's not a way to demonstrate
completion of a full semester, perhaps, or something more longer that you would see in a traditional school.
But all these have come through and been vetted through both policy workgroups.
These are pieces that we're going to continue to work on this spring.
And then for the next steps, we'll make sure that the measures that we've collected
and bring forward to you are, of course, valid and reliable and can be used to determine
whether or not a student is approaching prepared or prepared so that we do have some technical work ahead of us on this piece.
I would also say just that you're going to see a slide in a couple of minutes about the additional inclusions beyond 2020.
So there's definitely interest from, I think, from you all in expanding this out,
continuing to expand out the college per indicator to make it more robust as we move forward.
So the next piece is looking at stability of state indicators.
And this is in keeping with continually improving our dashboard and looking back on the original decision that was made
four years ago in establishing cut scores for each of the indicators and making those distributions at the local education agency level.
We have determined that the methodology is relatively stable.
However, the board did take action back in November 2017 to make adjustments to the academic indicator.
So we've heard some concerns expressed in the field about the movement of colors within the indicators outside of the mathematics English language arts.
Sometimes you will see schools or districts move a couple of colors.
And why is that happening?
And so we're going to take some time this spring to also look at making sure that what we've been using continues to be stable as we have, of course,
additional data points we can better inform about how to how to proceed or if we have maybe some changes we recommend to you.
So one of the things that folks have been providing us feedback on is why can't you just adopt what we've been using for our small student populations,
which is, of course, a three by five grade, which means you've narrowed in the ability to be on the extremes.
So currently, of course, you've adopted that for the graduation rate indicator, suspension rate indicator, chronic absenteeism indicator and the college career indicator.
And these are the different cohorts that our application that we use for that that student group information.
So we'll be taking a look at the three by five as a method, but also looking at whether or not it could be applied for large student populations.
So in thinking about making sure that what we've currently been using for for our five by fives is stable, that we can justify movement of colors,
we're going to bring back to you some some options moving forward.
And one of those options would be looking at making sure it's on the next it is on the next page, looking at applying what we've done for the academic indicator to the rest of the indicators.
Eliminating the colors on each row to two colors as opposed to three.
Some of them have three colors and potentially eliminating our three by five grid.
So we'll be again getting out to not only our policy workgroups and the technical workgroups to express how we how we move forward and the recommendations we make to make sure that the system continues to be stable,
that we're not having concerns about, you know, folks moving with a drop from from a blue to or dropping down or again vice versa.
OK. And then beyond 2020, I'm going to talk through a couple of these and then move on to the English Under Progress Indicator.
We are we have actually a student intern that just graduated from UC Santa Barbara, who's helping us review potentially using the Armed Services Vocational Optitude Battery Assessment, which of course is used for students who are wishing to go into the military.
But there's also opportunities for students to get access to certain career tools by taking this exam.
So we are looking at who else uses it.
So far we've seen our neighboring state of Nevada uses it in their accountability system.
What are the benefits of it?
What are the concerns of it and potential limitations of it?
And one off the bat is we cannot get this data from the test vendor.
We'd have to actually collect it from local educational agencies.
So that is something that we're focused on.
We are also focused on as a result of your discussions last year, the state still of civic engagement.
So we've been working with Barbara Richardson and her staff to come up with a small working group that would work through how we would potentially bring state still of civic engagement, which you have not yet adopted, of course, into the accountability system.
So that is work that we plan to engage in early this year as well.
And then another pending thing that we've all been reminded of often is the inclusion of the California Science Test, the CAST into the accountability system.
So we're proposing that we would be able to work on creating status cut scores for the 2021 dashboard and a performance color for the 2022 dashboard.
So I don't know if you'd like me to pause. That's a lot before we move on to the LP.
And I do have Jenny Singh and Jonathan Issa here to respond to questions as well.
Oh, you know what? I have one extra slide before I get to attachment to that.
That would probably be better to finish this one out.
There was also in talking with our stakeholders, actually our equity stakeholders, there was a mention made about the requirement under Education Code Section 52064.5 about bringing in students with school level data received from another entity to utilize in local indicators.
And I think early on we thought a good first data set for that would be the California Teacher, the credentialing commission data.
We've had an existing data sharing group with them for several years now.
However, they've been in the midst of implementing a new data system themselves. Of course, we don't have a shared data system.
We're doing this complicated match process.
So the first time we'll have a full set of data will be this fall from them.
So we're going to be spending time once we get that data to see if it would be the language in the legislation is relevant and reliable.
So if it meets that standard, by other way, we'd bring forward to you our progress on reviewing that data set for potentially preloading that into the local indicator data set so that districts wouldn't have to input their own information twice, right?
Because they're already giving it to us through CALPADS and then through a match with the Commission on Teacher Credentialing.
So this is a piece I just wanted to mention.
The budget currently, this current year does include some funding to San Joaquin County Office of Education to start on this work.
They actually have to start over on the school accountability report card program.
They have to rewrite that program as the foundation for this work moving forward.
So there's additional funding that's proposed for next year to work on this.
This is actually a pretty big infrastructure that would have to be built.
We could do it manually in the beginning, but this is something that will take some time.
So I just wanted to mention that this is on our radar as well.
And with that, I would defer to.
Great.
Member Rucker, member Sun, member Ortiz-LaCone.
All right, go ahead.
Cindy, your presentations are always endlessly fascinating to me.
I think that either means I have no balance in my life or I actually don't understand what you're saying.
Could you go back to the slide where you had the list of other data points under consideration for inclusion in the CCI?
Some are, so my question for these, and I find this a fascinating list.
My question about some of these is, are there some differences between them like from who the data would be collected?
And also, are some of these, would they be considered as lagging indicators?
That's my first question.
So these data points are all being collected through our student level data system.
That's what I would say first.
As far as lagging indicators, they're as good as the data year we're using for everybody we've caught up.
So we would use it for the cohort of the year that we were working in.
So for 2020, we would see 2020 data from each of these measures.
Okay.
Then my next question is, as it relates to the work you did on the previous item on the Perkins Plan,
because there's a definition of what a CTE concentrator is,
you worked with the CTE folks to call the information from the student data system for the students who meet that criteria.
So I'm curious as to why CTE concentrators is not included on this list as a possible data point that could be added to the CCI.
I'm going to bring up Jenny.
She knows this like the back of her hand.
So the definition of CTE concentrators is actually a CTE completer.
That's the way it is defined in the plan.
I understand that.
And we do have, CTE completers have been included in the CCI since the very beginning.
Okay, so maybe I didn't ask my question correctly.
So for the data that you're collecting about CTE completers, is that directly related to the definition that's now in the Perkins Plan we just approved?
Yes.
Okay.
That's probably the question I should have asked instead.
And then my last question is for Cindy.
So the last slide you had was related to considerations about how to use data that would be collected by another entity.
I'm going to renew my request that, again, as it relates to the CCI and the development and collection of data points for the CCI,
there are other state entities that are funded by the Budget Act from the legislature who also collect data about our K-12 students as it relates to college going,
as it relates to CTE participation, and some of their data is more granular and more particular about the kinds of information they have.
I still think there's an opportunity for us to look at and understand those data systems as well and how we can use those data systems,
particularly from the community college chancellor's office, to also inform some of this work.
So I would like to ask you to also add a button or a dot or something to this to-do list,
because this board, while Board Member Lee Cohn and Board Member Sun and I have seen some of that and participated in those discussions,
the rest of the board doesn't know about some of the other data systems out there and the kind of data they have the ability to collect and the way they do their work.
I think it's important for us to take a look at that and consider whether or not it could inform what we're attempting to do,
because what we keep hearing a lot of times is what is the limitations of our current student data system that I believe some of these other data systems could address.
So I think that that's also an important bullet to add in particular to that particular slide.
We'll do. We do have a data sharing agreement with the community colleges and we've been giving them data.
However, we haven't received any data back, so that's on our to-do list.
And then the other thing is I would say I am a designee for the superintendent on the cradle to career work group.
And so these kinds of issues are definitely being, it's all state agencies at the table, and so it's actually brought out a lot.
I understand that, but it's not on this list.
I understand. And I think to your point, we are working with the low-hanging fruit, which is data that we've currently been getting.
We will add community colleges to the list, but I don't currently have that data.
Yeah, because I think that fruit's even lower than what's on this list.
Okay, so Member Rueck and I are thinking exactly alike. So my comments are around the CCI as well.
Great. It's really nice to see that CDE is working on all of these additional measures that can be incorporated and that you're doing a lot of research.
And I would also agree with Member Rueck that there's data out there that can be collected from other entities that you might want to explore and utilize.
I will say that as you are developing this and what I would hope is that as you're collecting this data, trying to remove some of the burden of putting more and more information by the LEAs.
But at the same time, if you're collecting data and some of this data is coming from outside of, beyond the LEA or the schools, that you somehow be able to reflect that back to the schools.
Because at this point from the CCI, information goes out into cowpads.
There's a calculation on which students end up in certain levels, but the schools and the LEAs don't necessarily know where, which students hit which levels and what you're counting.
And so it feels a little bit like they're operating a little bit blindly.
They send information in, but they are not quite sure exactly how it all got calculated.
And so as you're looking at that, especially if you're collecting data from outside of the LEAs, then somehow being able to reflect that data back to them so they can double check and see, oh, I didn't know the student was on this and that.
It would be really helpful, I think, for them.
Just to make sure I'm understanding, I think what you're suggesting is to perhaps without a report or provide a student level data set for the college career indicator to LEAs to be able to check their work.
Yes, please. Thank you. Very succinctly said. Thank you.
That is not low-hanging fruit. I want to be clear.
We're going to be evaluating how high the fruit is hanging to make all these suggestions.
It's a very difficult task for us to do.
In absence of that, though, we do make very public our business rules and we do know that there are districts out there, not everybody.
There are a few districts out there that are able to calculate this based on those business rules.
But I appreciate the suggestion and we'll add it to our list. Thank you.
Thank you.
Okay. I will see how much we can fit on one PowerPoint slide.
Yes, member Ortiz-Lacon and member Burr and member Strauss.
Okay, great.
Cindy, I just wanted to clarify one thing about the college and career readiness indicator.
We did vote on that.
It was something that we voted under the previous board, but I remember taking that vote where we did say it was and.
My question is around the student growth model, since I will miss the fun as you're all engaging in those discussions.
And I know that we are not using or we're not controlling for student demographics as many other districts have done, and I believe the core districts also do.
But we are reporting by student populations or student subgroup, correct?
Correct.
So I would want to encourage us that when we're looking at our English learners, that we do disaggregate, that we don't have to take the same definition that we've used under the academic indicator.
Since the student growth model is really matched scores and looking at that student against that student's performance a year before, that we look at an exclusive English learner progress or growth and also for our reclassified students because we want to make sure that we're able to see are they actually growing post reclassification.
So to my fellow board members, I would highly encourage you to look at a specific L2L RFIP to RFIP and not cluster our students.
Thank you.
OK.
First, Cindy, as always, I just want to say thank you.
The scope of work is kind of mind blowing and we keep adding to it.
So I really appreciate you sharing with it just to also sort of rewind the tape for a little bit to say once again that this shows how we model continuous improvement from the very beginning of the creation of the accountability system.
We said don't have all the answers.
We're going to have to revisit this all the time and adjust accordingly.
So I just appreciate how how much you keep that at the core of your work.
I also want to talk about the student growth model for just a second.
And I appreciate your comments, Felisa.
I think that's very important.
But I do think that what I want to reinforce is that I feel like that people have different uses for growth models.
And so I think as we continue to work on this and I know when we talked about the residual gain model before, it was kind of eye rolling because it was very difficult and technical and hard to understand.
But I get that that's and I appreciate the expertise of the technical design group to say that's the kind of model we need to use at the state level if we're going to use it to identify LEAs for particular help differentiated assistance.
But I think that there are a lot of other people out there who have different ideas about what a growth model is.
And at the simplest form, it's to say the same kind of thing I think that Felisa was discussing.
How are our kids progressing?
And if I'm a parent, do I have a piece of information that says to me, yes, this student is growing and they're growing, especially at transitional points.
And that's what I want to emphasize, that when they move from elementary school to middle school, when they move from middle school to high school, that they're prepared to do the work, that they are at grade level.
And I'm not sure that what we're going to get will yield that information.
So I think we need to be careful about what other ways can we communicate that and we'll hear some of this tomorrow on just preview when we talk about charter renewals.
This happens a lot with charter schools because their grade configurations are different.
They're getting students from a lot of other schools.
And in many cases, those students are way below grade level and they're not rewarded for showing the growth given the model that we have now.
So I just want us to be aware of all of those issues and be crystal clear about what a growth model will be used for, both at the state level and how we will communicate effectively student level growth, both to parents and to LEAs.
Thank you for the feedback. We haven't noted. I have staff in the audience taking good notes, too. We'll be working on this directly.
So just to follow up, since Member Burr and I are the liaison to accountability, we've been involved a lot in the continued feedback and support.
I just want to thank, again, Cindy and the team along with Member Burr about how diligent and how focused you are on trying to get this right and continue to work on it.
So with that, I'm glad that we're moving along in the student growth model.
I think the communications are going to be really, really important going forward and the stakeholder input.
There is some confusion. We have some continuity in some of the letters that we received about some of the concerns and some of the recommendations.
So I just want to ensure that we have a broad level of stakeholder engagement and that our communications that we just work really hard to try to be clear as we move forward.
The other thing I appreciated is your discussion about looking at stability of state indicators.
Because I think we've known we've had to reset some cut scores. We know we've tried to look at small schools, but I think the methodology and the stability is really important.
And hearing from stakeholders and then working with the technical design group, I think, is going to be really essential as we keep trying to continually improve and get this right.
And then I think with the English learner indicator, and we've talked a lot about that, we are we had already committed to revisiting that.
And I think your timeline is June, I believe, and I haven't gotten there yet.
We took a pause for clarifying questions, so we haven't gotten to all of that yet.
All right. So I have a few more comments and I'll wait till the rest of your slides.
Thank you. Just procedurally, Cindy invited us to take a moment and give clarifying questions on that part, but we haven't finished the item yet.
And so if you have questions on the other parts of the item, let's please hold those. You have a clarifying question on this part of the item.
So going back to the point that board member Burr made concerning the residual gain model, I agree with her that stakeholders have different goals or purposes for the use of a student growth model.
I need to say I'm actually not able to ready to vote on that part of we're not voting today.
Oh, OK, good, because I'm not sure we have a clear consensus as a board on what we're trying to do with the model, because I've heard several different points or goals for the purposes.
And none of that would be addressed or given to us with a residual gain model.
So but what I will say is this conversation has now made me appreciate my seventh grade Algebra one teacher because I understand the slope intercept formula much better right now as a result.
But yes, I'm very concerned about that.
And I think maybe there needs to be some time for us to talk about what we the last time we had this discussion, we had a different board president and he said that he wasn't ready for that conversation.
So I'm no more ready now than I was a year and a half ago for this.
And so I'm hoping we will take some time to be very deliberative and thoughtful not only about the model, but what we have as a consensus about what the model is supposed to do for us.
I think that's very important.
We've not yet gotten to public comment because we stopped for clarifying questions, but I think we're deep into the, you know, many issues in the item.
And there was, by the way, a paper from the CDE in February, which is linked here, which does get into some of those questions about what could a growth model be used for of this kind and what could it not be used for.
So I would like to allow Cindy to continue the item, but also ask you whether when we complete the item, do you want to get into that discussion today or did you want to come back around the deeper discussion of the growth model next time?
What was your plan about that?
I would prefer to come back.
So I think we can put a pin in that and say it's going to need serious discussion.
We'll put time for that on the May agenda probably.
Okay.
Great.
So if you want to continue with the other part of the item.
So I'm going to move to attachment two, and these are revisions can under consideration for the 2020 English on our progress indicator, which of course this year will have a color again, which is very exciting.
We brought this in as a separate attachment because there was a lot of questions that were brought up in the January meeting when we did not have an item.
And so we wanted to make sure to have this as a standalone conversation within within the item.
So just as a reminder, and I think we we tried to outlay this in the in the agenda item that you see before you today.
The board adopted the cut scores, of course, last November based on the same methodology that we used for every other indicator.
So status cut scores for every other indicator.
And that methodology was originally adopted by you and some of you in May of 2016.
So what the process that we do is in determining cut scores is we look at data from all local educational agencies.
We and in charter schools, of course, because they're considered local educational agencies under LCFF.
We rank the results from highest to lowest, and then we set the cut points.
And this process is described on page 18 of this technical manual.
The technical manual is actually two hundred and seventy two pages if you want to read it at any point in time.
But page two hundred and twelve actually shows you the distribution.
So I know that was a question that was asked that like, where do we find this information?
And so I wanted to make sure that we included some of this really background information that sometimes we don't get into this kind of detail with you.
But that you have it if you get asked about it or you want to talk through how this was said.
Now, keep in mind, when we made the recommendations back in November, we make recommendations for cut scores.
We don't actually then go and say, based on this, how many districts are going to be in differentiated assistance?
That's not something that is appropriate when we work with accountability systems.
We want to make sure that each measure is treated the same.
And so there's been some questions about distribution.
So let me talk through what the distribution was for the status.
And then I want to show you the same information for the college indicator just to give you a comparison.
So, again, looking at this from like a bell curve, we have the very low end, a little bit less than 10 percent.
We're in the very low for LEAs and on the high end, about six point five percent.
We're in the very high majority of our LEAs fall into the middle at forty one point eight percent.
And this is based on matched data. Right.
So we looked at any English learner that had an LPAC result from current year and prior year.
So that was about eight hundred and forty four thousand students for the college indicator.
So, again, using that same methodology, we look at the very low just under 10 percent at nine point five and the very high at nine percent with the majority in the middle at thirty eight percent.
So within a couple of percentage points of what we did for the college career indicator.
So based on this information, I just wanted to walk through.
I don't actually have a slide on this, but there was information in some of the letters.
So I wanted to make sure I said this when we when we actually ran the numbers and did differentiate assistance.
In my mind, for differentiated assistance, you need to be have the same student group in in two different priority areas.
And for English, the English learner progress indicator, you also are using English language arts and mathematics in that same indicator.
So you have to find something else outside of those three indicators to determine whether or not a district would be eligible for differentiated assistance.
So when we look at the data for our English learner subgroup, of course, the English learner progress indicator only encompasses one subgroup, English learners.
We had thirty seven LEAs and county offices of education and very low and eighty one charters and very low for a hundred of total of one hundred and eighteen.
Based on that hundred and eighteen, we like to cross other indicators in different priority areas.
Fifty seven districts were identified for differentiated assistance for their English learners student group.
That represents about one hundred thousand of our English learners.
So just over 10 percent of our English learners and includes districts such as San Juan, Vallejo, Lompoc, Santa Maria.
And I wasn't picking on Lompoc, but it came up this morning.
So I thought I saw it. Oakland, Delano, Laco, San Diego County Office of Education.
So it represents a broad scope of districts out there.
I think the other thing to keep under consideration is because we were denied the waiver by the U.S. Department of Education for being able to include our reclassified students,
we lost out on one hundred and eighty three thousand students in the indicator as opposed to 2017.
So that is a consideration that we cannot compare what we're doing now to what we did in 2017 because of because of the RFEP issue.
So I just wanted to give that sort of perspective.
And this work was done in conjunction, obviously, with with Jenny Singh's staff, but under the leadership of Jonathan.
So they did they did a lot of iterations because of the consternation we heard in the field.
Sure. So we had we looked at the data between 2018 and 2019 to see how many students have been reclassified.
And it was one hundred and eighty three thousand four hundred and sixty students.
So remember, our waiver would have included them not only in the in the denominator, but in both both parts of the equation.
So so where that would have helped demonstrate progress for some, this doesn't allow you to demonstrate progress because they're excluded from the calculation.
So with that, we will spend this year looking at well, first of all,
we're spending time now help working with our assessments division to make sure that our students are being tested.
It's very important that students get access to this test and test.
And of course, now that we're computer based, we don't have the concerns about lost tests and some of the other issues that have come up over the last several years.
So we're very hopeful that we'll have a very good data set for this this year moving forward so we can match those match those data sets between the two years or rather three years.
So with this third year of data that we'll receive, actually in the next slide, it gives you all the specific dates.
We'll rerun not only we'll look at change, but we'll also look at making sure that that the status cut scores are still they still fall in that bill curve that we we use for our methodology.
We will be bringing forward this information to not only a technical design group, but of course, we've had this long standing English under progress work group and also to other stakeholders.
We do convene a local patrol funding formula stakeholder group and then CPAC meets as well.
But here's the full complement by month of what we're doing around this work plan.
Actually, the first month I just was notified this morning that this meeting was canceled.
That takes place next week, the regional assessment meeting.
I don't know about Kabe, but we do have two sessions planned to talk through the English progress indicator there.
And one of them is actually a joint presentation with San Diego County Office of Education and Sacramento County Office of Education.
So we've got a lot of activities around rolling this out.
We want to make sure the field understands what is being done.
We know that change will bring a lot of information forward and we'll see we'll likely see districts that are in the red more so than we saw on the very low just because they need to show progress.
So that is the information for the LP.
And with that, I have two more slides and then if it's OK with you.
OK, is that we have been busy since we last saw you in November.
We've had a lot of presentations.
We've been traveling a lot and doing webinars.
So these are our latest statistics.
And this is the recommendation.
And just as an aside, we did have an article recently from Kentucky that they were looking at our methodology.
So I thought you should be aware that our methodology is potentially being used by other states.
So I'm happy to open up to questions.
Public comments.
So I do want to limit us to clarifying questions and then we'll take public comment.
And then if we need to dive in deeper, we'll decide whether we're going to do that before or after lunch.
Because we'll see where we are timewise.
So are there clarifying questions?
And I do have one myself.
You were saying earlier that previously we were including RFEPs in our calculation of English learner progress and now we're not.
I just wanted you to explain that a little bit further.
So when we moved forward with getting our Every Student Succeeds Act state plan adopted,
one of the things that we had included there was our calculation of the English learner progress indicator,
which gave credit towards students who had been reclassified.
During our negotiations with the U.S. Department of Education and Karen and I,
we're the executive director of your state board, was there in person with myself and others to explain why it was important to include that student group.
And ultimately we went forward with an administrative hearing on this waiver.
That waiver, they determined we needed to submit a waiver to allow us to include students outside the English learner student group.
And that waiver was ultimately denied.
So in bringing this back and recalculating our English learner progress indicator using this new assessment,
we were not allowed to use our reclassified students in that calculation.
And in the SSA law itself, it allows students who are English learners to be part of that group for a number of years.
That's only for the academic indicator.
So that's only for English language arts and math.
And that is not the case for the same.
That is not the case.
And in fact, in trying to apply some of the same criteria, that was why the waiver was required.
And that's why our data are not comparable.
Clarifying questions before we go to public comment.
Clarifying questions.
I know she's thinking, can I slip this in?
All right.
I do want to get to public comment.
I think we do have some folks waiting for that.
So let's get to public comment.
Will the following individuals please line up at the podium?
Martha Zaragoza-Diaz, Jessica Sacco, Savannah Campbell, Mary Perry, Brian Rebus.
Good afternoon.
Martha Zaragoza-Diaz, and I'm representing the California Association for Bilingual Education and Californians Together.
I appreciate the information provided by Cindy with regards to the LP.
However, we still have major concerns about the cut scores and the state setting very low standards for the expectation for schools and districts on the progress of English language development over time.
Based upon our review and the available LP data files, 99% of California's English learners are enrolled in districts that are not flagged for needing attention to help students progress in learning English.
It is strongly recommended that CDE and the State Board convene a stakeholder group and LP committee meeting no later than June 2020 to review the cut scores, the methodology for determining these cut scores, and to provide recommendations on how to adjust the cut scores for the LP performance.
We look forward to the opportunity to revisit the academic indicator for English learners when discussing the growth model.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, Jessica Sacco with Children Now.
I am here to say thank you to the CDE staff who shared with us the planned timeline for including CAST on the dashboard.
We're really grateful for that information.
I know the field will be excited to receive it as well.
In regards to the growth model, we are also very excited after this many years of working towards a growth model to be here today and really appreciate the members' comments as well as the staff's concern about really having a clear communications plan for how this is going to be received by the field and utilized by the field.
We would like to suggest that you consider reporting out on multiple years of data since you have multiple years of data about which you can report when you do report out on the growth model, including providing student level information, as well as encouraging staff to consider how a high school level growth model might be incorporated.
We also support the decision to not adjust for demographics.
In terms of indicator stability, we are interested in engaging those conversations as we recognize the challenges that this presents.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
I'm Mary Perry with California State PTA, and I have to echo the comments about what an encouraging process of continuous improvement this work on the dashboard has been.
We work really hard to inform parents that this dashboard is for their information, and the fact is that's a long haul, and there are always kindergarten parents.
So that kind of awareness is an ongoing piece of work for our organization in addition to the awareness about NGSS specifically.
And what we know is that parents really care about science education and really don't know that there are new standards and that implementation is slow.
And part of what the assessment system in the dashboard can do is to raise the awareness for parents about that implementation and about the new standards.
So we really are encouraged with any efforts that this board can take to elevate the visibility of those assessment measures, including the dashboard.
Thank you.
Hi there. Good afternoon, President and members.
My name is Savannah Campbell.
I'm here on behalf of Ed Voice, and we would just like to express our strong support for making a growth model a top priority on this year's dashboard.
I think Governor Newsom said it best when he said, can't manage what you don't measure.
And as a former district teacher here in California, I can't think of anything that's more important to measure than how much our students learn and grow.
I would echo comments have already been made about subgroup work.
And I think what Children Now has said about reporting multiple years of data, I think stakeholders would like to see this over time.
And as a high school teacher, I think I'd love to see this data at a high school level too.
There's plenty of LEAs that already do that with their growth data.
They have that eighth to 11th grade transition year or transition time, I think would be important to see.
And just echoing the student level reports would be key, you know, with privacy laws and all that considered for teachers to see with those beginning year rosters for parents to see and holistically understand their students' academic time.
So thank you very much.
Madam President, I'm Brian Revis speaking on behalf of the Education Trust West.
First, we want to say congratulations to member Ortiz Lee Cohen, sort of, but we're going to miss you.
You've been an amazing equity champion and we're sorry to see you go.
With regard to the college and career readiness indicator, I wanted to share.
We're not ready to ask you to adopt FAFSA completion, but I wanted to share that's something that we're looking at.
That's the free application for financial student assistance.
We think it's a powerful step in measuring whether or not someone's ready to go on to college.
We have some unanswered questions of our own, but something we're looking at you might want to consider.
And then lastly, please continue and consider expediting the work on the growth measure.
We think it's one of the most important things you can do as a matter of a course correction.
Very important for equity.
Tells us whether learning is happening at an accelerated rate.
That's what we need to close gaps.
So thank you.
Good afternoon.
Sarah Lillis with Teach Plus.
And first, we wanted to thank Cindy and her team for acknowledging, for working with us on the priority one issue and making sure we can use the data that we have in the new CalSAS system
about looking about teacher assignment and distributions.
And we think that's a really important conversation and look forward to participating in that and appreciate their willingness to work with us on that.
And again, just sort of reiterating at the danger of reiterating too much.
We are very supportive, really excited to see growth.
We're on the cusp of really implementing a growth models part of our dashboard.
And so, again, reiterate the need for communication, being very clear about communication, about what it is, how it should be used to parents, to families, to teachers, and to community members.
But also, again, sort of exploring what it means.
And I think, like our colleagues, want to look at whether or not we can include it at the high school level, particularly as it relates.
I know there's a lot of conversation about the growth model in English learners.
We have teachers who are struggling with how the dashboard, how the dashboard is being interpreted for English learners at the high school level.
And so sort of really exploring both the growth model and that.
Hi, good afternoon. I'm Erin Napdy from Public Advocates, testifying today on behalf of the Equity Coalition.
And these matters are also spread out more fully in the coalition's letter.
We also strongly agree with the comments submitted by our coalition partners in supporting the incorporation of the growth model into our accountability system, like so many other states have done.
And we'd like to thank the board and CDE staff for ensuring strong stakeholder engagement in this process and ask that continued engagement and communication with stakeholders be a primary focus as the growth model is rolled out.
The whole purpose, as you know, the growth model is to make it meaningful for stakeholders on the ground to assess improvement over time.
And given its complicated nature, ensuring that stakeholders understand the model is really necessary for it to be an effective tool.
Respectfully, we're also concerned that the state board may not be doing enough to meet its obligations under the Federal Equal Education Opportunity Act to improve, excuse me, to identify and to improve LEAs whose English learners are underperforming and who are improving too slowly.
The Equity Coalition urges the board to take another look at the LP cut scores and to make certain that they're set at an appropriate level to ensure the LEAs are making reasonable progress with their English learner English proficiency and where not the time.
Good afternoon, board members, John Afle from Public Advocates, member Ortiz Lacone, thank you for your service.
We're going to miss you.
We were surprised to see that the work on the indicator, priority one indicator, local indicator, setting objective criteria by January 2021 was not included in the staff work plan that went to the board that was set in a trailer bill last year, but very pleased to see the staff
acknowledge that that is important work to be done this year and they have reached out to us and we will be having a conversation and looking forward to making that work.
Data, we know that teachers are the single most important school level factor for time achievement and we really do need to be setting objective criteria for improving in that area, thanks.
That's it for public comments.
All right, so we can take a little more time to dive into issues and I know member Ortiz Lacone is waiting to dive in and I think member Strauss and member Pagalanan and member Rucker and you were raising your hand, but I think you were pointing, okay, anyone else?
Okay, I know that all of us received a lot of letters and we've heard from the public regarding the thresholds for the LP and I also know that we did follow the same methodology that we've used with other indicators.
One thing that was important in the past was making sure that those thresholds were based on real data, that we weren't setting something that was aspirational but perhaps not achievable.
However, I think we should probably think about our methodology because when we have the number of sites or LEAs that were identified with none or few in LA County, Orange County and Imperial County, which are the highest concentration of English learners,
to have no district or one district identified, then we should probably revisit our methodology to see if it's still an appropriate one for this indicator that it's quite different than the others, right, because we're measuring for progress.
Now we're waiting for a third year of data to give the color in the dashboard and I think that we will see a lot more red.
I don't know that districts will necessarily be ready for that reality as well.
You know, I was talking to an administrator who said when accountability was under Title III with the AMAOs, people, it was in the big money, right, now it's in Title I, but people were really laser focused on making sure that they were meeting those AMAOs and that she hasn't seen that sense of urgency since we moved to the LP.
We all thought we would see it, right, that there was a reason why move from Title III to Title I under the ESSA.
So I think that either people won't be ready to see that red indicator because very low doesn't translate to red in their minds, or they're going to really struggle to try to meet the needs of students once they get to that level.
I know that the memo alluded to maybe more sites being identified once we have the status and change, but I'm also wondering what that will mean if we move from a five by five to a three by five, because do we know, do we have a sense of what it would mean, any projections, how many districts would be identified under the five by five versus the three by five if we move all of our indicators to that same five by five, three by five.
So I would encourage us to look and see, one, what does it mean if we do have districts that will have that change next year, how many do, or this year, how many do we think we would identify under red, and then what would, can we do some data runs to see what that means under the five by five versus the three by five.
Thank you.
I think Member Strauss is next.
So I just want to talk about two areas to continue my comments, one on EL progress indicator and then the other area of science.
So I know this is the third year, and then we had agreed that we would revisit the third year once we have the data.
So I think we do really need to take a look at this indicator again and make sure we're getting it right.
I really appreciated, Cindy, the LP status distribution, the graph that you had and sort of how the LEAs are laying out, and I think that's something that we should continue to look at.
I know we have areas of our state that have high concentrations and we should really take a look if we're reflecting correctly student achievement.
But when you talked about the bilingual coordinators input, and I think that part of the stakeholders, one of the things we know in our state is we have 58 counties.
We're really big.
We're trying to get a whole system in place and trying to calibrate, and I think as we work with them, I think what we're realizing, and I think the EL leads met at the end of February.
I'm not sure if you know what that means, but they met, and they're not all on the same page as far as how they're interpreting, what they're hearing, how it's being communicated out to LEAs.
So as we build our communication, which we talked about as a real priority, I think it's important once we agree to really try to calibrate the leads in the area of English learners so that the communication across our state is as...
And I think that's actually true in accountability and LCAP and all the communication.
But in this area, my understanding was there's some confusion going on with the EL leads, and it's something that we ought to pay attention to.
My other comment on science is that we've been working on science for a long time, and I think those of us who've been at this a while realize that from the adoption of the standards in 2013 and the framework and the materials,
that still out in the field today, there are teachers who don't know what our new standards are.
They have no idea.
There is not the districts with money and funding the way it is.
Some districts are thinking about aligned materials for next fall, but more likely it's the year after.
It's a slow process, and it's a long time in coming.
So I really want us to continue to stay aware of the science issue.
But the thing that I've now become aware of is that there...
And I'd like you to clarify what you know about the fact that we had committed a couple years ago that when we had valid and reliable data, we would look at an indicator for science.
And now we're hearing from the feds that that may...
We've been trying to make the California system and the federal system one system, not two systems.
And now we're hearing that the feds have some concerns about the number of academic and non-academic indicators and what that mean to one single system.
So I just would like you to clarify a little bit about what we're hearing from the feds, what work we'll have to do on that.
And because we did make a commitment that we would have a place for science, and yet we're hearing some different communication from the feds.
Sure. And let me be clear, we haven't directly asked the feds about bringing the Fed's main U.S. Department of Education, bringing the science test on board as a standalone indicator.
We would definitely have to revisit our state plan.
And one of the negotiation points that actually Dave set was really instrumental in getting us to a point where they could agree to our state plan was to talk about the balance between non-academic and academic indicators.
And so as soon as you introduce a new indicator, we now have a potential imbalance for those indicators.
So we need to start those discussions based on our past experience.
These things take a long time and they've changed staff tremendously in that place, in the department as a whole.
And so the folks that we were working with before are no longer in the capacity they were in.
So I just, you know, unlike the English Learner Progress Indicator, which, of course, has been around and we were able to retool and such, CASA is a whole new ballgame.
So we need to make sure that we start those conversations, which was what we signaled in the item that we needed to do, to see how we can come up with a balance of indicators that they'll agree to.
Can I clarify that while we would think of science as an academic indicator, the Department of Education has been ruling that it's not an academic indicator.
I know. So that's the balance that Cindy is referring to.
And that could, that interpretation could evolve over time.
There could be a new ESSA in a year or two.
Yeah, there are lots of ways in which that might unfold.
But right now, that would mean we would have to rebalance our other indicators to have a preponderance of weight in the academic indicators.
And we've tried to make sure that each of our indicators are equally weighted.
And I think this introduces other potentials.
And I don't know that you would all want us to go there.
So we just need to explore our options.
Perfect. Thank you.
So I would like to also agree with member Ortiz-Licon because, you know, methodology can kind of seem very concrete in that it's always, it's always correct.
But it's also important to recognize what's happening in real life when you're seeing the results and just making sure that English learners are really getting the most help needed.
And I had a question about, I know we were going to say we're going to save the growth model discussion, but I have just one question.
So not being here before and reading the agenda item, it says that the SB directed the CD to further explore the residual gain model.
And I was just curious, did that mean that the other models were not at all explored?
If we are thinking about not necessarily going that route or clarifying where this is going, were those other models also explored?
They were definitely explored.
There was there's actually been several several meetings in which these were discussed and where the board landed was residual gain model most aligned to the priorities that the board set out.
I think the board meetings date back to 2016 on bringing this to that to conversations.
But it's obvious from the discussion this morning and this afternoon that we'll need to spend a little bit more time talking about what so what what does this mean?
How is this going to be used?
And then I have one more one more thing, just kind of a side note.
But hearing from districts, I think I think it's important.
There's a lot of amazing things that I think we're reaching towards.
But I do also think that it's important to look back at exactly what we have that's existing.
A lot of superintendents and districts are talking about how they still sometimes parents are confused.
It's still a little complicated.
And there still is time needed to work on what's already existing maybe before like super extreme measures are taken because, you know,
everything existing, even though it might seem completely stable, still, you know, need some improvement.
So find that balance between working on what's already existing and then also, you know, working towards, you know, more drastic improvements.
But we can come to member son after that.
So let me begin by saying I'm not going to comment about the science indicator, because if I did, Linda would have to order me to take a seminar.
So so I am going to talk a little bit about the LP.
I read with great interest and concern the letters that we received.
And I took them personally, not because I'm a board member, but because I'm a former classroom teacher.
And I remember my students who were English learners.
And if I knew then the things that I'm supposed to understand now in this discussion,
It should not be hard to figure out whether how we're using the indicator is giving us the information we're supposed to have to identify districts whose students are not performing as we expect.
So I was shocked. I was amazed. I was aghast at the districts that were not included.
I was shocked. I was amazed. I was aghast at the number of English learners whose test scores on the LP were not included.
I was shocked. I was amazed. I was aghast that in a state as large as ours that has as many English learners as we do that not all of them seem to be getting tested and reflected in this data point.
So I understand that people are still learning something about this work.
But I'm going to say again, if I as a classroom teacher had this tool to use when I was in the classroom, it would have been so much more helpful to me.
And it would have helped those students that I taught as a result.
So the fact that we are not pushing harder to make sure that this data is used and is provided in a way that is useful is of great concern to me.
I am concerned that we still continue as we are developing and living with the question that we're not we're not developing an answer that moves the conversation forward.
So it is emotional and it is personal to me.
And I'm and I'm so sorry to see Board Member LeCone leaving us because I can't be the only one up here that feels this way and that responds this way.
I'm wondering whether what you're responding to is something that was in the letters that I think Cindy tried to correct some of the data on a few minutes ago.
So I think that while there's always reason to be concerned about how we're understanding what needs to be done with English learners,
there are many more districts that are identified for differentiated assistance than were reflected there and many more students were tested than was reflected that data just were not completely accurate.
Members.
Thank you.
And just it's my experiences as an English learner very early on when there was no English learner programs or even identified.
I appreciate your comments.
I actually my comments was on back on the growth model and I having heard the conversations again I just want to encourage that maybe we have those conversations sooner than later.
There are a lot of folks here who are very excited about this growth model and I don't want us to disappoint if we don't have the initial conversations before CDE goes and does their technical work.
I think we are going to be working against each other.
So I just encourage us to have that conversation.
And it is extremely important in the context of looking at some of our students who are not have not been supported properly or not have performed well traditionally.
And we need to set something up so that we can really assess and support those students moving forward.
So this is not an item for vote or action.
It's an item for giving input.
We have given a lot of input.
I'm sure that it's been well recorded and well received.
Just to summarize I think that we're many of us are saying we want to come back.
We want to talk about the growth model.
We probably need another conversation on the LP so that we can continue that depth of understanding.
And then the third one I would add to that is just to the point that there is also to be added to the dashboard the information about teacher qualifications that we ought to bring that back also for more examination.
I think I've captured the sense of the group.
And with that it is lunchtime.
We thank you Cindy for that wonderful presentation and all the work that went into it.
And we will reconvene at how much time are we allowed to give ourselves for lunch.
Forty five minutes.
Yeah, we'll we'll say 115.
Okay.
Welcome back.
We're going to resume our agenda with item six, which is the special education item.
The CD recommends that the state board approve the SSP prepared by the special education division to be submitted to the US Department of Education Office of Special Education programs by the mandated submission date of April 1, 2020.
This item will be presented by Kristen right from the CD.
Kristen, please begin.
Darling Hammond and members, can you hear me.
Excellent.
Before I start this, can I just take one moment to give a special thank you to Nikki Sandoval and to Felisa Ortiz and cone for their incredible service and support around students with disabilities.
Nikki, thank you for being the liaison all this time your thoughtfulness and humility and brilliance have been so deeply appreciated and will be very much missed on the special education commission and Felisa Thank you.
Not just on behalf of your support for English learners, but for students with disabilities and students with disabilities who are English learners.
I know you will all continue to fight.
So thank you.
So my name is Kristen right and I am the director of the special education division here at the California Department of Education.
And I'm here today to ask for your approval so that we can submit this next report of our state systemic improvement plan.
This is part of a multi-year plan that you've heard about from for a number of years, and that we've been reporting to you on.
And so we're not.
We're stuck.
Chad will help.
Thank you.
So just to really quickly recap what the state systemic improvement plan is.
This is one of our requirements.
Remember last meeting we worked on the federal indicators one through 16.
This is indicator 17, which was added much later in the process under the Individuals with Disabilities Education Act.
And this is our multi-year plan for improving results for students with disabilities.
And last month or two months ago, you approved our annual performance report, which was all the data as well as and what was happening with the federal indicators around students with disabilities.
This is every state's opportunity to do something around improvement in many states did much small took much smaller bites of the apple, if you will.
They did really specific sort of almost research kind of projects around working with single student groups within the students with disability student group and even focus on specific schools.
California decided to go big, and it was at a time when we were just rolling out the local control accountability plans.
We were trying to figure out where special ed fit with all of this.
The task force report, I think, was just getting ready or just come out.
And so this was really used as California's big vision and vehicle around how we're going to make sure to help create that one coherent system of education.
So, you know, the annual performance report consists of those indicators.
This is indicator 17.
This process started in 1314, which was actually prior to the task force report and when the LCAP and the accountability system was just kind of getting started.
And so the purpose was really to achieve coherence and alignment about across state and federal systems to realize one system of education, which we had not coined at that point.
So the phases that we walked through were now in phase three, which is sort of the final before the final report to basically talk about our progress.
And I'm happy to report that we've made a considerable amount of progress in the state around the system's coherency, unbelievable progress, in fact.
And so with local control funding for you kind of being a driver around the conversations, the state systemic improvement plan kind of came up at the same time.
And it really helped special education become part of those conversations.
And many of you were there for that.
So the original theory of action, if you notice, actually talks about the LCAP and that being the vehicle for sort of hopping on the train to get this coherency.
And so, as you know, because we've used the Pacman charts and shown you a million times over that overlap between student groups, that really that was also another guiding force in really how special ed entered the conversation.
Understanding that students with disabilities or also students in poverty, they were also English learners and they were also foster youth with one in four foster youth being a student with a disability.
And altogether of students with disabilities, 70 percent of them being represented in the local control funding formula.
So really not they're in a separate system.
They are all part of the same conversation that we're having.
And you guys have done such a wonderful job at including special education in the conversation.
So the summary of phase two, the implementation plan.
Again, our accountability system was in transition.
Our infrastructure was changing.
We use this as the vehicle and to that coherent approach.
And now that we're in phase three, we really want to report out on our progress.
And so today, this presentation, I'm going to give you a little bit of this so that you can vote appropriately whether you want to send it forward or not.
Hope you want to do that.
And then we're going to I'm going to ask Carla Estrada to come up and talk about our unique partnership we have with the CCE around assisting the improvement of students with disabilities.
And then we've brought a district in one of our technical assistance projects to show you just how this is actually impacting students, which we hear from you often that that's what you'd really like to see.
So we have made significant progress, as I highlighted before.
One of the major latest undertakings is around the Selpa leads as part of the state system of support.
So we really sort of put Selpas in a more of the overarching role, not just for the local parenting role, but really to help build statewide capacity around how do you serve students with disabilities and improve the outcomes for students with disabilities.
And Carla will talk about them in a few minutes.
Those are the ones that have been awarded from the past year from the first time the Selpa leads were awarded, and the only time so far, and they are hard at work, creating resources at every level at the foundational level so lots of general resources for the whole, as well as specific
targeted resources to help Selpa directors work with their districts to provide more support.
So the special education division as part of our activities and our requirements under the Individuals with Disabilities Education Act, as many of you know, we receive around $1.4 billion a year in IDEA funds to support the monitoring and improvement and procedural safeguards for students with disabilities.
And within a little bit of funding that we have at the department for technical assistance, we do contracts and provide services for technical assistance through some of our county offices and other providers that have specialty areas of expertise.
And there's some that are highlighted here on the slide. And today we have our Supporting Inclusive Practices Project, which is one of our signature projects doing work with districts around system coherency, specifically to increase the outcomes for students with disabilities in their least restrictive environment or closer to general education.
So we, as a strategic partnership, from the beginning with the California Collaborative for Educational Excellence and my partner in crime here, Carla Estrada, who will be up in a minute, we continue to align our own technical assistance with the needs of the field, whether it be around differentiated assistance or what we're seeing in our own data.
And so one of those highlighted areas, as you know, that the state could use an additional boost is around access to general education. And so if our theory of action is that great first instruction is the primary driver of student outcomes with a great teacher, that we want to make sure all kids have access to that great first instruction and that special education and our brilliant special educators are able to do their work as well in partnership with general education and not instead of.
So we asked ourselves as part of our evaluation questions over the years, and this is what we reported on in the report and I won't read through all the questions, but just so you know, we have our own evaluation that we ask of ourselves each year.
And as part of our ongoing monitoring activities, we're also embarking on an evaluation process we're putting in place to see are the things that we're monitoring for and everything that we're doing in the special ed division is that mapped towards improving student outcomes.
We're not just doing it for compliance purposes, but we're doing it to have real change.
So our data that we used because the US Department of Education Office of Special Education programs really wanted states to have specific data points that are directly related to students.
When you're trying to talk about systems coherency and you're trying to make that tie to student level data, that takes time.
Right. We did see increases this year as you know, although slight across most of the areas around assessment and are slowly continuing to go up about 1% a year around least restrictive environment.
But we looked at two of our signature projects. One, our sums our California scale up multi tiered system of support, which you have seen presentations from Orange County and Christine Olmsted about the scale up in California around that, as well as our supporting inclusive practices project that you'll hear about from our folks in a minute.
But what I wanted to say about those is, is although those are at county offices and they work with us, we work directly with them. We at the Department of Education are responsible for the contracts and grants and working in close collaboration with our partners across the state to make sure that we are all on the same page around being able to scale all these activities.
One of the things that I also want to highlight, and we've talked about this a little bit in the last couple previous meetings, is really cannot accentuate enough that casemath to CALPADS transition, that eliminating the special ed data system and migrating it into that larger data set, which I think is going to provide us with a lot of rich information over the next few years to really get to root cause analysis for our districts and schools.
And so one of the things that the Office of Special Education Programs wanted to make sure of is that states are really looking at their own data quality. This allows us to continue to upgrade our data quality.
So we have the one single data system. We've put a lot more validations in place, and for the data wonky people who like to talk about data validations and data reliability and validity, this is a huge step in the right direction.
And it really does encourage the relationships at the local level because where does the data come from? It comes from the local districts and schools who now have to talk to each other about their special education and general education data.
And that has presented some challenges that we've been able to walk through around really getting people together to talk about their data, which has been really exciting.
So as part of our measurable result that we're asking you to approve and send forward as part of the state systemic improvement plan, we used assessment.
And you know the data, you were presented to it a number of times, but this is the data that we used to move forward.
For most of the areas for ELA, we definitely met our targets, although we'd like to see obviously a lot greater improvements for students with disabilities over the next few years.
And so as we continue this work, we feel like in some ways we've been doing this a long time and in other ways we're in the infancy of this work because our structure has really been now developed where we can start actually, you know, still putting some of the pieces together, but we're really starting to see some movement.
And I know our folks who are working with the districts will talk about that.
But we will continue to maximize and get every bit out of this state systemic improvement plan we can to have a seat at the table.
And I'll tell you that we don't have to ask to be invited anymore.
We are part of the team and part of the invitation on the automatic, but we are also internally streamlining and integrating our monitoring processes.
And so you may hear things about a mega letter that came out to all the district superintendents that basically spelled out all of the activities that every district was involved in last year with the special ed division and will be involved in this year.
And I think we finally landed on a version 33 of the letter.
Once it got out after it went through a lot of people's lenses.
I think it was still more than seven pages of information, but it's all in one place.
And what we've heard in the past is it's so hard to understand what all these different pieces are when we get them at different times and in the mail and in our email.
So it's all in one place and we'll continue to improve that.
But just so you know that that's out there and districts have all that information in one place.
So I am going to transition now into our next set of slides, which are not in this set, apparently.
Chad, I could use your assistance.
I'm feeling really old right now.
That's it. Thank you.
So I'm going to transition to introduce Carla.
But but if there are any questions about what I just presented, maybe we can take those now.
Chair Darling Hammond, clarifying questions.
Do you want me to clarify the meaning of clarifying?
Because I want to be sure that we save the big discussion until after public comment.
But yes, please, clarifying questions now for Kristen.
All right. OK, we can move on and then we'll we'll come back to you.
We will have wonderful. So so at the end, what we do need from you is that ability to be able to move it forward so that we can send it on to the U.S. Department of Education.
So as we are now moving from this big idea, this big dream of having one coherent system of education, we do now have a system of support that has come to birth.
And we're really excited about the work that we've been doing collaboratively with our county offices of education,
with the California Collaborative and with the state board around having a shared partnership in trying to increase outcomes for all students,
but students with disabilities in particular. So I'd like to invite Carla Estrada to come up.
She's the director of the Systems Improvement and Innovation at the California Collaborative for Educational Excellence.
And we work very closely together to ensure that we are on the same page and that we're giving consistent messaging to the field and to our partners.
We serve as sort of co-parents to the self-elites. And and so our have have it's been really nice to be in lockstep and being able to have partners in this work because we know that it's not any one person or entity that can do this alone.
And I'll hand it off to you, Carla.
Good afternoon, board members.
So what I'd love to share with you are some highlights of how we've really within the system of support started to really work together in being able to meet the needs of our students with disabilities.
I'd like to highlight some examples of where that's actually happening, but also share with you some reflections that we've had so far since we've been able to within the system of support identify these leads and knowing that we need to just keep getting better.
There's a lot more work to be done. We're fully aware of that. We see that in the data. And so how do we continue to engage in continuous improvement ourselves as a system of support?
So just as a reminder, the system of support really serves as a resource, a network, if you will, of being a connector of best practices, as well as being facilitators to other counties, as well as other LEAs that are engaged in these kinds of best practices.
And then also, they're meant to be a resource to ensure that our school districts and our charter schools and other schools are able to receive the type of support that they may need based on their data.
And so just as a reminder, again, this is really a web of opportunities that we're trying to create throughout the state.
Also, as a reminder, we have leads that have been identified today. I'm going to focus more on some of the work that the GEO leads have been doing as well as the SELPA leads.
But we've also had other partnerships, as I will highlight as well, with other leads within the system of support. But just as a reminder, here are who they are and where they exist throughout the state.
So our geographic leads, their real purpose is to build the capacity of county offices to address issues of inequity.
Two examples that I think that are important and very focused around students with disabilities are Kern County and Chasta County.
So Kern County has been partnering with the SELPA system improvement leads to really look at not just the outcomes, but the data that they're using to be able to engage in continuous improvement.
One thing is you see districts go through cycles of improvement, really trying to understand like a root cause.
What we're finding is sometimes being able to look at the data from different perspectives.
For example, state and federal performance indicators, as much as academic performance and so on, requires you to dig deeper and really push yourselves.
And so the system improvement leads have been hard at work in being a resource to county offices as they engage in these kinds of continuous improvement conversations or
differentiated assistance. And Kern County is a great example of how they started to do that.
Another county is Chasta County Office of Education, who's really been partnering with the Placer County SELPA in being able to implement and really build capacity at the local level around universal design for learning.
And I think this is really important because one of the things that we hear very clearly from our Northern California partners is that they share how hard it is to access some of the resources within the system.
Because being able to commute and travel and being able to access these things is something that could take multiple days.
It's not just coming to one day of training. And also they've got to make sure locally they're building that capacity.
And so the nice thing with the Placer County SELPA is that they've been going out to Chasta and Trinity and other partners to be able to help build local capacity, coach, be a reflective partner where they are rather than expecting folks that come to them for every training.
And so I think that's something to really pay attention to as we think about some of our communities, especially our LEAs, who really do want to participate in some of our offerings and trainings and things like that, but it's just very difficult to do so.
So we're looking carefully to see how they build this out and how we can think about that as a larger system.
So as a reminder around our SELPA leads, their primary roles to build special education, our SELPA's capacity to support LEAs in achieving their goals and actions and services identified in their local control and accountability plans.
And as again, as Kristen had shared, these are our different leads with different roles.
So we have the system improvement leads who are focused on data quality and literacy, continuous improvement.
Meanwhile, our SELPA content leads are focused on English learners, students with disabilities, evidence based practices, especially for children with autism.
Others are focused on universal design and also thinking about how augmented communication can be used with UDL in mind.
So they've been really expanding that work as well as our disproportionality SELPA, who's focused on really helping that we create a better predictive analysis of understanding of who are kids who are at risk and how do we know that and how can we respond to that?
So a couple highlights of how they're starting to work with LEAs directly, because I think this is the other thing that although they're working to build capacity of the SELPAs, how are then the SELPAs working with the LEAs?
Ultimately, that is the goal, not just building the capacity of SELPAs.
We have a lot of SELPAs who also have some really great resources.
And so how do we also leverage what is already existing and making sure other people are aware based on a particular area of need, like disproportionality, that they know that it exists?
And I think a really exciting one with our South County SELPA on disproportionality is they're using design thinking as part of that process.
So how do we disrupt issues of inequity if we're just going to keep looking at the problem with the same lens?
How do we start to really think differently about issues around disproportionality?
We've known for a long time who is over identified or under identified.
We know who's not getting services or are experiencing inequities like suspensions and so on.
And so what are we going to do differently about it?
And they really frame it around awareness, action and scale.
And so they've been working with administrators and teachers, parents and community members and SELPAs on how do you use design thinking strategies to be able to disrupt what you're seeing around disproportionality?
So they've started those kinds of partnerships with particular LEAs.
We also have our Imperial County SELPA who's done a phenomenal job of really bringing together the EL roadmap, looking at what we know we're seeing in the data as far as performance for our English learners and our English learners who are students with disabilities and really also leveraging the recent guide, which is just wonderful to see in the state of California.
Trust me, a lot of people nationally are paying attention to the fact that we have a guide around English learners that are also students with disabilities.
And so how do we leverage resources, CDE's team, Veronica and others who've been working with us from the EL department to make sure that as we're building out communication, we're making sure it's in alignment to the work Kristen and Veronica are both leading in the state, but also making sure that the SELPA LEAs can really be a resource to other districts as they're struggling with how to be able to meet the needs of language acquisition as well as disability impact.
They have been working with counties to build their skill capacity or developing modules in partnership with the CDE to be able to use this guide more statewide.
Then we also have our SELPA from Marin County who have been leading our work around evidence based practices.
They've been growing regional teams throughout the state of California from the SELPAs to be able to be in depth coaches that could then support other SELPAs and other LEAs in being able to implement evidence based practices for kids with autism.
This is definitely a population that we find sometimes folks are really struggling with like how do you implement the work knowing that our students are all very different.
There is a continuum and so the continuum and need looks different.
So how do you make sure that locally people are available to support?
And so their strategy has been very much focused on building these kinds of regional teams through the SELPAs and then building their capacity to be strong coaches and trainers as they work with LEAs.
And so eight teams have already been identified and we look forward to seeing that continue to grow to scale.
We also have our open access SELPA which is Placer County SELPA.
They have been already off and running making sure that resources available around universal design for learning are available for folks online.
And so we include their website here as well because I think there's so much there that folks could really be using now.
I think the other piece of it is that they're also building regional teams working currently with different SELPAs and county offices and LEAs.
So they're welcome LEAs to be able to apply to be regional team members with the idea of being able to implement and be a resource to other educators on implementing universal design for learning.
We're really excited to see how they, for example, I shared with you earlier, been partnering with Shasta going out to help them.
One of the things that I've been hearing from folks, especially around the SELPA lead, has been how much they've been willing to come out to them.
It's not a we're offering a training and you come to us very much of where is the need and can we get more local, which I think especially if we're trying to build capacity, people need to feel that it's closer to them than further.
And then lastly, our system improvement leads are another group that, again, it's so impressive to see how our SELPA leads have just continued to build the resources, be responsive to the things that folks say they immediately need.
And so the system improvement leads have put out a variety of tools, one being the state performance plan and indicator guide.
So as we talk more about our state performance indicators, what are the connections that we should be seeing with those performance indicators and other data that we have available to us?
And so they've created a tool in partnership with the CDE to be able to create something very easily accessible, which I think people have really appreciated and provided training around how to use that data then for continuous improvement.
So that's the level where they've been able to get more local.
The next resource that they've created is the data quality toolkit, which is also available now for SELPA.
So one of the things that folks have really been struggling with is how do you bring all these data pieces that come in different places, how we put them together and be able to generate reports that when we're doing differentiated assistance, for example, that we'd be able to share with our LEAs or be able to serve as information that we use to do some root cause analysis.
So this is their website to be able to it's gone live, it's available for folks so people can start using it now.
And I would say the last thing that's a highlight for them, I think, is that they're also putting a conference together in April focused on system improvements and looking at data literacy, data quality, as well as continuous improvement focused on students with disabilities.
And locally, these are just a couple of the partnerships that they've already started with in order to make sure they're building capacity with county offices as well as school districts.
I know I've shared a lot around all of them, and so I wanted to make sure you were aware if you have a handout that highlights what their main purpose is, their key focus, as well as their websites and resources that are already available, as well as training and other opportunities to be able to access them.
And I also want to make sure the public saw that these things were available to them so they can access them.
I think one of the things as we dive into more of like next steps is we have a lot of work to do around communication.
I think we're trying to really reflect on what has been working, what has been successful, what are actually people accessing and want more of so we can grow.
But also recognizing that are we actually saturating the system too much with too much that everyone's offering in that we could be actually leveraging more of the talents within the system of support.
And I think there's some examples. So for example, the self-leaning disproportionality work has partnered with the equity lead in San Diego, as they were putting out their equity conference and other type of activities related to equity.
And so there you see a strong partnership growing with a lead. Could we see more of that?
I think a lot could be the same thing could be said for different leads, but I think we could do an even better job of being more systematic together.
And so we are Kristen and I are working together to engage and facilitate that kind of reflective thinking with the sample leads.
We really try to model that continuous improvement is not just something we talk about that we need to engage in and take a pause to make sure that we're meeting the ultimate goal of this grant.
And Kristen, you want to share a little bit more about next steps?
Sure. And so we definitely it's been exciting to see the integration of the sample leads into the larger system of support and really starting to work closely with the geo leads in terms of we all know that we all need to build capacity around special education.
And we've spent a lot of years talking to ourselves, and it's nice to be going out and talking to others too.
So one of the ways that we want to make sure to demonstrate to you that this isn't just theoretical and we're not just having a good time talking about it all day, is that that we are really partnering directly to support our LEAs utilizing what we have across the state.
California is very vast. And so we know in order to to grow things, we cannot do it alone and need our partners.
And so we've been working closely with SELPA, but also with our county offices of education and our districts as well as our lead agencies to try to bring this all together and kind of get a common message.
And, you know, I don't know about you, but I feel like we are as a state kind of all on the same page right now around that common message around belonging and equity and the fact that we believe in every single one of our students and want to give them the best opportunities we can.
And so as we think about what's happening in the trenches, we have a couple of our shining team here to talk to you a little bit about.
Thank you, Carla, to talk about what they're doing in the field.
And so it's a great pleasure to ask Kevin Schaeffer and Kristen Brooks to come up.
And Kevin and Kristen are two of our, they work, both work in different county offices.
Kristen works in Riverside County and Kevin works in El Dorado County, and we'll let them tell you a little bit more about themselves.
But we are in a deep partnership with them because, as I described before, they are one of our technical assistance projects under the Individuals with Disabilities Education Act.
So they're funded and supported through some of our T.A. dollars.
And so we are we contract with those county offices and then work in partnership with some of my staff in the special ed division for this project to be a project.
So I think we need to get your PowerPoint up. So if you want to bring that up right now and.
I'm going to go ahead and hand it off to them. And then at the end, if there are other questions or anything that you need us to come back up for, please let us know.
Good afternoon, President Darling-Hammond, members of the board. It is an honor to be here before you today and share about our project.
My name is Kristen Brooks, executive director with Riverside County Office of Education and supporting inclusive practices.
And I'm Kevin Schaeffer, director of program support through the El Dorado County Selfies and the Supporting Inclusive Practices Project.
And in just a few moments after we're done talking about our project and sharing some information, we're going to bring up Dr.
Catherine Mahoney from Arcadia, which is the real information you want to see and hear about in terms of right down to the district and student level.
So our objectives in sharing with you today are just a few, one around providing an overview of our project, supporting inclusive practices, sharing lessons from the field and recommendations for this work as we continue to build capacity and scale throughout the system.
And then, as I mentioned, learning about Arcadia's journey specifically within this project, work that they're doing collaboratively with us, but as well as kind of flying out of the nest on their own and doing the great work on the ground.
So the focus of our project is to support district leadership teams in their intentional design and redesign of pre-K through 22 systems and supports for inclusion and achievement.
And it's specifically for students with disabilities because this is out of the special education division.
But we really want to emphasize that we're talking about all kids.
We're talking about students with disabilities, but we're also talking about students of color, foster youth, students identified as English learners, low income, the range, right, as well as students with significant cognitive disabilities and those identified as gifted and talented in shared safe spaces and shared learning environments.
So although we're talking about students with disabilities, we never leave out that we're really talking about all kids in all spaces.
And that envisioning starts first and then we build capacity, we implement scale up and pay it forward.
So once we learn how to build this system and scale it up, how do we support others in the same journey across California?
And it's really centered on culture, policy and practice.
So as part of the cultural piece of what we work with our liaison, we've taken it back to the student level.
And that's the question that we get often.
How do you impact student level outcomes?
And one of the ways that we've implemented just really over the past year and a half or two years, we've taken it back to the student level.
And that's the question that we get often.
How do you impact student level outcomes?
And one of the ways that we've implemented just really over the past year, year and a half is looking at identity,
looking at intersectionality of identities and then also bringing in self-reflection on implicit bias, privilege and power.
And we look at that through the lens of how is there a barrier potentially created by our belief system as adults and how we interact with students of varying identities?
So we help our teams understand what identity and what intersectionality is.
And then we also have them go through a couple of activities and looking at implicit bias and how we approach students who we may not understand their particular identities and how those identities intersect.
So that self-reflection piece is critical to this conversation.
And again, we're not focusing solely on students with disabilities, but we're looking at sexual orientation.
We're looking at race. We're looking at language.
We're bringing all of those conversations together.
And then we pull out disability and we look at that one identity and help our teams understand that it's an identity of deficit.
And if we approach students with disabilities through that lens or mindset that they have a deficit in who they are,
then we're not going to make any inroads in progress for inclusion of students with disabilities.
And as Kristen said, we have to look at the whole system and how they got there and how the implicit bias could be that reason for disproportionality in the end result.
So we ask the question, how does that perception, that adult perception impact student experience and outcomes?
And then we also in the envisioning phase really help our teams understand what inclusion is, what inclusion is not, and help them to identify what their vision for inclusion is.
And we get a lot of comments on what inclusion is not.
And there's a lot of connections with our LEA saying, you know what, we've experienced that before.
We've experienced dump and hope.
We've experienced putting students with disabilities in general education classrooms with an untrained aid and calling it effective inclusion.
It's actually just integration. And they're in a space.
We talked about the differences between mainstreaming inclusion,
whether or not students experience a community or a sense of belonging or they're just put in an environment to say that we are in compliance with our LEA indicators.
Line of sight inclusion.
You've all seen that cartoon with the three phases with the kids looking into the baseball game and there's the wall in the boxes and the very last one.
The fence is still there, but they can see all of the other students playing the game, but they're not participating.
That's line of sight inclusion.
And then if we're going to do this work for compliance only, then it's not going to be scalable or sustainable.
So we have those really hard conversations on why are you doing this work and why is it important to you?
Is it because you didn't meet your indicator targets or because you truly feel that it's a mission to have students with disabilities included effectively in general ed classes?
So this is really our conceptual framework.
And this comes out of the work of Booth and Aidsco out in the UK, but very much applies to us out here and really talking about the foundations of culture,
policy and practice.
So what is the culture that our districts have?
What do they believe about all kids?
What are the policies that that are being enforced that support that culture and that belief about kids?
And then what are the practices that are happening in the classrooms?
When we presented before, we talked about how we can't just have really nice vision and mission statements on the walls of our boardrooms.
We have to really walk the talk, right?
And so and how is that getting down to the student level?
We don't want to sit around conference tables and talk about the way that it should be or could be and talk about going slow to go fast and not making any forward movement.
But really, how are we getting down to the student level to make progress?
Because that's what our work is all about and leadership at all levels driving this work.
So we're not just talking about our cabinet members or even our site team administrators.
We're talking about what are our parent groups?
What are our union leaders telling us?
What are our students telling us that we need to do to be more inclusive in our practices?
So we have created this blueprint for inclusion.
You may have some of our members here may have seen this before.
But our blueprint is really centered on research from both the educational world and the business world, really in terms of innovation of ideas and change ideas and change management.
And so oftentimes our districts will jump to implementing, which is the third phase of our blueprint.
They'll see the data, they'll see the dashboard light up red and in need reaction say, let's implement.
We need to go full inclusion tomorrow. We need to be a co-teaching institution tomorrow.
This needs to happen right now because look at our data.
And there wasn't really that planning and that forethought and bringing everybody together and saying, OK, what is our current state?
What is our desired state? How are we going to get there?
How do we envision this together?
And when we have our meetings, who's missing from the table?
Who needs to be here to have these conversations?
So having that cohesive leadership team looking at our vision, mission and values and are we again really walking the talk?
Where do we want to be in terms of our of our long term outcomes?
Communicating with clarity and urgency of purpose.
Sometimes our districts are telling us, well, we tried that.
We tried that inclusion thing and it didn't work.
Our teachers were really inundated and afraid of what was happening toward this inclusion movement.
And oftentimes it's because nobody knows their role, the expectation, what this is supposed to look like.
One of the analogies we use is, you know, if we gave everyone in this room several puzzle pieces and said, you know, you can pick whoever you want on your team.
As much time as you want, as much chocolate and coffee as you need.
Go ahead and put it together. Could you do it?
Yeah, we could do it. What would make it easier?
Well, if we saw the picture, what it's supposed to look like, right?
We can all build the puzzle eventually, but it really helps if we know the direction that we're going and that clarity and that sense of shared purpose and accountability and responsibility.
And then really around persuasion and first adopters.
Not everybody's going to be in the boat at the same time on day one, but really starting with a forward movement with those folks who are your early adopters in this work and then building it out.
And then implementing scaling it up and then paying it forward as we talked about.
So Dr. Mahoney is going to come up and share her experience in Arcadia.
But she was one of Arcadia was one of our what we call transformational districts really working toward that that change and now has become an exemplar to then pay it forward and show others and tour others at the site and meet with their leadership teams and talk about how they created change on the ground.
So this is really our blueprint and our method to our madness.
So our structure, as Kristen shared, we have a shared partnership between El Dorado in the north and Riverside in the south to cover the state.
We currently work with 45 different local educational agencies and that's anything from single schools to self as in county offices throughout the state.
It is voluntary. This is not, as Kevin mentioned, a compliance driven project.
This is really are you in this? Here's what our project is about.
Here's how the tiered technical supports work.
Are you ready for the support? You know, are you in this with us? Because it can't, again, just be from a compliance lens.
People really need to be in that space and willing to create change.
So our districts are at least cycle out about three to four years or so to make room for others to participate.
And we have a lengthy waiting list of folks who are really wanting the same type of boots on the ground support.
Los Angeles Unified is our largest district with 100 plus school sites really implementing these inclusive practices or more inclusive practices as well as rural sites with just one or two schools that really impact the entire community.
So we're as far down south as Imperial County and as far north as Siskiyou.
And we are on the road all the time.
We live on the road. CDE was really, really clear. They wanted to make sure that our project was tiered in terms of the level of support that we provide.
So at the tier one or universal level, any district, any school, any LEA, any county office, SELPA, can participate in the tasks that are on your screen right now.
So we have a website. If you go to our website, you can see our team. You can see our grantees, our exemplars.
Under the tab that says what we do, you can also see the events that we host for free for any LEA to participate in.
We host webinars and we also do some thought partnering with any LEAs that call us just to kind of talk through any of the questions that they have.
We have a pretty large social media presence on Facebook and Twitter.
We put everything that we do everywhere that we are and anything that's going on in CDE's world just to create a community across California so that everybody is clear on what's happening and what they can take or participate in.
We have our in-person and our virtual events. We also work with the thought partnering with the leadership teams.
But I think one of the biggest tasks that we provide is making the connections between all of the resources around system of support.
So we try to really understand how the system of support is working and who the contact individuals are within each of the leads and the geo leads, the SELPA system improvement leads, the content leads,
just to make sure that all of our grantees have access to the work that's being done.
We find that there is a lot of confusion or LEAs that don't know what's available to them.
That's a huge role that we play in our thought partnering and our support of LEAs across the state and those in the project.
So tier two, our strategic level of support for the 45 grantees that are in the project.
All of their professional development is personalized. So we work with the LEAs on their PIR plans, their LCAPs, developing activities, and then the actual implementation of those activities.
So if they choose to really focus on universal design for learning, we would help them either make the connections to the content lead out of placer or we would provide the professional development ourselves.
We also work with leadership teams, not just special education leadership teams, but we want the entire district leadership team to be a part of the conversations in the planning.
Each of the LEAs are also afforded grant funding over the course of the three to four years that they're with the project.
And with that grant funding, they can use it to create communities of practice, PLCs, they can send their teachers and administrators to events or bring speakers into their LEAs.
So it's specifically focused on what their needs are and then making connections, not just within the system of support, but really looking broadly.
We know that if we only focus on special education teachers and administrators in special education, we will not make the growth that we would like to make.
So we also, with the assistance of Kristen and Carla, helping us to make those connections to who are state leaders in secondary transition and workability, behavior restraint and seclusion, AB2657, California PBIS Coalition, CAPTN, Institutes of Higher Education.
Institutes of Higher Education are now redefining their teacher preparation programs around universal design for learning.
So we're heavily in to the institutes and the planning of what that would look like and helping the IHEs understand what the needs are of LEAs.
And then labor management initiative, working with Ed Honorwitz on how do we create relations between labor and management that do impact students with disabilities positively.
So Kristen had mentioned we focus on policy.
This is a huge area where policy can dictate students being excluded in our system.
We also wanted to provide you a list of grantees and exemplars.
The exemplars are in blue. The grantees are in green.
You can find this on our website also under who we are.
We also have a map of California on the website where these LEAs are listed on pins on the map.
We found this morning that we had an LEA in Mexico, so we're correcting that right now.
So we also just wanted to list our partnerships across California.
We talked about many of them.
We are also, as part of our contract, working with Mary Grady and the Edge publication on our website, brand new tab.
All of the Edge publications are updated and archived on the tab farthest to the right.
So a list of partners and then our priorities.
Our priorities, again, are not just special education focused, but really looking at systemically,
how do each one of these priorities impact positively or negatively within the local context of our LEAs?
And I think that's a really important point to make is that we don't dictate how LEAs implement their inclusive practices or their inclusion.
We really look at what is their local context and then how do we move that forward
within what their identified priorities and initiatives are.
Just a quick slide of our website that we're very proud of.
And then finally, we're also asked, what does personalized approach look like?
So just three examples.
One of the local LEAs that we're working with, their local context was they were developing their LCAP,
they were developing their PIR, and they were coming up with activities, one of those activities being universal design for learning.
So they asked us, what would this look like?
So we created a professional development plan for this year for all of their secondary teachers and their administrators,
where our team were small but mighty, but four of the members of the team would come in on the exact same day on four different campuses
with the same information so that every secondary teacher and administrator received the same information across the course of this year.
Next year, we're looking at implementing with elementary administrators and elementary teachers.
Same message and same vision.
Another one of our local LEAs, their local context was the adoption of a new ELA and math curriculum.
So their focus was really working with their ed specialists to help them understand what UDL means in terms of a lesson
planning framework around equity and access so that they could work with their general ed teachers to build that capacity.
So we worked with their ed specialists, we worked with their paraeducators to really help them understand what it means to lesson plan
around the idea of access and equity.
And then finally, Carla had talked about how all of the lead work is coming together using the Shasta geo leads,
really identifying what the priorities are in their counties in the far north.
And then a lot of their staff utilized the SELPA systems improvement work, went through that training, brought that back, and they identified UDL.
So they contacted Jill King in Placer for the content lead around universal design for learning.
What we realized, we have grantees in the far north that we've been working with.
So our integration is to help sustain after the content lead work is gone,
but then also understanding what they're being exposed to so that we can continue that work with the grantees.
And then we also looked at the SIP alignment across all of the counties that we work with.
And out of that came a conversation with Reading Unified School District saying we would like to get into the project.
So it's kind of how everything is integrating from the geo lead all the way to the requests of LEAs being asked to come into the project.
So just a little bit of data and Catherine's going to share a little bit more.
But when we're looking at specifically indicator five of those indicators that Kristen had mentioned,
indicator five is least restrictive environment for ages six through 21.
And so when we're looking sort of at the target area across those five years or so, five to six years,
we're looking at a three percent increase in students who have IEPs included 80 percent or more of the day.
So this is specific to indicator five A, let's say five B is included 40 percent or less of the day and C is outside
or separate schooling or nonpublic placement, let's say home hospital and others.
So the increase in just five A. So again, participation in general education, 80 percent or more of the day.
The state target is three percent across five years.
When we look at SIP overall, we're seeing a three point three seven percent increase in one year and then an average of five to twelve percent across three years.
So when we're looking at our districts that we're working with and doing that deep dive and rolling our sleeves up, boots on the ground work,
again, not just sort of pushing out resources from behind our desk,
pushing out all across California and saying we are here to show you how these resources map to where you want to be.
And we really want to be in this work with you.
And when we see that really deep dive with districts, we're seeing a really amazing increase.
And it's not, again, what Kevin mentioned.
We're not walking over the toolkit and saying, here's how you do inclusion.
It's what is your culture, your context in your community, your students and families, what are their needs and what does the landscape look like for you?
And how do we build that out for you?
And then we have some outliers, as as Catherine will mention, where their increases are upwards of more like twenty four percent.
So some quick lessons learned just that this is an organic process, again, cannot be a toolkit and there's intentional design and sometimes redesign.
Sometimes things are in place that we're not producing the outcomes that we want for our students.
So we go back. There's nothing wrong with going back.
If something is not working for kids, we don't say, OK, let's wait till let's wait till July or August and let something sit in place.
We really want to be able to intentionally design and redesign those systems and that our first adopters really have to be our school boards and our superintendents.
We have to have the support from all areas for this work to really be successful.
Breaking down those silos and self-imposed barriers and we talk about self-imposed barriers.
We're talking about what are those policies and practices that we have put in place?
What does that master schedule look like? What is our professional development calendar look like?
How much collaborative time are we really providing for our teachers?
Are we engaging our parents or have we imposed those barriers that are limiting our ability to be more inclusive models?
And that it's really not a student readiness model.
We can't say when the kids are ready to be included, the kids are already ready to be included.
It's our systems. It's the adult and the system readiness model, not the student readiness model.
So sometimes it really is about mindset and we know that that's the hardest piece to shift around mindset.
And we know that we have to appeal to that sort of rational and emotional side of folks.
The rational side being here's the data, this works, here's the research around inclusion.
And the emotional side is this is a moral imperative for our kids.
And really a re-culturing, as Michael Fullen says, with relationships as the foundation for change.
So just some quick recommendations and building capacity.
Continuing this regionalized and personalized tiered system.
So we know that, as Kevin mentioned, we're small but mighty.
So we have these 45 folks that we dig in deep.
But having that tier one where everybody can access at no cost and local to them, north, central, south events,
virtual in person to really have a variety so that we can reach as many folks as we can with this work.
But keeping the boots on the ground and listening and moving forward and connecting resources and initiatives and priorities.
Matching our resources as we're looking at increasing those indicator targets in this next round of state performance plan.
So we have clarity around the purpose and our sense of urgency with intentional design and measurable outcomes.
We really have to have that data piece to show that these outcomes are working for students.
And then once we see that success, really having a platform to celebrate that success and call that out and share that broadly.
So leaving you just with this quote as we bring Catherine up that we do the best we can until we know better.
And then once we know better, we do better.
So Catherine Mahoney is here because she knows better and she's doing better.
So we'd like to introduce Dr. Catherine Mahoney.
Hello. Thank you so much for having me.
I can't tell you how thrilled I am because really it's just the next few slides are just me getting to brag about my kids and our staff and our organization.
And so I'm very grateful for that opportunity.
Arcadia, as you can see, is a district of about ninety four hundred students, TK through 12th grades generally,
although we of course support preschool through 22 with our special education programs.
We have 11 school sites, six elementary schools, three middle schools, one comprehensive high school and one alternative school of choice lab school.
So we're medium. This is some demographic information.
What you'll see, what might be highlighted is that we have a relatively small population of students with disabilities,
which you'll see is related directly to the support we've gotten and the efforts we've made over the years.
Our largest population, our largest student group is Asian, sixty five point six percent students in that category.
And we are a high performing school district, which is interesting in the sense of inclusion and LRE,
because while that's seen as a positive across many contexts,
when we're looking at trying to include students with learning needs, that sometimes has been a barrier for us.
And so that's been a lot of the cultural mindset changes that we've worked on as we took on this work.
Again, really proud of how our district does overall.
However, back in 2014, 15, what we were seeing with our data for students with disabilities was that we were definitely going in the wrong direction.
So as our teachers were trying to figure out how to maintain those lovely blues and high test scores,
they struggled with figuring out how to teach that broad spectrum of student need within one classroom.
And so we had a trajectory where we were then pulling students out of those general settings to give them those specialized alternative modes of instruction.
And so that's when we were given the opportunity to apply for the grant,
because our data was not only poor in terms of our students with disabilities in LRE, but going in the wrong direction.
So we're now closer to about five years.
And what we focused on with the support of Kevin and Kristen was universal design for learning and co teaching.
And we looked at that because of the different grade levels.
So universal design for learning really was a good fit for our elementary sites,
whereas our secondary sites really co teaching seem to be a better fit in meeting student need.
So we are currently based on our own kind of live data analysis at 56 percent of our students spending 80 percent or more of their day in general education settings,
which is what the state target is right now and is more than about 28 percent growth over a five year period.
So we're really excited because while that data speaks a lot on its own,
there are a thousand stories behind that data of individual students doing more than they thought they could do,
teachers doing more than they thought they could do and parents coming to us and saying they also feel more included.
They feel more part of the community.
So the data tells us a lot, but there is just more rich narrative data that I can't capture here.
The seven point nine percent of our population of students includes our preschool to 22 year olds.
But again, is a quite low rate of identification because what we're finding is that our schools are able to support kids without labeling them.
They're able to use those skills that they've learned through the training and the design through the grant to worry more about getting the services and supports to students
than creating the assessment processes and the documents and all of that while still ensuring that they're being successful.
Our graduation rate for students with disabilities is ninety two point four percent.
And really exciting to me is the post school outcomes because really we're not just about giving getting them to a diploma,
but making sure that all of our students are successfully engaged in their communities once they leave us.
So sixty three point nine percent of our students are engaged in higher education.
Almost eighty nine percent are engaged in competitive employment and ninety seven point two two percent are engaged in any employment or education.
And again, this is specific to students with disabilities.
I'm sure you're familiar with this data, but just as a point of reference, this is the performance data for across the state of California for students with disabilities.
ELA at about sixteen point two percent and twelve point six percent with mathematics.
And what I'd like to highlight for you is the growth we've seen in three of our schools.
One is a high school setting. The other two are elementary settings.
And from 2015 16 to 2018 19, we now have students with disabilities who are meeting or exceeding standard at a rate of 50 percent.
So it's exciting because that is truly reflective of we're not doing what Kevin kind of referenced at one point of dumping and hoping we're not just including them in a setting,
but we're truly supporting them to to be strong learners who are making progress.
What this doesn't show, which I also appreciate it from the sense of the support is that we actually had a drop in scores for students with disabilities over that five year period before we pick back up,
which I think is reflective of the learning of the system, the teachers learning how to do these things, being having that productive struggle like we expect our students to do where they don't just have an upward trajectory of learning,
but rather they struggle. They don't always do it well. They don't do it right the first time.
One of our district values is learn from failure. And that was evident in our data, I think, at some points.
But when we look and track our students overall, they made progress with us. So we everybody works together.
The students and the teachers and the staff and the principals all grew together.
The way we approach this that was very much supported by the grant leadership was making sure that we ensured the organization knew the why.
And we actually spent a year on that. We didn't do any change to program.
All we did was look at our why. And then the other area of focus we selected was principal leadership.
We spent a lot of time ensuring that they were the lead learners who could support this effort, lead it from the front, answer questions and be there to then also design very specific SIP plans for their individual school site based on school site need.
So for us, and it was already referenced earlier, the SIP grant design itself really married a focus professional development opportunities with experts from across the nation with local choice and self-determination that allowed us to meet our district's unique needs.
So we were given that flexibility and really the coaching and the grace provided by Dr. Brooks and Mr. Schaeffer was absolutely instrumental to our progress.
There was a lot of cheerleading, a lot of coaching, which was really helpful because it wasn't always that squiggly line.
That's more of what we followed versus that straight line to get to where we are now.
So just to give you a brief kind of overview of our journey, in 2016-17, again, we just focused on our why and we just trained our Board of Education, our cabinet and principals regarding what LRE was.
And everybody had to identify their own why because different people have different whys, right?
For some people, it was a compliance need. For other people, there was a moral imperative.
There was a social justice imperative, but if we didn't focus on that, then we weren't sure that we'd be able to maintain course.
We might stray from what the actual goal was.
And then we spent a lot of time checking the data.
There's a lot of data that, you know, if you just flip those numbers and you have them in the wrong place, we didn't want to turn the ship based on bad navigational data, right?
And so we spent a lot of time with our staff building in structures where we check that data all the time to make sure that the choices we were making was based on good data.
We then, in 2017-18, felt prepared to work with our teachers.
So made sure that then we provided co-teaching training to all of our secondary special educators and voluntary identified general educators because we wanted people who love this idea or are passionate and were on board with it with us.
We also sent a small group of coaches and principals to UDL training at CAST using SIP funds to do that.
We went to Indiana for this training.
We worked with principals to then also develop individual site LRE plans because we were hoping to model the support we'd gotten from SIP in looking at this isn't a monolithic change that would happen.
It really needed to be based on the unique needs of school sites, the unique skill sets of school sites, staff as well.
When we, you'll see a little bit later, we spent some time looking at Hattie research and self-efficacy and knowing that our staff needed to believe that they had the skill set to make these changes and people are at different levels with that.
So we want to make sure that principals had the leeway to develop that in their staffs.
In 2018-19, we continued with another small group of principals attending CAST trainings.
We then just kind of built capacity training more and more people who came on board.
And really it was the positive feedback that we that spread out amongst the groups really built itself that they were able to come back and share that our high performing students who say in our high school setting, which is highly competitive initially thought, well, that's going to be something that kids who have learning needs need and require.
And they truly ended up saying, you know, I learned better that way.
It was so nice to have two people who could explain it two different ways.
And although I didn't need it, I benefited from it, which is a UDL philosophy, of course, that what was essential for some students to be able to access and participate benefited a wide variety of students.
Teachers also really appreciated learning from one another, which was a nice byproduct as well of this initiative.
We also spent some of our money investing in collaboration and planning time because that was the number one piece of feedback we got as we were working on this, that teachers just didn't have enough time for the rich conversations that had to occur in order for this to be successful, effective and not frustrating.
And then in the beginning of this year, our coaches asked to be trained in UDL.
Even though they weren't special ed coaches or LRE coaches, they were content area coaches, but they wanted to infuse their practice with UDL practices.
So that became the way that we provide instruction in different content areas.
And so they the SIP monies again funded UDL courses for all of our instructional coaches to participate in.
Katie Novak came and did our district wide staff development day, which I think speaks volumes about our board support and our superintendent support and the principal support that everyone got on board to say this is so important.
We would like to have this be our day long speaker, which I go back to that first year where we got them to believe how important this was and make sure that they knew that this was a sustained effort over time.
So they would come back and invest in this when we were ready for that.
We've also then continued the co-teaching training for additional staff if they've come on.
Collaboration and planning time again was where some of the funding went.
And then spending additional training funds for principals.
Again, principals be really, really important to this initiative for us.
So some cultural changes that were really significant for us.
Again, I already mentioned our board of education executive cabinet frequently speaking to the value of inclusion and our initiatives that that's just part of who we are.
We believe that that's who Arcadia is.
I thought of a more professional way to write this, but I didn't.
I've been adopted by our education services department.
This is the first district I've been in where I'm not in a different building.
I'm not on a different floor.
I'm not under a department that I'm like, why am I under MOT or whatever it might be?
I am at their weekly meetings.
I am presumed to be there.
I am expected to be at the table.
I'm expected to participate.
And when I have something that comes up, they expect of themselves that they are helping me with a solution.
And that we are just fluid in in our efforts together and just even the we talk a lot about the importance of language.
The idea that these are all of our students and that they can see the value I bring to their conversations because I have areas of expertise that they didn't know they needed to know.
And they have expertise and things I didn't know was important for my kids.
So I don't know a lot about the district benchmarking, perhaps.
And because we're able to have these fluid conversations, I see how I can bring value to that process that ultimately will help kids in the classroom.
The hiring processes for our cabinet level employees, many of our employee categories include questions about inclusion.
So I think from the get go, we are setting the tone that this is a value and expectation within our district.
And ultimately, relationships, relationships, relationships modeled by the SIP leads that we have.
But our students, our families, our staff interdepartmentally, I don't know how we would have made the progress we made if we weren't willing to all just jump in and trust each other.
Families had to trust us because we were recommending things for their kiddos.
That seems scary. And they trusted us to do what was good for kids.
And then our staff also having to trust us that we may believe more in them than they believed in themselves at times.
But that we would provide whatever resources and supports we could, knowing that we had SIP behind us to make that claim, right?
That we said we can send you to PD or we can give you a collab time to do this work.
Thank you.
So I'm going to ask our liaison, Nikki Sandoval, if she'd like to say a few framing comments.
And then Member Strauss, who has sat in on some of this work as well, will then take clarifying questions and go to public comment and then come back for discussion.
Okay. Thank you.
I just want to applaud the great work and the leadership of Kristen Wright.
And I was delighted to hear from Dr. Estrada, too, because it really demonstrates how far we've come.
And when I first joined the board seven years ago, it was right around the time or right before the task force report was issued.
So while the challenges are not new, the approaches that we're taking now are.
We're seeing challenges that have existed for a long time, practices that have not benefited our students very well at all.
We're looking at these challenges through fresh and through many different eyes.
And so that is exciting.
And it speaks to the unwavering commitment to one coherent system of support.
These aren't programs. These aren't isolated services.
We are rebuilding a structure that not only serves students with disabilities, but all students in California.
So I just want to shine a light on that.
The report, the plan was outstanding.
I love the illustration of the different content leads, the system improvement leads and how that all fits together.
And then hearing the real life examples today.
I love the energy of our last presenter.
You're pumped. It's great.
So I just want to acknowledge and support the outstanding work that's happened and the directions that we're going as a state.
And I think the whole nation is watching.
So I'm very supportive of this plan as it exists.
And when the time comes to to make a motion in support, I'd be happy to do that.
So I'll just follow up with Member Sandoval and just picking up recently with the work.
I, too, want to thank Kristen and her incredible leadership through this work and Carla for your work in CCE and for our self-beliefs and for Catherine Mahoney from Arcadia.
I think it was great.
And I support what Nikki said about being able to see the big picture and to see how it lays out regionally in the state.
I have to personally thank Kristen for the list of acronyms because the feds know them well.
But when I was reading through the diagram, I said, I think like if you didn't know them, you wouldn't understand them.
So we got a little side guide here.
So I thought that might be really helpful.
Also, I think from where we've been, those of us have been around a while in education to realize where we're going in special ed,
the idea of needing to train and build capacity, which is what we all know is going to change practice,
the fact that we're a giant state and the regional level with all the  and I appreciated, Carla, too, for you going through the geo-leads and the self-beliefs
and what each self-belief is focusing on different and then seeing how that all connects because it's going to take us a while.
I do believe  and I love the quote, right?
I believe people are doing the best they can until they know they can do it differently.
And I would just also thank  I actually got to be at the Katie Novak presentation with an entire district.
It was pretty amazing because our Katie would be known for high-performing but traditional in their teaching practice,
and to watch their philosophy change over time and watch principals and teachers begin to embrace a different way of teaching
and going into classrooms and seeing it really is a great model for what the capacity support's been
and the ability to invest in the teachers and leaders who do the work.
So I think we have a lot of work still to do. We know that. We have lots of kids who really need the support.
But I feel like the plan is very thoughtful. It really addresses what the key issues are and gives us some guidance.
And we know our target is far bigger. We know we need to do more full inclusion with quality instruction and support.
But I think this lays a strong foundation. So I just want to thank everyone who was part of this plan.
Are there clarifying questions before we get to public comment?
All right. We'll take public comment.
There's one person signed up for public comment. Andrea Ball.
Hi. Hello. Is this on? Oh, thank you.
Andrea Ball here today on behalf of Orange County Department of Education in support of this plan.
I really want to thank the department and the CCE, Kristen and Carla for all the work.
The plan is great. You'll see the highlighter of the MTSS work. Orange County Department of Ed has been the lead for a number of years.
They are partnering with View County and more recently with the UCLA Center for the Transformation of Schools.
But as I look at the plan, when you see the theory of action for this entire systematic improvement plan,
and then you look at the bottom of page 10, the description of MTSS, and you probably are all familiar with MTSS,
it really reflects the saying that because MTSS is not in itself a program or an approach only for students with disabilities,
it's a framework to improve support for all students. And I think that's what this plan reflects.
And I just want to thank you, Board Member Sandoval, for your comments,
because I've been in education policy for about 20 years working at the district, state, and different levels.
And it's really an exciting time that we're looking at students with disabilities as part of support for all students. Thank you.
I'd just like to say amen to that. I was reflecting on the fact that when the board, well,
Mike Christ and I agreed from the CTC and the state board to go out and try to raise some money for the Special Education Task Force,
which is now like so many years ago, but to see the work that has been done in the meantime to get us toward a unified system of support for students.
And particularly I want to thank everyone who contributed to the plan
and the participation of our friends from Arcadia to actually illustrate what it's like when you put it in action.
It was really very inspiring. Discussion. Yes.
I just want to highlight, so I'm so impressed with the presentation because it highlights so many things
that are going well in the system of support when you look at and you hear the example of what was explained.
It's a perfect example of CDE, CCE, and county offices coming together to really impact local efforts.
And that's what I think I was hopeful that we envisioned when we were thinking of the system of support.
And I have to agree with both the comments of Nikki and Eileen around the leadership that Kristen has shown.
It was special ed that was calling for one system integration before we were talking about one system integration.
And it was a special ed task force that called out MTSS before people were talking about MTSS.
So I think we need to just call out and lift up that there's been some incredible leadership
and collaborative leadership in that field that has helped this state move forward.
I really think that this sets up the next phase of the work, which is really building our highly qualified educators to do the heavy lifting that's required.
And I just can't underscore enough and thank Kevin and Kristen and Arcadia for being here as well.
You are a small team, but the volume of work that it takes to do this,
the level of collaboration, the resources, the energy.
And most importantly, what I saw in Arcadia's presentation was the commitment of resources.
So a lot of districts, when you're bringing a Katie Novak into your district, you're talking about money.
And a lot of our districts are in a position where they struggle to do that.
This is an example of breaking those barriers and setting things up to do the right work for students with disabilities.
So I just want to thank you for lifting all of this, bringing it to light.
I really appreciate it because it just highlights the efforts.
And I commend county office work and CDE's work and CCE's work for really showcasing what the one system of support can do.
Yeah, we've had our public comment.
We can say anything now.
Now I can make a speech.
No, I also want to just commend the work.
It's obvious.
One of the things that I noticed today that I haven't seen in a lot of presentations is, you know,
Kristen and Dr. Carles Estrada and the work and the collaboration between the department and CCE
and the way that it's exemplified by the work that was presented.
It is very much something about collaboration and close contact and breaking those silos.
And I think that's something that we it's really hard to do at the scale of the state of California.
And so one of the things that as I was the presentation on intersectionality,
I thought about so many of our students that fall under those categories because the populations mirror so much.
So you have a number of students, the students of color, I think are 70 percent within the students with disabilities, 17 percent of English learners.
You spoke about integration, and I think integration period has always been the hardest work, right?
Because it's either done superficially, tokenized or talked about, but not completely achieved.
I want to focus a little bit on the else that are part of that 17 percent,
because I'm wondering what is their identification if it's language and speech.
And I also want to know how the three way crosswalk is used when you come in and provide technical assistance and support.
And if you want to tell them about that, I don't know if everyone's familiar with the three way crosswalk that the department it was.
Was it Veronica with the department put it out?
Yeah.
That crosswalks between the roadmap you're talking about and the it's LCFF, the real roadmap and then the special education APR measures.
And we're happy to provide you all that.
So you can take a look if you haven't seen that yet.
But I think you bring up a really valid point.
And we've been doing a lot of work along with the self leads to really go out and make sure that everyone's aware of the students with disabilities,
the EL guidelines for students with disabilities and around the data.
I think it's an area where as a state, now that we have everything in CALPADS,
we can maybe hopefully have some deeper conversations about how we can help districts further unpack that the overlapping intersectionality data for EL,
especially because, as you said, where are those connections so that we can really target?
I think that's where we start in districts.
I know we do that work when we're working directly with districts is really keep digging,
keep digging around to see where those root causes come from.
But, you know, at a statewide level, it'd be great to get to that point as well.
Member Pagalan.
I just wanted to say that I really respect in all levels of the presentation, the honesty and, you know, recognizing where we still have to grow.
I really appreciate that.
I think it's very easy to just talk about everything that's, you know, that you've done.
That's amazing.
But I really, really, truly respect the honesty around where we're heading.
We can accept a motion if we're ready.
I move approval of the state systemic improvement plan as proposed by the CDE.
Second.
Any further discussion?
All in favor say aye.
Aye.
Any opposed say nay.
Any abstentions?
All right.
Thank you very much.
Woohoo.
And if you want to stretch a little, we're going to get our next item is called the mega assessment item.
And so if that makes you want to take a stretch for one second while our CDE support comes up, but don't go away.
Okay.
Thank you.
Yeah, yeah.
That makes good sense.
Okay.
Don't go far.
We're going to get going again.
We have many miles to go before we sleep.
No, I said you could stretch, not that you could go anywhere.
Can't go anywhere.
I'll encourage people to take their individual breaks as they need them.
We still have several items, so.
And I know people have whatever planes and trains scheduled for tomorrow.
Okay.
Wonderful.
Sure.
Yes, that would be awesome.
That's good.
Yeah.
Is this a long one or a short one?
So I could see myself.
Are you guys doing something that needs more time or?
No.
Okay.
All right.
Then we're going to go ahead and get started.
Okay.
We're now going to take up, as the room clears out, is so much enthusiasm about the mega assessment item.
We're excited about it.
We're now going to take up item seven, our mega assessment item.
The CDE recommends that the California State Board approve the following contingent on the availability of an appropriation for this purpose.
The 2019-20 school year per pupil apportionment rates for the CASP tests administered as part of the CASP system as provided in table one of the attachment two.
The 2019-20 school year per pupil apportionment rates for the LPAC tests administered as provided in table two of attachment two.
And before I ask the department to begin the presentation for this item, I want to thank the several stakeholders who provided input on this item.
Among them are letters asking that the state board support a funding request to assist with the implementation of the California next generation science standards.
There does exist a firewall, such the board does not take positions on legislative proposals.
Therefore, I do want to encourage the stakeholders who are interested in that to make inquiries before the legislature where those appropriations would be authorized.
And now let's turn to the department's presentation of this by Mal Vang.
We're very pleased to have you here and presenting.
Please begin.
Good afternoon, Chief Deputy.
Are your microphones on?
I don't know. Are they on? Okay.
President Darlingham and board members, I'm Mal Vang.
I'm the director for the assessment development and administration division.
The item before you today is both an action and information item.
So I would like to start with the action part of the item.
As you mentioned, the California Department of Education recommends that the California State Board of Education approve and contingent on the availability of an appropriation for this purpose.
The following the 2019 2020 school year per pupil apportionment rates for the CASP test administer as part of the CASP system as provided in table one of attachment to in this of this item and the 2019 2020 school year per pupil apportionment rates for the English language proficiency assessments for California tests.
And minister as provided in table two of attachment to of this item.
So, as you may be aware education code section six zero six four zero one and six zero eight one zero eight three require that the state superintendent of public instruction apportion funds to local educational agencies for the administration of the CASP and LPAC respectively to enable local educational agencies to administer the tests.
Okay.
That was my recommendation, I will circle back to that.
And this table shows the proposed per pupil rates for the test administer as part of CASP, you'll see that you'll have your smarter balanced summative assessments for English language arts and math.
You get one rate for that assessment, your California science tests, California Spanish assessment, the California alternate assessments for English language arts and math, the California assessment alternate assessment for science.
There's a grade two diagnostic assessment for ELA and math.
And then students who do not take the test due to a medical emergency or a parent exemption. There's also an apportionment for that.
And this slide shows the proposed 2019 2020 LPAC apportionment rates.
The current initial and summative LPAC apportionment rates is five dollars per pupil as approved by the state board of education in November 2017.
At this table, the city recommends that the approve the following rate changes for this year.
An additional 50 cents per pupil to the apportionment rate for the initial LPAC in kindergarten and grade one, and for the summative LPAC in kindergarten through grade two for the one on one administrations.
And an additional 50 cents for select students who participate in the initial LPAC rotating score validation process, which collects a sample of speaking and writing responses from a percentage of LEAs.
And a second rating is assigned to validate the scores.
I will stop at this and see if there are any clarifying questions you may have about the apportionment rates before I move on to the next topic.
My question is, could you go back to the slide for the first slide on the CASP assessment? Next slide.
Sure. So on the CASP assessments, which shows the smarter balanced assessments for English language arts and mathematics, when we began our original contract with smarter balance, there was a cap on the number of assessments the state would purchase.
Is that cap still in place?
Well, in other words, after that cap, then we would pay for a certain number of assessments up to that cap. Tony is saying yes.
Yes, that cap is.
Yes.
You're talking about our membership.
Yeah, our membership. So Tony is saying yes, that cap is still in place.
He knew what I was asking about. I wasn't artful in asking the question. So thank you very much, Tony.
Any other? OK.
OK, so this next part, since we released the California science test and the California Spanish assessment results earlier in February, I'd like to go over the statewide results with you so that you have that information as well.
As a reminder, the California State Board of Education approved the CASP or California science test reporting hierarchy in November of 2017.
So for the CASP, we have the results are reported at two levels and overall and then by each of the domains, life sciences, physical sciences, earth and space sciences.
In this slide, remember that students are required to take the California science test in grades five, eight and once in high school in particular in grades 10, 11 or 12.
So this table shows the grades tested, the scale score ranges for each grade and the mean scale score and the achievement level in which the mean scale score aligns with.
So there are in terms of the achievement levels, there are four levels similar to the ELA and math.
We have level one standard not met level two standard nearly met level three standard met and level four standard exceeded.
So this is for our reference. So in terms of the mean scale score, as you can see, for example, in grade five, the scale score ranges from 150 to 250 about 100 points there.
And the mean scale score for that grade is 201, which is about the level two in terms of the achievement level.
So, again, by grade, this is by achievement levels and the number, the percentage of students at each achievement level by grade, roughly around 30% of students met or exceeded standards.
And with 23, the lower percentage at 23% for grade 10, which is also the grade with the fewest students taking the test.
As you may remember in high school, they don't they take the recommended to take the science test after their last take science course.
So some of the students in grade 10, there's fewer students taking it because many students take more science courses throughout their high school years.
So most students here perform in the standard nearly met level.
And then as you look at the data, this, this just shows overall the percentage of students at each achievement level by gender.
The all students category here is provided for our reference. And you may notice that the data looks pretty consistent.
The achievement across the groups and the standard met and standard exceed is roughly around 30, as I mentioned.
And then this one is the percentage of students in achievement levels by race or the city.
Across the four levels look.
Pretty more very right. It looks pretty varied when you look at the gaps among groups are more apparent.
As you can see, in terms of the colors here, what I would look at is the all students, as I mentioned, was around 30% met or exceeded standards.
So if you look at your African-American group, it's at 14%.
Your American Indian or Alaskan Alaska native, 21%.
Your Asian group by 59% Filipino group at 45%.
Your Hawaiian Hispanic or Latino at 19% and your native Hawaiian or Pacific Islander at 21%.
And your two or more races, sorry, the whites at 44%.
And then your two or more races at 45% met or exceeded.
So, as you can see, the gaps among groups is apparent and varied and wide.
In terms of the percentage of students in each achievement level by program group, you have your English learners are students with disabilities economically disadvantaged migrant education homeless and military.
These are the groups that we report for federal purposes.
So we have, again, English language, English learners at 3% students with disabilities at 8% met or exceeded, and they are economically disadvantaged 19%.
Your migrant education program 12% homeless 15% and military at 30% 33%.
So, again, the gap is wide and apparent even among programs.
So, any thoughts I kind of went through that but it probably not any big news to you.
If you have any clarifying questions you like to say about the cast, otherwise.
Yes, I have the, I have the CSA.
So we're going to look at the California Spanish assessment results.
Again, this is like the first year of operational test for the California Spanish assessment like the science test, and the results are reported at an overall score reporting range for each student.
And this picture kind of shows the second part of the students report.
And that show indicates the score reporting range associated with the students overall score. So there's no reporting at the domain level for the Spanish assessment.
If you look at the range here, the score reporting range indicates that the student can do what the students can do in the area of reading, listening and writing mechanics.
So this is for our reference that there are those, the California Spanish assessment score reporting ranges by grade or grade span.
It ranges from, and of course, this shows the Spanish assessment score reported ranges for each grade level and grade band with the associated score reporting range of one, two or three.
And in terms of the summary, the statewide mean scale scores by grade.
This slide includes our statewide mean scale score at each grade level, along with the associated score reporting range.
As you can see, the majority of the grades had a mean score that fell in score reporting one, range one and two.
So as a reminder, the 2018 19 was the first year of our administration, and these results again may not be much of a surprise to us based on discussions that we had with our educators during our standard setting meeting and throughout the development of this assessment.
We know that the various bilingual programs are developing or are in the process of being developed.
So there will be years when before we could really see some additional consistency among programs.
So at the state level, we'll continue to gather information about the students who are participating on this assessment and then in Spanish instructional programs that they are participating in to make sure that we know that these programs do vary.
But hopefully over time that there could be some development that's consistent and that the students will receive the instructional programs that will align with the standards in which they're being taught.
Okay.
So, any questions.
I don't have a lot to say I do want to welcome now. So, taking over the work of Michelle center and the assessment division that has done such great work up until this point.
And, you know, as, as now has presented, you'll see both our cast, the science test and the Spanish assessment test is still in its early stages.
And, you know, as, as member Strauss said earlier, we put the site, the standards together, the framework, the science materials and all that we're still not getting this quite into the schools yet and you'll see that the results still demonstrate that so we definitely have more work to do in that area.
And the same with the Spanish assessment as the field kind of understands a little bit more about this and we do have such a variety of students who are taking this test.
So, it's going to take a little while before it stabilizes a little bit and we can find out more of how these assessments are impacting in the classroom as well.
So, so that's really all I have for this.
Any further clarifying questions if not we'll go to public comment and then we'll come back for a deeper dive.
Oh, you've got another couple more.
This is very straightforward it's just showing you where to go and where the data is posted, should you like to explore more on our public website.
And then we're there, and then just the recommendations again.
Okay.
And I'm done.
Yes.
Yes, we appreciate it and you were being so kind to us and pausing and asking for questions and that was good chunking we appreciate that.
Are there any public comments.
We have five speakers for public comment.
Peter Ahern, Jill Grace, Lisa Higdahl, Jessica Sacco, and Edward Russell Jr.
President Darlingham and members of the board.
My name is Peter Ahern.
I'm president elect of the California Science Teachers Association.
I'm here in support of the coalition letter that you mentioned earlier and that we've actually revised and just resubmitted.
We just heard about the results of the first California science test and they're pretty bad.
And we know from our experience with Common Core math and ELA that these new standards are hard.
They're difficult shifts for teachers and for students and teachers need support in order to be successful.
The NGSS were adopted in 2013, instructional materials in 2018, but unlike ELA and math, science received no targeted funding for implementation.
So we now have an opportunity to correct that and provide targeted funding to support science.
We will continue to work closely with CDE staff to support NGSS and our commitment to include science on the dashboard in a few years.
But remember, NGSS has not received funding.
Thank you very much.
Good afternoon, President Darlingham and members of the board.
Dr. Gregson and Jill Grace, the regional director with K-12 Alliance, a STEM program within West Ed.
And thank you for your leadership with NGSS, having a great framework, instructional materials that we've been able to influence a science assessment.
We're continuing to revise and we're really proud to work with you and work with CDE on making those things happen in our California NGSS K-8 early implementation initiative.
We've seen NGSS transform science teaching and learning.
We work with eight districts and two charters to attempt full implementation.
And while the initiative is highly successful, our superintendents state that they won't be able to sustain this level of support through their LCAPs.
They need additional funding to change the system.
Our science community is equipped and ready to go.
We have strong, well-trained leadership network ready to take on statewide implementation, but targeted funding is necessary to provide the professional learning to support NGSS.
The pedagogical shifts that all students should impact all students and provide them access to a high quality science education and close the gaps that Mal mentioned.
And we're just asking for your leadership with that.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, Deputy Superintendent Gregson and President Darling-Hammond and members of the board.
My name is Lisa Higdahl and I am the science curriculum coach of the Galt Joint Union Elementary School District.
Galt is one of the districts that has participated in the early implementation initiative.
Due to the dedicated science funding that was provided by that initiative, we have moved our science education to a level never before experienced in our district.
We have a district expectation that science will be taught regularly as a core subject in all classrooms.
Administrative and science leadership supporting instruction that embraces the NGSS pedagogical shifts.
Students using the science and engineering practices in multiple disciplines and an increase in field studies and habitat restoration projects for all with strong connections to NGSS in the environmental principles and concepts.
To continue that growth, this district and all districts will need the support of dedicated state funding for NGSS as requested by CSTA.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, Jessica Sacco on behalf of the California STEM Network, a project of Children Now.
I'd like to start out by thanking members Ortiz, Lincoln and Sandoval for their service and we will miss you.
Welcome Deputy Superintendent Gregson to her new role. Congratulations as well as the new director, Mal Vang.
We have worked with Mal for years and we're really excited for her and connecting with her on the assessments.
I do want to thank you.
I do want to connect some of our comments.
We do recognize that there are restrictions and you know, orders of things in place that when it comes to talking about funding for standards implementation, we're just simply grateful to board members as they participate in their liaison experiences,
as they are instructional and educational leaders in the community that they continue to keep science at the forefront of their mind and recognize the heavy lift and the needed investment that is required for those standards.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
Any other public comment?
Okay, I will note that the governor's proposed budget does include something on the order of 90 or 100 million dollars for STEM professional development, including NGSS implementation.
So we will watch that on its way through the legislature with our fingers crossed.
And then just to clarify, President Darling-Hammond, and if that money goes through, then we'll be able to help guide how that is allocated.
Is that right?
No?
Thank you.
We are now open for discussion, but not that topic.
Yes, member Ortiz-Lacone.
Well, not that topic, but just closely related.
You know, I'm looking at the percentage, the caste percentages by student, specifically race and ethnicity.
And though I know the numbers, it's still always shocking to see them in front of you.
And I do agree with board member San that it's early, it's the first year, the, you know, the training, the resources, the materials have not necessarily trickled down.
But it's working for some students, right?
You could see it there.
There are some students that despite all that, they're doing quite well.
And so I think that, yes, we need to give it some time, but I'm concerned that the time we're giving it is only at the cost of some students, right?
And that's for everything.
If you look at ELA and math, we still have that conversation.
We need to give it some time.
So I'm wondering what from the department side, I know that there were some conversations about possible funding, but what are we doing on the department side to provide support as we're hoping to increase these numbers next year with or this year when the new administration of the assessments given?
What are we given in terms of guidance, support, training, whatever it is?
Would you like me to speak to that?
Sure.
So we've got a couple of things happening right now.
Mal and her team are looking at we've been requesting money to support kind of a 3D module.
So it's professional learning resources for teachers and resources for students that are all based on California and GSS.
We also have our quite comprehensive California science framework.
And so I think we have to go back to providing more professional learning around the California science framework because it's the document that every single teacher can have for free in their classroom and utilize in their department meetings, their grade level meetings, their school meetings, provide with professional learning for administrators.
So we have those elements.
We're also looking at developing out some of our performance tasks that are in GSS based so that our teachers can understand how to incorporate performance tasks embedded in their instructions.
We've got a multi layered approach, but we know that we need more professional learning to saturate across the state for our teachers.
And also we have our science collaboration community as well, who's working on this as well throughout regional projects and trying to get saturated down to the classroom teacher.
And what I'm thinking is when you think about exposure teaching and then you look at careers in STEM, when you look at, for instance, a Latino population in STEM careers, we're 10% and 3% for Latinas.
And so courses like this will eventually lead to the workforce.
And for some of it, for some of us, it will have real implications.
Member Rucker.
So I agree with board member Lincoln, Ortiz Lincoln, that the performance gap of students by ethnicity or by these subgroups is stark, but it's not surprising.
And I guess the fact that it's not surprising takes me back to the conversation when we were approving the new LCAP template.
One of the concerns that was raised by a number of stakeholder groups is that districts are not being given enough guidance or that the guidance doesn't contain a sufficient mandate to make sure that what districts prioritize or plan for in their LCAPs truly addresses the needs of students.
And so and then I'm also sensitive to and remembering the state's audit report pointing out that it's not clear that districts are actually spending their supplemental and concentration grant funds on their students.
So I see these test scores and it makes me go back to wonder, so how is the planning that schools are actually doing actually data driven when every single time we implement a new assessment, the same students clearly are not being served well.
There needs to be a point in time where we start seeing some differences when the same students are performing well and are obviously succeeding and benefiting from the instructional program.
And nothing the data keeps saying, regardless of what subject area the assessment is for, the data continues to say the same students are not being served.
It's easy to blame the test. It's easy to wait for your presentation and look at data that verifies what we already know is going on.
But at some point in time, our accountability concerns about continuous improvement and the work that should be going on should say or should show in some way returning a corner.
I mean I understand, I mean this brings back to me the reasons why Martin Luther King urgently said there are reasons why we can't wait.
You know, when we implement the next assessment that people are pushing for and the gap still looks the same, it still says the plan is not working for somebody.
So while I'm happy to focus on the continuous improvement, the plan is not working for somebody.
So I believe in and I accept what some of our stakeholders said, while the law may not create a mandate for how we can direct districts on what they write about in their plan,
I still think, and this data shows, we need to give county offices more guidance to speak with on how to talk to districts about the planning they are doing and how to use the data to do better and effective planning.
Because it's irresponsible to blame the test or say that there's something wrong with the test when every single test is showing there's something wrong with the planning and the system.
Yeah, so I wanted to mention, it is important to note that we are in the early stages of this test, but it was very alarming to see those results.
And for me specifically, the STEM careers are the ones that are the most fast evolving careers.
And if we're not fast on this, as fast as those jobs are evolving, then the same groups of people that were left behind in the past are going to be left behind in the future.
So I really hope this can be prioritized because moving forward with the kind of jobs that are growing, this is going to be essential and STEM careers should be the main focus for students who are in the education system right now.
The comments from my colleagues bring a question up for me then in our system of support that we just talked about.
How much of that when we're going into districts and supporting schools that have been identified based on current dashboard indicators, how much is that support spread beyond let's say content areas that that are not necessarily on the dashboard yet.
And it would be helpful that when we look at comprehensive support that, yes, while the dashboard gives us data and schools may have been identified based on dashboard, that there are systemic issues within districts and schools that need to be addressed.
And perhaps that could support other areas as well, not just in that specific content area or specific student population.
Do you like me to say something to that?
So as far as the system of support and our counties working directly with our districts to really understand what are the barriers that are impeding student success.
So the reasons why they're eligible for differentiated assistance and let's remember that a district is eligible for differentiated assistance under two different priorities, right?
And not being able to serve student subgroups within those two priorities.
So when they're doing the root cause analysis, they are looking at multiple pieces of data.
They're looking at all of their achievement data, not only ELA and math, but curriculum embedded assessments in all of the content areas because it's not just ELA and math, right?
Those are symptomatic of the other content issues, other issues in content areas.
So they're looking at their system of professional learning for their teachers, the type of instructional resources their teachers are using in the classroom, and then what type of learning environment that they've created within the classroom for their students as well.
So they're looking at all of those different layers to then determine, OK, what are your issues and how do we fix them?
So it's not just looking at those singular pieces of data, it's multiple pieces of data.
You know, you need a motion on the per pupil apportionment rates.
Do I hear a motion?
OK, so I will make the motion, but can I just ask something related to this?
Not really directly to this item, but it's kind of associated with it.
We all know coronavirus schools closing.
It's right around testing time.
Now, if you could just maybe talk a little bit about the department's guidance to schools.
If they chose to close, what's this?
Has there been something out there regarding?
Could we come back to that maybe after the motion?
Do you think this influences our vote?
Well, we can come back after the motion.
Yeah.
Yes, we did work with our communications office to put out some communications last week.
And we also work with our contractor to ensure that if schools close or are contemplating closing,
that they reach out to our contractor and they will work with them within our testing window.
We have a wide testing window for CASP.
It opens on January 14th and ends on July 15th.
So if they are open within those times, their instructional years within that span of time,
they could adjust their calendar or testing windows with our contractor.
There are various options on the table.
I think that we're supposed to hear some guidance from the feds.
I heard through the grapevine, so don't quote me on that about this very issue.
So once we get some guidance from the feds, it's just that we're going to get some updates from them, some guidance from them.
I'm sorry to burst the bubble, but that's really it.
As the issues and concerns are coming up around COVID-19 and how this is affecting our testing windows and the school closures,
we are constantly working with our Department of Public Health and reaching out to Cal OES and then the federal government as well to update our guidance as we learn more.
It is literally and our Deputy Superintendent Lisa Constanza can speak to this every hour.
It's something new and different that we're addressing.
So we were kind of the hub of all that and completely understand that.
Just want to make sure our contractors have that capacity to deal with the changes and fluctuations and all that.
And we just want to be supportive of that. Yes, they do have the capacity.
And in fact, we've already reached out to a few within this week.
And because most of our tests are online now, it's a lot easier to do that kind of adjustment.
OK, great. Thank you.
All right. So I will make a motion to the department's recommendation to approve the apportionment rates for the CASA tests administered,
provided in the attachments one and two of the item and the per pupil apportionment rates for the LPAC tests administered as provided on table two of the attachment two of the item.
Right. Any further discussion?
All in favor say aye. Any opposed nay.
Any abstentions? Motion passes.
Thank you very much.
You. Well, I'm not done yet.
I'm not done yet.
Hopefully we do the right ahead to the Golden State seal merit diploma, after which we'll take a break before we do the waivers.
So in this item, the CD recommends that the state board approve the Golden State seal merit diploma eligibility criteria specified in attachment one,
which updates the criteria for students to demonstrate mastery of science curriculum using the California Science Test Results to award the GSMD for graduating students effective March 2020.
And Malvang will present. Please begin.
Thank you, President Darlene Hammond.
The item before you today is both an action information item.
The California Department of Education recommends that the state board of the California State Board of Education approve the following eligibility criteria for the Golden State seal merit diploma specified in attachment one,
and including the updates to the criteria for demonstrating a demonstration of science curriculum mastery to include the California Science Test Results to award the Golden State seal merit diploma to graduating students.
So per Education Code sections five one four five zero through five five, each local educational agency that confers high school diplomas are required to maintain appropriate records in order to annually identify graduating seniors who have earned a Golden State seal merit diploma.
And to affix the insignia to the diploma and transcript of each qualifying student.
So the revised eligibility reflect the current availability of our state assessment results and include the following changes, as I mentioned, to add the use of the CAS results earned in grade 10 or 11 for the category of science.
And although some students may not take the cast until grade 12, they have had reasonable access to meet the science criteria using our course and the course grade option.
And there's our recommendation.
That's it. I only have that slide.
Do this in two minutes. No graphic.
Are there any clarifying questions about this? Yes, member birth.
Thank you, Mel. I just want to make sure that on the criteria.
The item number four, where it allows for two additional subject areas that students can choose from that my understanding is correct that where B is a grade of B or numerical equivalent or above upon the completion of high school courses in other subjects.
That includes visual and performing arts, foreign language, because we have such an emphasis, at least up in the top on what I'm going to call the core subjects.
But as you know, those other areas are available for complete for completing graduation requirements.
So I just wanted to clarify that we're not just focused on the core subjects that are shown up there that have tests that go along with them.
You're right. Are you talking about five B? Yes.
Completion of in other subjects.
Or could it be career tech and we spent all morning talking about career technical courses and there's such an emphasis here on what our quote traditional subjects and I know this grew out of years and years ago, the Golden State exams when these were all test based and they were all very specific content area.
But I hope that we're taking a broader view and I just want to make sure that's what we're voting on.
I believe in five B and C, it does leave that local decision for the for the LEA to make the decision of which additional courses in other subjects beyond the ones that are listed from one through four.
So that is my understanding, but I don't know if I have any.
Do you need to phone a friend?
Done. Yes.
Okay.
What is it?
Yeah, I was going to text somebody, but would you like me to follow up with you?
Okay.
Oh, okay. Sure. Sure thing.
We'll let you get your text off and then we'll go to member rocker and then we'll go to member son.
And but we'll let let you get that answer moving.
And did I miss anybody else who wants to get in?
Are you ready?
Well, I'm trying to not ask her to multitask too much.
I think she's got somebody who's going to research it.
Okay, so somebody working on it now.
Okay, so we have another question for you now.
Well, I was actually going to attempt to respond to board.
Oh, I see.
It said because the students are being allowed to choose the fifth way or the other to meet another way to meet the fifth criteria.
When we were working on this, there was a lot of conversation about making sure that we were including elective courses like the arts as well as career and technical education courses.
And that was the purpose of B and C.
C in particular was intended for students who took capstone courses or earned badges for career and technical education programs so that they had another way of offering how they met the requirement.
And so it was intended to include the full spectrum of what's on a student's master schedule or school plan for meeting their local graduation requirements that encompassed all of their courses.
That was what was behind B and C.
And at the time, there was a lot of conversation about A.
It seemed like A was duplicative of what was already encompassed in one, two, three, and four.
And so that's the reason why B and C were broken out and narrated or explained in that way.
So the answer that should be coming back is yes, it does include all electives, regardless of subject area, as well as career and technical education.
And I've completed this form a number of times from the LEA.
And that's my recollection, too, but I want to confirm before with my own staff.
So we'll wait for a little more confirmation, but then we can go on to member Sun is waiting.
Anyone else who was waiting?
Yeah. And having done this at the site level has been many years and I've been directly involved, but I believe that is the case that you can select the additional is up to the LEA.
But this does bring me to my soapbox about this particular item.
I am going to recommend approval because the recommendation is sound.
It is consistent with what we have been doing under the Golden Seal merit diploma and within the confines of the Ed code that is there currently.
I do think that this the overall Golden State seal has gone through quite a bit of evolution.
And I've questioned every time this item has come up, why what what is this now for?
Because it was originally, as member Burr said, the the Golden State tests.
And that was prior to when we'd had state tests.
And so is a way of earning this diploma based on some objective criteria that is out there and consistent across the board.
Then we didn't have tests for a while, so we went to this grading system.
Then we started tests again and then we started adding the current current assessments into a mixture of grades and all that.
So it's evolved really quite a bit.
And I guess I still question what is for as long as it's in the Ed code.
I know that we still have this program, but I just I I'm not sure.
You know, we will continue building this, but I don't I don't have clarity on what the actual goal of the Golden State seal of merit diploma is.
Yeah. What do you get out of the Golden State seal merit diploma?
I think it's a good point.
I mean, you get it.
Yeah, OK.
Yeah, so so I that is the question.
But again, yeah, this is one of those questions.
Yeah, it is a bigger question.
But I will support the recommendation.
I just think that we put a lot of time in building something that we're not really sure the purpose of.
That's all.
Well, you know, it had a purpose at an earlier moment in time, right?
That was a bigger, broader.
But sometimes we need to look at how things evolve and we need to make things go away.
Well, you know, and I have having gone to a number of high school graduations, my own and then many, many others since then.
You know, these awards mean more to the school giving them often than it does to the students receiving them.
And a lot of times also, it also means a lot to the students who watch their peers and friends receive those awards.
And many schools think that it's motivating.
But I think that the purpose of giving these programs, these awards is more hype and more self self aggrandizement for the school and the school program.
And so while I think it's important later on when students are all grown up and they're looking back on this and they're trying to figure out ways to motivate their own children.
You know, because I'm looking at board members who have young children and, you know, I have often made the mistake of telling my godchildren, pay attention.
It's going to be on the test.
Now I'm telling them, pay attention.
I want you to get one of these awards that I'm approving.
So I think no, it is.
I told I told all of them I want to get that foreign language award.
I want them all to get that one because I thought, you know, because they're African American.
We barely, you know, in my family, English is our second language because we're all from the south.
So it's important.
It is important for a reason.
But I think the generation where we were into that badging and earning those badges, this is a holdover from that time when we weren't so focused on assessments.
We weren't so focused on just simply graduating but doing something that that high school graduation was a mile marker and an important accomplishment that meant many things to that particular generation.
So some of this awarding and this particular idea is a holdover from that.
And I think it's an opportunity for us as we sit and question the value of it.
And we have a student member who obviously is going to receive one of these awards.
It's an opportunity for us to think about what it is we're trying to tell both our parents, our school community and our L.A.
as they prepare this spring to award these and identify students, what it is we really want them to say and help students understand about receiving it.
And so I think we've got an answer to the we have an answer.
So it can be any course a district wants to include.
The trend has been toward even PE courses and performing arts.
All right.
Can we move forward on the item?
Yeah, and yeah, we're just going to just comment on member Rutgers point.
I mean, this is also the criteria is agreed B plus for one single mathematics or you could say ELA for the entire four years or three years.
So in a course, so you could make Cs or Ds as long as in one year, there was a B plus in that year and that one subject area.
So it's a criteria is not what I considered so high that it's so again, it goes back to we established this criteria.
What is the purpose of it?
And and again, it's maybe we want to put this on a future agenda.
Well, yeah, I've asked about that.
I mean, to really discuss to discuss what exactly because right now we have people waiting to get this.
OK, some of our own diets.
So you did you want to move?
I can move the item.
Yes, you put it that way.
I'll second it.
OK.
All right.
We have a motion and a second.
I don't even want to ask if there's further discussion.
All in favor say aye.
Aye.
Any opposed say nay.
Any abstentions?
The motion carries that we will come back and talk about our broader purposes for this at a moment in time where people are not in the middle of earning it.
OK.
Thank you very much, Mal.
We appreciate it.
And we're going to take a brief break till four.
OK, we'll let people actually get their cup of coffee and get to the restroom and then we'll come back and do waivers.
Can I call the meeting back to order?
So we're going to go to waiver consent and we're going to take up waiver consent items W1 to W12.
I understand there's a correction to the proposed term for W11.
So Christian Wright's going to clarify W11.
Yes.
So for item 11, waiver item 11, the CDE recommends that the state board approve the nonpublic school student placement outlined in waiver 11 and our rationale for the change in the item versus what was posted to align the necessary start and end dates for the school year.
Because the way we certify is by calendar year, which is different.
And so we just don't want to we want to make sure that we have everyone covered.
So the clarifying the correction is that we want to be sure that there's not a lapse in coverage for the student in the school.
So the clarification is that you approve the waiver and that there's a change in the timeline.
Okay.
To the dates.
Yeah.
Oh, thank you.
So the new date will be December 11th, 2019 to June 30th, 2020.
I'm sorry.
July 1st, 2021 to get them over the hump.
So thank you for clarifying that.
So now I have, is there any public comment on waiver W1 through W12?
There's no one signed up for public comment.
No one.
Okay.
So do we have a motion?
I will move the consent on the waivers.
We have a motion.
Do we have a second?
Member Ver?
Thank you.
Any discussion?
Just to clarify that there is a correction to W11.
So with that, do we have approval of the motion to approve the waiver consent?
All those in favor?
Yes.
Aye.
Thank you.
Motion carries.
So we're going to do state board priorities now.
The first thing we're going to do is we need to approve the preliminary report of actions
and minutes for the January 8th and 9th meeting.
Do I have a motion to approve the minutes from the January board meeting?
I'll move.
Member Sandoval moved?
I'll second.
And Member Sung seconded.
Any discussion?
All those in favor?
Say aye.
Aye.
Any opposed?
The motion carries and minutes are approved.
All right.
So what we're going to do now is to go over our liaison reports.
We're going to go in reverse alphabetical order, but I'll go at the end.
So Sue, you'll be toward the end and Ting, you're going to be at the beginning.
So we'll just call each of the board members and please report on your liaison activities
related to items that we're working on.
Okay.
Member Sung?
All right.
So I will not be reporting on CTE because we've talked about CTE all morning.
But I will report that I did attend the California Subject Matter Projects Lead Learn Conference
on behalf of Board Member Strau, who was double booked at the time.
It was a great conference as having been a fellow in the Area 3 writing project when I was a teacher.
It was great to get back with the other teacher leaders.
Excellent conference.
And one of the workshops I noted and I attended was developed by or conducted by CCE,
Ronnie Jones from CCE and Amber Valdez from West Ed that did a design thinking workshop
on continuous improvement with teacher leaders.
So looking at teacher leaders being a very important part of the school change process
and taking them through that exercise, I think it was very similar to what was presented
by the district on their special ed program.
It was really fascinating to see.
So really glad that CCE was involved with that conference and the teacher leaders in California as well.
Thank you.
Member Sandoval?
Just a brief update on the California State Summer School for the Arts.
The application closed last month, late February, and the board will be meeting early next week
and looking forward to another fabulous session this summer.
Thank you.
Member Rucker?
I have a rather lengthy report, so I'll beg your indulgence.
It's only on three items, but there's a lot of information to share.
I want to begin by talking about the California Emerging Technologies Fund.
This is a nonprofit corporation established based on per requirements from the California Public Utilities
Commission in approving the mergers of SBC, AT&T, and Verizon MCI.
These merged companies made a commitment to contribute a total of $60 million over five years
to advance broadband in the state.
The high-speed communications that we generically refer to as broadband
and defined by the FCC in terms of speed and kilobytes per second in at least one direction
is important to communities all across the state.
And what we know is that there exists a digital divide based on the community or the zip code you live in
and the financial viability of families to be able to have access and pay for broadband on a regular basis.
So the goal of the CETF is to close the digital divide and make this technology available
to low-income families across the state and also to make connections to the schools
where these communities are served to support these schools in their effort to close the achievement gap.
Last month I attended one of their academies and this partnership has grown in scope and aspect
over the time it's been created.
These schools have met together, banded together with not only to create a community of practice among themselves,
but have created a large collaboration with a number of community partners as well as policy partners
both at the county and local level and municipal level in their governance and support by the boards
as well as their elected officials.
So the convening was in Long Beach at the Maya Hotel and in sitting there meeting with them
one of the most important things they did was create an apparatus to hold themselves accountable
for the impact and the rollout of these programs.
Every single student in these participating LEAs receive a laptop computer that they get to keep
and take home and use with their families and in doing that it provides an opportunity
for the collaborating partners to provide technology integration training for teachers
so that teachers understand the differences between simply substituting technology
for regular instruction and full integration of technology
and their goal is in continuous improvement to grow over time.
Throughout the three days that I was there with them I had to keep reminding myself
this is an instructional improvement program being sponsored by the PUC.
So it's a program and a project worth monitoring and paying attention to
because the schools have made a commitment to use this opportunity and the work that they are doing
to both close the digital divide and to close the achievement gap with their students.
The second thing I'm going to report on is the math program.
As you know we are doing the work right now to update the math framework.
So I'm going to begin by saying to all of us on this day is because math is a statewide priority
because that's the subject area that is our lowest performing core subject on the statewide assessments
it is a statewide priority but math as I say now every place I go needs to become your favorite school subject.
So I'm going to begin by asking each of my board members not today but by the time we get to Teacher Appreciation Week
I'd like you to think about who your math hero is.
And so when we do that moment at the upcoming board meeting where we give our thanks to whoever our teacher heroes were
I'd really like to ask you to think about who your math hero is and come to the board meeting to share that information.
Anyway going forward the Mathematics Curriculum Frameworks and Evaluation Criteria Committee
held its first meeting on February 26th and 27th.
The committee is made up of teachers and practitioners who have a wide variety of experience in mathematics education.
The 2021 Framework Revision is building on the work from the Mathematics Framework.
Remember the 2013 Math Framework was the first framework this board adopted after the adoption of the Common Core.
We have learned a lot about framework writing and supporting curriculum implementation from that time.
And so the goal of this committee and the charge of this committee is to take what we've learned from subsequent frameworks
and the work that has been done and improve on that conversation.
It's a highly descriptive process that's been shared with the members in this charge
and they are going at it full tilt to have the conversation about looking at and understanding what the framework should do
and how it should port instruction.
The standards themselves have not changed and so we're not rewriting the Common Core standards.
What we are doing is taking a look at how the context of how we're implementing mathematics instruction has changed.
Since the Math Framework was implemented we have a new funding formula.
We've matured and developed the dashboard and we've changed the way accountability works
and we have fully matured and developed our CASP system.
So the goal now is to produce a framework that will be just as strong as the framework we just recently adopted
in science and in health so that that framework provides guidance to teachers that is understandable
and focuses on what the data is telling us from the math assessment not only that teachers need but that students need to understand.
The goal, the plan that is laid out for the development of the framework is for a series of five additional two-day meetings.
The next meeting of the framework will be March 25th and 26th here at the CDE.
And you know whenever I talk about the Math Framework I always always try to remember to remind you that we also have a separate initiative
that's going on that's being sponsored by State Board of Education staff, Carolyn Fister.
So I'm going to ask Carolyn to help me with my last item that I want to report on.
I have previously given you updates about the work that's being done through the California Statewide Early Math Initiative.
The Math Initiative is led by the Fresno County Office of Education as part of the state's system of support.
It's a multifaceted, multi-fat, multi-agency effort that focuses on improving children's mathematical outcomes
through professional learning, coaching, family engagement, resources, research and communications.
Many of these resources are already available on the Early Math Project website and the AIMS website.
And there's a lot of new resources that are under development and will be added to the website in the coming months.
Today I'm very excited to show you a sample of one of those new resources.
The initiative has been working with film director Les Mayfield to create 30 short videos
that will be a foundational piece of an early math application and communication campaign.
So I'd like to share a sneak peek with you of one of those videos.
Okay Jake, you ready for another adventure?
Ready!
Alright, hold on to your car seat. It's time for a shape safari!
We are now heading deep into the wilds of shape country.
Be on the lookout for the elusive triangle.
Look, there's one! Triangle!
Alright, good job bud. Now, let's see if we can find a square.
They're not easy to spot and they often hide in the trees.
Square!
Alright, good job bud. Can you find a circle?
There's a circle?
Where?
Right there!
It was right under my nose!
Alright, now I've saved the hardest question for last. You ready?
Yes!
What do you want for dinner?
A circle!
Hey Jake, a circle is not a food buddy.
But it's a shape!
Oh, alright! Good job bud!
And the winner of today's shape safari is Jake!
Woo!
For answering all the questions correct today, you have won a round pizza.
Yes, a pizza made of round pepperonis. Yes!
Thanks dad!
Hey Jake, I'm hungry. What do you think about a couple slices of circle?
Sounds good!
And that concludes my report. Thank you Member Rucker.
Well Brenna, I'm like this is really hard but you've got to follow her.
Alright, so I know it's been talked about a lot at the meeting and I really do thank the CDE for diligently working with the coronavirus and making sure that our students are safe.
It's good to hear that. I think that's kind of, you know, lost from the students perspective but it's good to know that there's that much effort being put into it.
I do believe that with the communication there's, I think districts are definitely going to have a good sense of what to do and the actions to take.
However, I also think it's important that they are being told how to communicate.
I think districts are definitely going to have a good sense of what to do and the actions to take.
However, I also think it's important that they are being told how to talk to students themselves.
I think that's an important piece too. I know a lot of students, you know, are very confused.
We haven't really been through something like this before and that adds to panic and when there's panic I know the situation just gets worse.
So that's one thing that I just thought I'd mention to keep in mind.
And then the other thing was just I would like to look into working with staff to possibly redesign the actual position that I am in right now.
So looking forward and trying to redesign that. So maybe students following me have a more sustainable and adequate platform to really make change moving forward.
Thank you.
Okay, thanks. Member Ortiz-Lacombe.
Well, this morning I was appointed as the chair of the Latinx Advisory Council, a committee that was created.
And so moving forward, I look forward to reporting from the other side on the Latinx Advisory Council.
And I just want to say, Member Rucker, you put me in a panic when you said I'm going to have homework for you board members.
I thought it was to solve a math problem, but I was like, oh no, don't do that to us.
Yeah, I really don't have any other than my new, I'm looking at everyone, I'm putting it in document here.
Yes, other than my new committee.
Thank you. Member Navo.
That was funny. I really appreciate math being lifted up.
I had my favorite teacher said, Navo, you're the best D student I've ever had.
It was in math.
So, and he said, you could be the best A student I ever had.
And that was when I actually put some effort into my schooling.
And so, yeah, it just reminded me a lot of unique challenges. Thank you for bringing that up.
So the system of support has a lot going on with it.
I think there's a lot of great collaboration between CDE, CCEE and county offices and geo leads and CELPA leads.
I'm going to be brief simply because, you know, barely breathe here.
There's not a big audience, to be honest.
But there are two things that I think should be on our radars.
One, the system of support in the four districts in the state that are really moving towards this tier three type of intervention.
They're in a two point point five evaluation with CCEE using the systemic instructional review that really goes in.
It's a really delicate process, but it's really going into these districts that are struggling to get the outcomes that they want.
Really is trying to separate skill versus will and really trying to lift up what are the options for the system of support with regards to how best to meet the needs of the educators in those systems that are working so hard.
And so I think this will be coming to us a little bit more clearly with regards to.
So what do we do as if if these districts continue to struggle to produce the outcomes that they want?
And the system of the support has exhausted its system of support, so to speak.
What happens? What can we do next?
I think this is a real issue for a lot of people out there watching the system of support.
So what's going to happen with districts keep moving, keep moving, keep moving, and nothing keeps getting better.
I think we saw some of those issues come up today.
The other one is the CDE and CCEE produced the basic levers, basic components tool.
So for those of you that are unfamiliar with that, that's a six component assessment of the foundational infrastructure of a district around its readiness to actually produce positive outcomes for students with disabilities.
So if a system wants to do kind of an assessment of its foundational readiness around its ability to move outcomes for students with disabilities,
this is the first tool that I'm aware of that really gives a district an opportunity to just go through that very quickly and highlight some areas that are they struggle with.
So I think that just that just hit the newsletter.
So I think as districts see that they will be very interested in that.
The only other thing I'm going to I'm going to say about the system of support.
I have it here is, I think that I want to commend you as board members for all of the hard work that you've been a part of over the last, especially 10 years, for those of you that have been on that long and I want to thank
board member Felicia, these are Lacon and Nikki for all that you do.
But I think if we step back and you look at what you've actually accomplished, the system of support is obviously at a place where people are wondering if it's going to work.
But what we forget is how much we have asked the locals to do.
And if you were to come into this system in 2010 to now, and you're a teacher that just entered the system, you have experienced in 2010 common core standards of VLA and math.
2012 ELD standards in the seal of by literacy 2013 14 the LCFF and LCAP implementation, which all of this requires educating the professionals in the field about what's happening.
In 2014, ELA and ELD framework which was 1400 pages in 2015, the ESA in 2016 global 2030 initiative prop 58 which was a new dual language program.
2017 the California EL roadmap and the new outback assessment.
2018 you had 1718 had the belief modules around the else 2018 you have the US newcomer toolkit around the else in 2019 you had the California practitioners guide to supporting English learners with disabilities.
In 2019 you had the English learner toolkit of strategies that successive put out.
And in 2020 you have the new online LPAC and field testing.
And in 2020 21 you have the alternative LPAC.
That's not counting MTSS, UDL, math, and science.
And we ask ourselves, well, hurry up.
I think if we don't take time to reflect the educators in the system, I think of the teachers that are were in our system.
We were a district that was on the move and we couldn't get to EL training.
Because we had we those are teachers were trying to figure out UDL.
So I think it's just I want to commend you for all that you're doing, but I think it's a great time to just kind of.
Except that the system of support is going to take some time.
So thank you.
Member Burke.
Thank you, Matt.
That's apropos of that.
I think it's important for us to repeat our mantra that from our former president, Mike Kirst, patience, persistence, humility.
I always live by those words and I think it's very important.
I appreciate you going through that inventory because I think we kind of lose sight of that.
And I'll just take a point of privilege, personal privilege and say years ago, I worked at the state level for a former governor not to be named.
And went to work for a school district because I really wanted to work in a school district and fresh off of four major initiatives that we passed at the state level.
Expecting to see on the first day that I stepped foot in that district, everything was underway.
And they looked at me like I'd lost my mind.
And so it was a great lesson for me to think about what we think we're doing at the state and we're doing all these whiz bang things and it's going to happen immediately.
And at least from my experience, it takes a minimum of two years for the information to even permeate at the level.
So that's why I go back to and we should repeat after ourselves.
Patience, persistence, humility.
Yeah.
So briefly, you already heard about my one assignment that I share with Eileen accountability.
We took that up this morning and again, kudos to the department and the board staff for all the work they do around that tomorrow morning.
You'll hear about my second assignment, which is charter schools.
Yeah, we have two appeals that you'll hear a lot about tomorrow.
So that's the end of my report.
So I won't be I think I'm going to match you for information, but I'll try to go a little faster so we can get out.
I know it's a lot of stuff.
Yours is so powerful.
But anyway, Patricia and I both share IQC as an overall liaison to it.
And we were very fortunate to orient and train all the new IQC members in January right after our meeting.
And so we broke they had an organizational meeting where they are all broken up into new subject matter project and assignments.
And so we really have a good committed and the training was just solid.
The CDE has done an amazing job in orienting and training them on what their roles and what the process is.
There will be there's edits to the visual performing arts and the world language framework.
They're out for the second 30 day comment.
They'll come back to IQC.
We will see them in July, just so you know.
And there's ongoing work on ethnic studies.
I think we'll hear a little more about that.
The other thing is we have a math community of practice.
So you might remember that we have in several subject areas where you have a collaboration,
small group of 30 people from around the state that are leaders in say math and in science.
And then they come together three times a year with about 100 members regionally from around the state to work on math or on science.
And actually the meeting at the end of April supposed to be math and science coming together for one day.
So 200 people and then breaking back up.
So that's here and I'll let you know when it's going to be in Sacramento, although we'll see if it's virtual at this point.
So the math community practice met in January 22nd, 23rd, and they actually had a speaker called Rehumanizing Mathematics,
which is really, I think, important to think about that how we think about our work matters.
And so it was a great kind of opening keynote to the group.
WestEd shared some really valuable tools and practices on standards implementation.
I think what we're seeing and that all of us have realized is how long it takes from standards to framework to materials alignment to finally implementation.
So I think WestEd's research has been helpful.
And so they were an important player there.
We do have a concurrence commission that meets twice a year on the subject matter projects.
And you might know that over the years, the budget has been dwindled to almost nothing.
And so there is some money in the governor's budget to enhance their work.
Again, it's not resolved yet.
But what they had a big conversation at the concurrence commission in January about how the subject matter projects need to be sure they're aligned to the priorities of the governor's vision.
And so each project lead actually gave support and what the science project's doing, what the history project's doing.
And then a lot of discussion also about computer science and a desire to have an area of focus in computer science, which is a priority as well.
So you'll hear more about that.
There were a lot of presentations and they had their annual lead learn conference, which Ting reported on.
And that's building capacity of teacher leaders to do really important work.
They'll be meeting at Oakland in June.
The credentialing commission, I just want to do a little bit on special ed.
So the credentialing commission does a lot of teacher performance assessments.
And so there's been a change, particularly around special ed teachers, that all teachers have a core level of instruction, that all teachers in their teacher preparation, what Mary Vixie Sandy calls it, a common trunk in the tree.
So everybody gets the training to deal with all students.
And then there's branches and specialization.
And so that's changed in some of the teacher performance assessments.
But remember, those of us that Matt was talking about, who've been in the system a while, weren't trained that way.
And so really, the whole system is trying to rethink how teachers are trained in capacity and strategies to deal with students with special needs.
The science community of practice met in February.
And so you heard some members talk to us about science.
There's a very strong science community out there trying to really work on implementation of NGSS.
They've been wonderful and very, very helpful.
They have regional teams to deal with sustainable practices, and they are right there helping us.
It's just we have lots of communities of practice and lots of leaders in every area.
But science is very vibrant and very, very committed.
So we were supposed to have a meeting coming up with the science and math leads, but it's going virtual, obviously, because things have changed.
And then L.A. County Office of Ed, like other county offices, kicked off their system of support and I opened it on the differentiated assistance.
And they talked a lot. That's a giant county. That county has 25 percent of the kids in the state of California.
They had to completely reorganize to try to break down their silos to do differentiated assistance.
And to their credit, the energy and the relationships and the resources that they offered were incredibly positive.
And when I talked to districts who were targeted for differentiated assistance, they felt like the county was going in there as a partner in a different way than it might have been in the past.
And they were hopeful. The dilemma was these were districts just some just identified.
They met in February. Testing is going to be in May. Cycle is going to end. And then we start again.
But anyway, they were there and it's a big lot of districts there and working really hard.
So a credit to the county office and their leaders for really trying to reach out.
And then you might remember that in December, the CSU UC State Board CDE came together around climate summit and Kim Patia Bronson went.
And so there was a follow up meeting in March last week talking about what do we do next about climate creating climate warriors and all of our students and how do we help.
So those of you who have been around in the framework process know that in our world, in our history framework and in our science framework, the environmental principles and concepts are in it.
But those we work so hard on those frameworks.
But how long it takes to get those frameworks out to teachers and districts we know is longer than we hope.
And they really want it integrated in teacher prep.
We want it integrated in classroom instruction and we want kids the next generation to be strong climate warriors.
And so that was a discussion.
It all came around to models of curriculum, lessons, teachers being confident enough to be able to work on climate literacy.
But definitely a desire of UC CSU CDE State Board to do that.
How that actually trickles down as we know is easier said than done.
But that just happened and I'm sure we're going to hear a little bit more about that.
So anyway, that ends my report.
Anyway, so with that, if there's any other comments or reports that people forgot to maybe say something, this meeting will be continued tomorrow.
Do we have public comments today?
Because the public comments are tomorrow.
General public comments are tomorrow.
So tomorrow we're going to start at 830.
The meeting's being continued and we're going to meet in closed session to discuss or take action on the case.
Emma C plus versus the state.
OK, so this ends this session.
The meeting is continued till tomorrow.
Do I have to hammer this right?
OK, thank you very much.
Thank you.